I'm not happy with you, you know.
Yeah, I'm the life on, what life on that could be?
Alright, I need to get a chance screen.
I need to get a chance screen.
Why is my iPhone bugging the fuck?
Oh, relax.
What?
I'm bugging out.
Am I getting a chance screen?
Get a chance screen.
No.
No, it's not.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Scuffs already started, boys.
Scuffs already started.
Look, he's a, he has a thing.
He has a thing.
One minute, one month.
I was there to do some, some business things.
God, the freaking scuff is a thing.
What the hell's going on?
The tracker is hating me right now.
Can you hear me?
Have you all seen this?
Have you all heard about this?
Okay, I think I'm going to have to move the iPhone about because what the actual heck?
Can you guys hear the background music or no?
Okay, you can now.
You can hear a bit of Assassin's Creed.
Good morning.
My iPhone is bugging out right as a, I'm pretty sure this can do horizontal.
So not sure why I'm going to absolutely not hold on.
I'm just calibrating, testing left.
No, what the heck?
Can you not see my face?
Sorry, blame the technology.
What's that?
I should have used my loading screen.
Sorry, can't relate.
Couldn't care less.
And something, something.
Oh my God.
Is it because it's dark in this room?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe being a goblin in the dark is a terrible idea for freaking tracking reasons.
Hold on, hold on.
I need to come literally on my hands and knees to plug in this light under my PC.
This is nonsense.
Honestly.
Why can't you see me iPhone?
I'm out of the port?
There are no keys.
Oh my God.
Right, anyway, I've got some good news.
Well, the good news is I've got my first ASMR club coming out.
Right, I've got to lay on.
Here we go, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Right, back and back and back.
Yeah, that's snuffing those.
Why can, can V-tube Studio not handle how you want them?
Why is that going?
Right, I don't think V-tube Studio works at all horizontal.
Oh, fuck you.
You stupid little twat.
First of all, you little prick.
Can it, hun?
Can it not, it can't go horizontal?
I'm confused but I'm ready.
You know what, fuck it, we're just jumping in.
I'll, I'll deal with the tracking issues once, uh, hold on, hold on.
Fuck it.
Okay, there we go.
I'm actually normal.
I don't know why the tracking bugging.
I'm covering up too much of the screen now.
Who's ready for someone's house screen now?
I do believe Asakul is still streaming, so please do support Asakul.
She's still streaming for a white Christmas.
Uh, let me just check before we jump into that.
Need to make sure I've got subtitles on.
Spoken language, English subtitles on.
Oh my god, I'm such a real gamer.
Are you ready?
AC is just ending.
Oh, does she be next?
I think she'd be maybe next.
Her god's EPS soldier.
Yeah.
Right, okay.
Oh, actually this is some, oh wait, no.
I, I did all my like, oh, latest, like tipper and all that if you did a donalink to me.
Oh no.
Oh, you know what?
Fuck it, we're playing Assassin's Creed, man.
Fuck the money.
I want to play Assassin's Creed.
Um, I wanted to say something.
I don't know if you guys would like this, but whenever we play a video game, obviously
there's names in the video game and, uh, as rid for a feature, but to like name people
and chat.
So I want it to be like special congratulations if your name's Desmond, if your name is Sean,
if your name's Rebecca, if your name's Lucy, if your name's Ezio, like in the video game.
I don't know, like maybe only the guy names make sense, but I thought that would be a
bit different.
Um, yeah, special shout out if your name's Desmond.
Uh, wait, that's right, you get a name by me.
Eh, there we go.
Eh, Desmond, that's right, your name is Desmond.
Okay.
I don't think anyone ever expects to wake up one morning and find themselves caught in
the middle of a war between two secret organizations.
I know I do, but here I am.
On one side-
Can you guys hear the game?
Better known these days as exturgo industries.
They're in the business of control.
Politics, economics, knowledge-
Hey Skull, hope you enjoyed your, uh, Tomb Raider, more like Whim Raider after I'm done with
you.
Eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh.
I'm terrible.
Friendsly remainder, we don't have HR, uh, if you-
Did you enjoy Whim Raider, you little E.P. polar bear?
I caught the start of you, shtween.
Don't worry, I'll tell you the lore that you're missing out on, cause I'm rambling on
the top of it.
Ohhhhh.
Oh my God.
Altair.
Not Altair.
The Templars wanted the location of something known as a piece of Eden.
The HR made-
Go out at night!
Nah, you're done.
Go away, manager.
Actually scare me.
They actually can make me graduate.
I always have to be like, my views are not-
They do not reflect the agency, because my views-
Mm-mm, they shouldn't reflect the agency.
Okay.
I was hoping that would be the end of my misadventures.
I have honey tea.
How are the snowberries?
Piece of Eden?
Eden D's nuts.
Okay, that was good.
You're welcome.
Da Frenze!
My ancestors from their insolence, searching for a path forward.
Ahhhhh!
But me!
I'm still here!
Ezio!
Ezio Auditor!
Hey, that's from Assassin's Creed 2.
We're gonna play that Lea-
Okay, I'm gonna play all Eden.
But we're playing Brotherhoods first.
Take me in between the views of the towns,
just to not reflect the agency.
True.
This is my story.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm getting ready.
Oh my god, I'm ready.
I'm so excited to fucking play with you.
I'm sipping my tea.
Tell me if it's too loud or I'm too loud.
But let's be honest, I'm always too loud.
If I'm too big, I might need to make myself smaller.
You know that.
Would you like me small ewe?
Me.
This is a police dog from Mario.
Let me hear.
That's actually the full dialogue.
We got it.
We did the quick time thing.
The bigger the better.
No!
Oh my god, it's a horse feature bird!
Oh my god, it's Oz!
We're Ezio!
Serious hooded man.
Watch this.
You're awesome.
Technical difficulties.
Oh my god.
I couldn't.
This isn't on Xbox Game Pass,
so we're not getting any gamerscore from it.
What's that?
Another reason to play this game later?
Gee, will it hurt?
I have to tell.
Oh, it's General!
Fun fact.
So excited to play.
Who is Desmond?
I don't understand.
Oh, wait, that's not Italian.
Where did that Italian speak?
I'm here, me, Ezio Alditore.
This is my favourite bet,
because it always glitches out.
The fabric always glitches out on his knee in the scene.
It doesn't matter how many times you play through this game,
like it is instance of new glitches going to occur
during the cutscenes,
but it always glitches out on the knee at that cutscene.
It doesn't matter how many times you play it.
Mario, what are you doing here?
Better to be left in the hands of the earth
than in the hands of man.
I can't believe the Pope fucking vanished.
Where's that bloody Pope gone?
Where's that Pope gone?
Sorry, I'm drinking,
and then it makes me do hypnosis.
I'll just get so excited, okay?
Ah, we're being swallowed alive.
A zirgian taste.
It's already occurring.
Are we ready?
Are we ready for the best freaking voice line from Mario?
Better to leave you in the hands of the earth.
Ah, it's such a good freaking quote.
It's an entire anime.
I was worried.
Quick, we have to get out of here.
Okay, so you can't actually jump up
if you do not engage in Eagle Vision.
So we're already in tutorial mode.
If you do not engage in Eagle Vision,
the game will not let you climb up at all.
But until you engage it.
So we're playing Ezio Auditoria da Frenze,
which means he was spawned in Frenze.
We are already an established assassin, okay?
We've just defeated the big bad evil in Assassin's Creed 2.
I'll shut up.
Oh my god, right, okay.
So yeah, we're Italian.
So Babadabopi, oh, that was jokes.
This up next part section.
So we're still in tutorial mode, obviously, the game.
But the reason why I want to mention that we're in tutorial mode
is because the game perfectly is structured.
He's created the sympathy of the only place.
What you're doing.
Oh, that's another good thing.
You condemn what you do not understand.
Right, so we can push people out of the way.
Out of my way, out of my way, out of my way.
Rosary beats up your arse.
Leave me alone.
Away you go.
Mario will actually get caught on those people.
It's quite funny.
That's your uncle Mario.
Uncle Mario.
Okay.
There you go.
My arm would blurted his attack.
Now I want you to remember that pineapple.
For no reason at all.
Remember the pineapple.
All hail the pineapple.
Okay, this next section is how you get one of the easiest
achievements in the game.
And it is perfectly sequenced for you to do so.
So look alive.
This is how you get the...
You haven't...
You're not to get hit.
Oh shit, he knocked them over.
Right, hold on.
You wait for them to attack.
And then if you perfectly execute all these men,
then you get your first achievement,
which I believe is frenzy.
But if you do it perfectly, Mario shouldn't.
Unfortunately, the camera angles are a bit...
No!
I lost this straight because of the freaking camera angle.
Anyway, your first achievement is to kill 10 people in a row.
You could easily do it at that section of the game,
but don't worry if you miss it.
There are many opportunities to do so.
The camera angle will...
Merce you up.
I was going to say,
Merc you up.
The camera angle is a bit funny,
especially when you're in between buildings.
It's telling me to follow Mario.
You must also trail behind Mario a couple of meters.
If you are right behind him,
you will knock him off his coded path.
The AI will fix itself,
and he will go back on the path,
but you must give him space,
or you will knock him off the rooftops,
and then you have to wait even longer
for this section to occur.
But it's fine.
It's not a bad section.
This is to learn mostly rooftop moving about,
how to get your agility sorted.
You kind of get used to holding down.
I recommend...
Oh, see, that's another thing.
Sometimes AI say we will do something.
When you tell him to jump in a certain direction,
it's fine.
This game has aged beautifully,
and I believe this game came out...
2012.
Skyrim was 2011.
Again, you can knock Mario off this
if you're too quick.
You must be careful.
It was 2010.
Oh my God, I was a baby.
I remember asking my dad for this game,
and fun fact,
my dad bought me the special edition,
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood,
and it came in a special box.
If you opened it up,
I had the Assassin's logo on it,
and you opened up the box,
and the game pops up and presents itself, man.
It was freaking good.
Here's another section.
If I continue up,
he does not move.
Are you ready for this?
I'm going to...
Oh no!
You can't progress.
You have to go to the side.
He is in a wall right now
in the tutorial phase.
Yes, my dad gave me it,
and I was so happy.
I was so lucky.
Well, I'm a Sitma fish.
We're holding the apple of Eden.
The page doesn't load if you
click the link in the description.
Did I mess up my own donation link?
Oops!
Oh, this is a beautiful song.
Oh, the theme song.
I think that theme is called
Family Auditore.
It's such a lovely song.
It takes you to just your profile,
but not the tip page.
Eepth.
Can management...
Can you update my link live on the stream?
Thanks, management.
So we are now going back to
Montregion,
which is the home of the Auditore family.
And we've been introduced to cannons.
Finish my tea.
Look how much money.
We have 53,000 Florence,
which was the currency.
Florence, yes.
So we are now heading back
from Il Vaticano,
Roma, with Mario on our little
horsey-worsies.
And we're about to come back
to our family villa location.
You can see that we've got the
Brotherhood, the Assassin's logo
on top.
And we've also got
the Assassin's logo on top,
and Assassin's is very famous in the village.
Because he's kind of the
back-assit.
Assassin's!
I want to meet him!
Please!
Enjoy your meal!
We are going to be home.
These places just keep getting better.
Yes.
So everyone's very happy to see
Assassin's back.
Thanks to you.
And we also renovated this place
in Assassin's Creed 2.
It's your sister!
Claudia.
I'm so glad to see you with my own eyes.
The Contessa afford me to
welcome you.
The Contessa?
Here?
June, you're truly dead.
She has a really, like,
good but bad voice line at later
section.
But it ruins it
if you've not played this game.
So, we are assigned
three.
I repeat,
three little side quests here,
and it just kind of shows you,
you know, you can walk around,
you can walk around in the game.
If you hold the trigger,
you will do...
Oh!
A bit of degradation there, mate.
That'll do.
Did you know,
to say,
push in Italian?
Spingy!
Oh, also,
it shows a bit of a...
a bit of a slag.
A bit of a Waman's man.
A bit of a slag.
But then, anybody, then, anybody.
We'll make sure he gets his whole...
Oh, that's actually Scott!
A second teacher!
To say get your whole
means to
punk a girl.
Yes.
Sorry.
No one in Town Watch
who's such a burden.
I am sure
it's the only self
to be proud.
You know,
he's this big.
Rizio Auditori
defends
it for Renzi,
for real, for real.
You?
The party
was supposed to be a secret!
Well, that's what happens.
Loose lips and all that,
both bottom and top, hen.
Several things.
Hey!
She is offering us
gratitude
and services
to keep her sealed.
She won't be sealed
once I'm
in the room.
I don't know what she's like.
So we have to
complete her first quest.
Oh, she's touching her chest!
Nipple stimulation.
Oh, it's always tomorrow
with you lassies.
It's never now.
It's never...
Like, come on,
let's go behind the dumpster.
Always the motto
with lassies, man.
Can I trust them?
The link in description
has been up to you.
Just make sure
in OBS
you have the audio set
to monitor.
Sure.
I'll totally do that.
One
out of
three
side quests, okay?
So you're supposed
to do the flower girl
first, okay?
Because she drags you
into the villa,
like up to the villa, okay?
Fancy a shag
from A.C.W. himself.
Can I do an Italian accent
with the Scottish slang?
Fancy a shag?
No, I didn't.
It just sounds like
fancy a shag.
No, no toilet time.
Oh,
Mario's going to murder me.
I have lost
his favorite horse.
Ah!
You're tipping!
Wait, I didn't hear it, though.
I see the tip.
I saw the tip.
Oh, hold on!
Wait, I just bet
if you run ahead of the horse,
you can actually get the horse
first time in the tutorial section.
Keep running, keep running,
keep running.
And then if you're Prince Pampi,
beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep,
aw, we missed it.
You can get it
first time in this tutorial section.
I'll open up
the stream elements
so I can see he just tipped.
Oh, my God.
This frickin' horse
he always jumps around.
Get on the...
Okay, there we go.
Horsespeed Tubers,
dominated.
Check.
Ta-da!
But you can't do that.
World record pace ruined.
Wait, so did you guys
hear any notification
of that tip?
I need to go read it.
Hold on.
Oh, my game paused!
Oh, my God.
Such a professional streamer,
by the way.
Stream elements.
Okay, stream elements,
sign in.
We hear it.
You don't.
I did hear it.
Oh, you heard it.
Was it loud?
I need to turn it down.
Oh, no!
I don't have my login
for stream elements.
I can connect it
to my YouTube.
Management that connected
to my YouTube?
Or is it...
No, wait,
that doesn't sound right.
No, it should be connected
to YouTube.
Stream elements should be
connected to YouTube.
Yes.
Okay.
If the stream goes down,
it's because I'm a fanny.
Full stop.
That is the same.
Uh...
Can I...
Hey!
Wait.
Uh...
Wait a minute.
Right!
Why is it showing me
people subscribed
to the YouTube channel?
Terrible.
Well, it's good that you subscribe,
but it's clogging up
the frickin' thing.
Right.
Save.
I see it!
I see tips!
I see snowpots as well.
Ta-ha.
Get it?
Anyway, sorry.
Thank you so much.
6.9.
Assassin's Creed Battle Hood.
Thanks for playing this game.
Uh...
Why are you re-thinking me?
This is literally my favorite game.
Uh...
Someone called Bajinga
works now.
Okay.
Congratulations for the four.
Thank you for the tips.
I really appreciate it.
Uh...
Right, okay.
Straight back into the fun
with just...
You spend as much time in battle
as your Uncle Mal.
My battles have already won.
I see.
That is good news.
Arrivederci has...
Arrivederci!
Sorry.
Are you squirming me right now?
Right.
So, you're like...
So, the next objective
is up there
and you'll be sitting yourself.
Uh...
I am gonna have to really
annoyingly
walk up all these buildings,
climb them up.
Eh, no.
The game is kind enough
to give you these sandbags.
Up the sandbags you go.
Right.
Why can I not hear notifications?
I'm actually gonna miss donations
if I don't have the sound on.
Just give me a second.
I'll just...
Uh...
Uh-huh.
Yep.
I know what I'm doing.
Uh-huh.
Advanced options.
Okay.
Hear me out.
Monitor.
Monitor only.
Monitor and output.
That sounds right.
Yeah.
Um...
Hopefully I'll hear it next time
if someone is...
Wait.
I can repeat the donation
like a five-head.
Oh, I missed a donation!
Anonymous said,
how's your day's drawing?
I'm fucking pop-champ.
Hold on.
I'mma test this if I can hear this.
Are you squirming me right now?
I hear it!
Okay.
I will know when people
are kind enough to tip.
Thank you for the tip.
Can you guys do 20 blazes?
How's your day?
You're squirming me right now.
You're freaking poll-grows, man.
Can I write something agency?
What'd you say?
About the agency?
Why doesn't it not display your message?
I'll need to update that later.
I don't think I can do it right now.
Anonymous, congrats, congrats you lozoni
on your debut.
Good luck to you.
Thank you.
Are you squirming me right now?
That was 50!
Why are you giving me 50?
That's a lot of money.
That's like...
That's...
I'm gonna be honest. That's a lot of money. You need to be careful giving me a lot of money
Cuz I'll just spend on the girls
Thank you 50s a lot though, please be
Came to your pockets and you know save for your future and all that
Yeah
Okay, back into the game I apologize, but thank you for the 50 thank you everyone for the tips honestly
So per SEO thinks he's retired after his escapades and Assassin's Creed 2 has ended
Brotherhood's about to give him a very terrible wake up call
So we're no getting the cannon master to fix the canons
It's AC oh, thanks for being one of you may see appreciate I think she's asleep right now
I'm hiding up the chat by accident. I'm sorry, please be patient. I am how do you say
Richard thank you
Wait, why can't I open up the game now? Oh, I cannot be this bad, please I cannot be this bad at streaming
Hold on right there. But now I can't see myself. Oh, you know what? You know what? You know what?
Okay, okay, okay, I can now see the messages. I can now see myself and I can see chat
So I won't miss a thing
Surely won't miss a thing surely surely call me surely temples didn't call me strong. It calls
Okay, I can see donors if I miss them I can see chat I can see Assassin's Creed
Oh
Are you squid me right now?
Brove
What makes you think I can even read that?
It's your auditory the forensic has hit me. Thank you
Joe Mikar I'll read it over after the sections
I believe it
Can I tell you a sad story actually really cried like I cried squid me right now?
Hey
Right, I'll read the the random Italian this person thinks I could think I can see
Thank you for listening to my Italian
Oh
El car yes, well, I gotta give
To compliment again on your heart love the accent by the way. How many times did you play the game to know it so well?
The answer is I actually couldn't even count how many times I've played this game
No, anything killing us is that breath
Take a drink of war
Did you saw my mother in Italian? Okay, one of my biggest pet peeves about this game
The freaking cannons. So you see how the hit markers there?
It looks like you're gonna hit it and the cannons are like way loud in this game. They're like far too loud
They're insanely loud
My my foul-ass breath
The guy sounds like a Skyrim guard most video games reuse
Voice actors, so you will recognize people over and over again
It's very common if you work in a video game that you will be used for NPCs for example
Or just miscellaneous characters all the time very common Skyrim is probably the biggest example of like the same seven voice actors
Being used over and over again
Other than Cicero and Skyrim shout out to Cicero and Skyrim can't remember the actual guy's name
But goodness greatly
He said hi my dear it's rare to see one so beautiful and so talented. Maybe you can teach me a beautiful
Wait, you can't even speak English and you like my accent, bro. You're gonna be in for a shock
My favorite oblivion line. Oh, let me retake that. Let me redo that in the left in the game
Okay, we have now just finished all our three side missions. We have just handled the cannons. Hmm suspicious
I wonder why we have also been able to ride a horse. That's because in later parts of the game horse riding is very
Necessary to X
To explore certain locations and it's just not possible on foot is partly you can do it
but it just takes up so much time and
We also help the lady which established that it's a auditory is a bit of a bit of a ladies man
And he's out for ladies holes. I mean we're all out for the ladies hole at the end of the day
Hey, hold
This is outrageous
By Zura by Zura by Zura
There are two major hubs of English voice actors to go from
So this is Katarina sports. She is a real person
Did occur a very badass personality
Based on a real person
We're like Katarina do Fanny cuz we're getting her
That's her mummy
That's Marquia Valley recurring character
I wish I could show you the magic she performed very good
Moving painting of the goddess Minerva spoke
Don't have a terrible tragedy to befall mankind in the future
Give hope of lost temple that will provide a to humanity
Then she called out to a phantom desmond as if you were there
After her warning she vanished
I
Cannot imagine such wonders
Did not house the terrible wet food fear this is good news
Did she appear human yes, but her words proved otherwise
All of her kind died many years ago. I wish I could show you the magic she performed all of the good delivery good delivery
Where are these temples Minerva spoke up?
Do not know perhaps we must search for them
Tell me how it ended for you did Rodrigo beg forgiveness. Make excuses from his power
No, none of those things the script pulled off another one. I got you pulled up another
Just watching the mirror on her the spaniards
Oh
Some of the voicelines are a bit goofy
Damn straight you don't come Mario here real one
That's me your uncle Mary
Maria auditory as your mummy big mummy kins. Did you know actually that's a bit sad
Maybe not and we'll just continue to the next part of the sequence. Oh, right ready everyone group session right now everyone get out
Not for this bit the bit that follows after hold on
Wait for it wait for it
See this is what happens when you pay for the premium pass at the VL or meet and greet booth
You're presented with a bathtub and then this part is me. That's you okay. That's you in the bathtub. This next bit is me
Yeah
Oh, this for a hundred dollars for the premium pass. Yes, please
Coming at you in my bikini
Welcome home reflin in my accent. Obviously. I'll have to play really put on my accent. Welcome home reflin
Mom is
Do you think a con we would let us have a meet a booth that would be hilarious
Forgot about that part of the scene. Oh, oh
Like what happens in the ASMR booth stays in the ASMR booth everyone sh okay
Fun fact I played this game in front of my mom and she was mortified at this scene because I was very very young
And I remember playing it at midnight and I had the dining room chair in front of the TV
My mom let me play it on the big TV
And she was like, what are you playing now? Like it's a sad that's great
Mom, please. I didn't make the game
One should always have the freedom to choose. Oh so salty so salty
Yeah, damn train and exercise is out of control
Put in the ass
Actually, that's another side note
I remember why my dad needed to spell
Oh, I was telling my dad about like some of my favorite games of all time like a couple of years back now
He was like, how do you spell assassin? I was like ass ass in and we both looked at each other like that shrek meme like
Like burst out laughing
Such children honestly
I'm not I'm not gonna lie if I felt like that my ankles would be gone. They would be dust
Okay, this is the worst part of the game that's about to come up because you can do everything right and the game will still fail you
So Mario has the apple of Eden
The one Italian like oh my god, she really likes assassins
My goodness
Uh to say help and uh, oh no, we lost our monies. It's not about the money money money
Forget about the money money money
Uh, you do not actually have to do anything the horse will automatically run for you in this sequence
So
The entire town is now being absolutely destroyed and raided and I'm currently singing that one Scottish song
All the horses get back up in this video game
I just what for anyone who doesn't like when the horses go down and with you with that
The horses always stand back up in video in this video game
No horse ever stays down even if it's been attacked if it's been hurt la la la la
Okay, this is the part I hate you can destroy
All the cannons and all the freaking towns people won't escape and you can fail the section
I have done it consecutively
All you have to do is destroy the cannons ignore everything else
But the freaking it's really hard to tell. Yeah, see I should have hit that third one
But it's really hard to tell like with the edges of like the radius your
Area of effect if you will and my goodness gravy it's frustrating
No horses were harmed in the production of this video game. No, they're not so
Please don't worry. All horses get back up
The aoe area of effect is it's so freaking hard to tell because you could perfectly angle it and you're like
I should have three but yeah
And especially the ones on the hill this oh
Beautiful beautiful
Do that again Hen do it again do it again do it again. Give us three. Oh, baby
Right, so unfortunately you can't really do much more after you've killed this one
Boom, baby
Okay, next section we've got to do this bit correct because this is where you can fail
The problem with the hill is you have to like judge behind the cannons. Oh triple, baby
Let's go three for three. Obviously. We can't do it for this one because it's not third, but we've got three for three so far
Okay, wait what that one survived. Hello
Uh
Use me excuse a moi
Do my eyes
So this is the problem. You can't really hit those ones
Now you might be saying you should hit that big brown thing. I've forgotten what their legal name is
But the big brown thing doesn't count
Uh, we can kill it. We've done what we can
So either we'll fail or we'll win depending on what the game feels like see there's 20 villagers 10
five
We did it. We didn't get a ballista a siege tower. I
Soldiers are climbing the walls
Okay, this is one bit. I don't like about this game. You ready for this
They change your weapons. So they've given me a sword. I've said, uh, let me keep my blade out because
I prefer fighting with a blade the only
Enemies that you're not to go against with the blade jump down. Oh, jeez
Yeah, my ankles would be disintegrated if I did that
um
It's much easier to fight with the blades. Oh my god
He just curbstomped that borgia guy. Did you see that encio? That's a war crime. You can't curbstomp people
That's not how it works
Jesus etio
Okay, hold on
These enemies. Oh my god, I just got twatted. Oh, I'm getting twat twice. Sorry. I'm too busy trying to be chatting
Kill at the same time. Um, no, I'm missing. Oh, no, everyone's gonna know I'm a terrible gamer
Um, the only enemies that are not effective. So like these guys for fuck's sake
They freaking attack before they're supposed to you can break their stance just by spamming. It's not a problem
Again, you for these guys that are double armored up literally take your gun out boom
It didn't register it. See, oh, he's getting a bit close mate. You're gonna need to aim
That was kind of it close for comfort
Point blank etio that probably wasn't even five meters. No been do we need to put glicks on them?
Oh, this is a sad bit
Of assassins
This is an invitation my family to yours
I
Like that part
There is a sentence that he said though that your friend this gun that your friend fashioned for us keep that in mind
I can walk faster means to stop in Italian
So we are now
Basically running on fumes adrenaline wise. We've literally just been absolutely
Destroyed we have three bullet wins. I think shoulder
Uh abdomen. Oh, okay. Just to show we've got two bullet wins. I could have sworn it used to be three
But I'm probably just wish me remember being
Uh, but yeah, we've literally our liver is currently bleeding out our kidney most like ow. What happened there?
Did you see me get turned into that rubbish pile? I was like liquid. Did you see that?
Ouch, I don't want to be jelly. Please don't turn me into jelly
Hey leaf cloudia lonia bam
So you'll get assigned one soldier to kill in the sequence, but they all do they all are aggressive towards you
You can clean them up if you really desire
But if the arrow is red that means the ai has assigned to attack you if the arrow is yellow they'll attack
Oh, also the guards have assassin abilities. Look how he's sitting on the wall
The coding in this game is a bit funny. Um, if you upset NPCs, they turn into assassins and start climbing walls
and stuff
You could always break a guard stance with a kick if you are struggling to fight them
But we do get access to long range weaponry very shortly. Um
But yeah, uh, you can ignore all these I think and just go straight in here. No you can't
You have to wait until they're assigned to you. Okay. Okay. Okay. The game does it quite often where it won't
Let you in
If someone is target locked onto you
Hey, come on Claudio ain't go all day. Jesus. We're under a siege. Take your time hen
Ezio, I'm in here. I will hold the back. Stop wait for us
We thought you had to kill sir Ezio. Not yet. Where does this passage lead to the north outside the walls?
Are you surprised it exists? I might have to open my door. Um, I must go help the troops
My freaking room is getting so hot with this computer
Ah
I'm coming. So we're currently inside the Auditori villa. We're now going down down down down deep inside
Down deep inside see how do you pick me?
I'm sweating um, I'm sitting on my sweaty feet right now. I don't know how you guys sit in your chairs, but I sit on my feet
Oh
We will play Assassin's Creed 2 because that is a very beautiful section in Assassin's Creed 2
We're essentially playing Assassin's Creed 2.5. It's fine brotherhood's good game
Right lore lore. I'm gonna take a war sip water sipping then take a sip with me if you're not got war
Oh
The horse was a paid actor
I'm not flexible enough to sit on your feet. I'll make you flexible once I've done me
Sorry
Hmm
We're actually speedrunning
Just love this game all over everything about it. The patience fantastic. We've completed sequence dna one
Battle wounds achievement unlocked
Lucy, I can't seem to get a position
Poe could one of you tell me what's going on
Sorry
I will tell you at the end a very sad fact about that blonde girl you see on the screen right now
But only at the end
Right, so that says in present day
Congrats if your name's Desmond
Congrats
Congrats if your name's Sean Sean's one with glasses. Congrats
I'm convinced we need to get our hands on Ezio's apple of Eden
Minerva altered it somehow when she are the tame traveling
We're at the Alti Torre Zilla. I will tell you in a second. It's our last safe, but we were present day
It turns out the Templars are watching the border
Ezio hid the poe sometime in 1507, but when I try to access that dna sequence
He seems to be remembering something else
Like a memory inside a memory. Yes, exactly
Maybe exactly maybe I believe you experienced something similar back at obstaga, didn't you?
Subject 15 exhibited memory within memory like patterns, but she was pregnant
The memories of prego's father and mother not in this was
Desmond's not pregnant
Oh my god, we've just been fat shamed in 2024
You guys remember when Bal got that model and she was like inflated and someone was like
This is fat shaming. I was like, no, bro. That's real 34 open your eyes
That's crazy that either that or rebecca's is not a very good engineer. Thanks asshole
Imagine coming out with an inflation model and someone's like you're fat shaming. No mother fucker
Ages ago the waves go through everything above brown. They're gonna find us. No, they aren't come with me
Oh
There's a lot of cutscene stuff up ahead, but I'll try and for those who don't know the game I will very quickly summarize
From the inside we're not getting in this way
What's her next move the road just moves back into the highway. This is not a good place for us to be right now
Do we have any tarps? We need to cover up the van. I really hate to stress this yeah, but we are running out of time
That's Sean. We'll help us. That's Rebecca. That's Lucy any ideas?
I don't know. Maybe there's another way into the sanctuary. Hey, I think I've got something
Okay, so we're modern-day Desmond if you don't know the game
Uh, we basically have a special bloodline
That commutes to the gods that created us
Um, and we use Desmond's DNA sequence in order to go back in the past very fictional based. Uh, I
Absolutely loved the concept when I was a child and I wanted it to be so real
I was like take me back to the battle of anaconda
Take me to big willy walrus
I want to see the construction
So we are like the trunk. I'm sorry. I don't know what the trunks are
Memories are stored in DNA. Yes. That's the quickest way. Oh my god me and Lucy
Oh
Oh, yeah, you know how to have fun you'll have fun with me the night Lucy
Okay, there we go. Oh, that was a loading screen by the way, it looked like it wasn't they were trying to hide it
What was that?
So Desmond also sees the past because his it's basically leaking into his present
So Lucy can't see any of this we can see this
They escaped through here what that's you and the villagers after the attack I can see them now
I know it's difficult, but try to compartmentalize focus on the present
What if I can't stop the visions?
How long before I start painting symbols on the walls?
Don't joke about that. Subject 16 had the bleeding effect that he's talking about and ended up in himself
But we learned more about him in Assassin's Creed 3
Well the animus he does to a man
Please do not refer to the animus that lets us go back into the past is the animus
Oh
Is a revelation not unless you want me to end up like that skeleton always
I'll find a way around
Always revelations, you're right. Sorry, my apologies. I apologize
I would say this is a revelation
Do you guys remember Dan bull's cover of Assassin's Creed Brotherhood revelations?
I meant if you see any
So we are now backtracking our way of sort
This is the problem. There's so much dialogue in this game at the start
And we are now backtracking trying to get back inside the villa
Oh no, Claudia, that's our sister
Just joined. Why is he wearing jeans? We're in present day. Actually. Yeah, could you jump about in jeans?
I don't even wear jeans. I don't even wear clothes after time actually
Do you want to guess what clothes I'm wearing right now? Because it's not what you think
Okay
We are selling tutorials, so it's a bit slow, but
Um, I just wear a bra and a hoodie
That's it. So my bear arms is on my game and chair right now with my sweaty feet as well
They never stop sweating neither do my hands. My hands are very sweaty right now actually, but they don't sweat as much as my feet
I'm sorry. I don't I don't think I don't care. I'll show up about that
Oh my marriage
Oh, I have marriage oopsies forgot to talk about that. I have marriage if you want to support me
I'm getting key chains with the girls and we're I'm going to make a little key chain ASMR
So the thing about this cutscene you have no health so you can literally just do that
You can't die in this cutscene in this section of the game
It's not a cutscene. It's a section again. You can just drop down
When did this become I wish I wish you
Nice try ready
God well, do you see such a skinny legend on this one found a switch
Oh, no, no don't do that. That's morey. Here we go
Something's open
Yeah, my leg. Hey, yo
Absolutely brain
So he shouldn't have said this line yet because
Oh
I've never had that happen before I got pushed out the way by the shadow
Oh my god, I've never had that happen before the shadows are freaking I wonder if you can attack the shadow
I've never been pushed out the way by the shadow before
See this is the thing about playing the same game over and over something you'll happen every time and it's just fantastic
Anyway, we're about to swim in medieval toxic waste
The game's being coded as you play
Toxic waste it was Lucy's idea
Oh
You're exaggerating
Whoa, whoa, uh, see when the camera angle start to shift it actually makes things like really hard to judge
It's good for the skin
Remember the that one post where that guy was like
For $500 let me go in your septic tank and he just hangs out in there and does the thing and it was like, oh you're
I mean
Yeah, that was quite the post
Wait
You're going so fast the game can't keep up
That was minging honest
Oh my god, it's you no it's you Desmond. Did you just ask a woman why she's not wet?
That's sexual harassment, honestly water check
Oh, I just fell water. Oh well, it's fine
I'm sorry. It like cold water just went on my leg and I'm like, ah, you know, that's fine. It's actually not that big a deal
Jesus, you know, that's brutal making someone fall to their death
Now I'm wet. I'm a cuttlefish. I was wet from the start
Human resources. Why is septic tank? It's just what the guy wanted. It's like that Japanese post
Oh, this is another thing. There is this is a true
hashtag
story
and
So this wife went away on holiday for the weekend
And her neighbor on Friday
went into her like toilet tank
Like Japanese toilets are different from the way it's like done
So he could look up and peep at her while she disintegrated basically
Um and because she went away on holiday, uh, that man
perished
via
I'm freezing to death in kaka
I was like, bro
Don't get me wrong. I'm no really
Shame in anyone for what they like, but to die
To die
I'll wait here. It's a bit extreme
It's a bit extreme
Oh g-san messed up on that one. I'm not gonna lie. Oh g-san
Yeah
Did they scatter his ashes?
That's too funny that I can't even laugh at that. That's awful. That's awful
Oh my god, that was so quick-witted
Damn
Thanks
Anyway, the sequence is just teaching us the relationship that et-sio has with lucy
Ed Desmond has with lucy jesus. I have the bleeding effect myself
No, no before you freaking take that out of context. The bleeding effect is when Desmond thingy's
Oh, uh, Veechabur's stomach is sore. It must mean they're they're just a ketchup packet. No
Stop it with the ketchup packet allegations. Okay
Veechabur's can't beat them enough. My goodness
Veechabur feels mildly ill. Oh, she must be a ketchup packet. You stop that right now naughty naughty
Stop it
It's all right, I'm a mustard pat it comes out yellow. Hello
Oh, should I be worried? Do we need to get you a doctor?
When the past memories and new ones melt in yes Desmond has a very hard time
Differentiating himself from et-sio because he spends so much time in the animus as et-sio. I mean you'd do it too
You'd do it too. You'd do it too. All right friendly over the section
Oh my god, it's the back of the statue
Repeat after me stat you that's how you say statue in scots stat you
No tea stat you
Oh, I guess there is a tea technical
Well, I'm as if you die in the animus and you just perish
No tea I've finished
Wow weapon ice gets free
True
Et-sio must have come back here way after the attack
But why
Desmond
Desmond let's open that door. I think big dizzy. Here's like, hmm big easy big as you all the touring
You have any fizzy juice, no, I might get a cola later, but right now I'm I'm high. I'm high is okay
I'm literally playing my favorite game of all time. I'm allowed to just word vomit and do whatever I please
Life is good. Bruv. Bruv. Life is good. I'm happy. I hope you know this experience is enjoyable
Don't apologize about burps. I don't burp much with water, but hey
Can you open the damn bookcase Desmond says Sean as I cut over his voiceline
Yes, et-sio has three things
Assassin's Creed to Assassin's Creed brotherhood and Assassin's Creed revelations are all et-sio elder towards storyline
Numbers Mason. Oh my god, we need to play black ops
In 1421
Oh my head, are we? That's all right Desmond has a boo boo
Let's get the animus down there
You're gonna create an entire corporal weirdo. Hey
Uh, um was watching the everyone's 2.0's
Uh lurking in the shadows
I'm so happy. Make sure you aren't followed
What is that smell?
It's my clothes. It was Lucy's idea. I smell like you swam through a sewer
It was Lucy's idea. It was Lucy's idea. Wait a second guys. You need to remember the there's a line right?
Is that confliction in his voice going? That's the word
Oh
My name rule one suck you are the king
Oh the girls they're absolutely fantastic in their 2.0's absolutely adore them
um
like
Obviously, I'm happy to talk about like some behind the scenes stuff
But like they were kind of shocked that I'm like, yeah, just do what you want
Like whatever you want go for it. You can say what you want
Obviously, as long as you don't see any nda content, you can talk about the interview with me if you want
You can talk about how you found the process
Talk about how you found debut
Um, yeah, just do what you want and have fun. I'm here to be a booty hole
Right look around Montoregioni for circuitless
That little dude asked they'll re-wrote small amounts of electricity to the power line underneath the villa
Don't ask me how they work if I understood that I wouldn't be the fellow hide in the van
I
Used to think
He is he Wheatley?
I think he might be Wheatley. I'm not sure from
a
portal to
So we're now currently getting an energy supply to the animus underneath the villa
In order for upstairs go the big baddies are called upstairs go in this game or templates. Those are the big baddies
Um, so basically you just need to go around the city
You can see that the patched everything up from the uh five centuries ago
That the big old fights were occurring. I really like stacey milk. Yeah
I saw the reaction to fondle a bosom
Admit that it was funny. Okay. Admit that it was funny or pick up 24 cards in uno right now
And anyone sitting with 24 cards in their hand are liars. Okay fondle a bosom was hilarious. I don't care
I think someone was like it sounds like you're naming them from like that parody
um
That parody movie
Uh austin powers and I'm like, yeah, you're supposed to have fun names. Who wants serious names that like no one can remember
like
Cuttles cuttlefish. Okay, so any cuttles. Let's go. Uh, a polar bear. Okay. I see I see still pause. Yes. She has pause
And she's cold. I see stop us. Let's go
Like it's really it's not that bad
Um, so you're supposed to just look around with eagle vision to get a sense of moving around. Um
And all that jazz there's like one right next to me. Isn't there yet? It's right behind me. Uh box
I vana humpullo
Hey
That was not a name karambi. No karambi for like a cs gov each of her
Perfect name. Don't care karambit. Yes
And karam sounds like haram so you can probably make a few puns
Yes, it's booted
Name from money python's life of brian incontinent above
African saw you's all laughing at it and someone posted that incontinent to a screenshot
I was like, oh no, they've got me laughing. I was like, oh, that was actually really funny
All right, we're going in the animus
We're about to go back into the past to be it's your auditory if we're still in the tutorial stage
I will tell you when we get out of this tutorial stage. Uh, we've still probably got another hour and a bit
sanctuary
As you may have noticed in the van, I've made some improvements to the animus and have a new vr training program
Here you can show off all those flashy moves you picked up from your ancestors
Let me open one in the mission
AC show
AC hall
Okay, but it doesn't make sense. Maybe if we had like a fire and ace like v tripper just saying ac
No, we can't like call ac. We already have ac. Oh, oh shit. Okay. So this is the virtual training. I despise it
I absolutely despise it
I just cannot stand this section. It's for people who enjoy the combat or practicing it me
I hate it. I despise it. Okay. You see that skinny guard? He is a problem
They can grab you. Yeah, see the guards are trying to grab me and then it breaks your streak if they grab you and so annoying
I freaking hate the we guards. Honestly. Oh, and I hate the Lancers too. I absolutely hate it. I'm much better in combat
Yeah, fuck you. Take it
Take it the Lancers have much bigger reach and are very hard to counter
So when you're on a killing streak it's much better to aim for those guys to defend your streak basically
Skinny ball bad guards. Oh, honestly
Lancer hates the skinny guards hate because they are agile warriors
And you have to freaking have a wee knife out in order to counter them properly
Shrimp check. Yep posture still shrimp. Thank you
Oh, we're in the tutorial for like another two hours
But the reason I'm going to praise the game is because it's hidden that you're in the tutorial
You progress through the story of the game via the tutorial like I know that sounds silly to praise that because obviously all games work like that but
I'll kind of
You can leave the machine whenever you like
I'm all set to go. Don't worry
One last thing as you raise your synchronization by executing events
repressed memories
You might even discover some repressed memories. She be caught in bottom. Okay, let's get started
Ass and feet locked on that seat. Oh, that's actually a really good like model
Ready for like an eight hour stream
Ass and feet get on that suit
Anyway, I never expected you to see you play something. I have terrible news, but these should personally play a video game
Subjects, dude
Okay, we're here present day
Give me one second. I'm gonna get a cola. Okay, I'll leave it on so I'm least I'm not yapping over the actual cutscenes for once
Oh
Sorry, I forget my hip. I need to close my eyes if I walk away so the sleep thing clicks on right but
Come on me. Come on me. Oh my god. Listen to the music
Beautiful
Oh gorgeous
Roma
Yes
I just got chills
Such an idiot. I just love this game so much
I just feel like so full of it like my heart feels so full. I get to share this game and
Just appreciate it for what it is and this game come out in 2010
And it aged beautifully. I will not tell I will not take anyone telling me this game didn't age well
So we're currently injured and going to the doctor. We're about to learn about health bar. So we're still injured
We're still hurt
In the top left corner. We have five health squares and only one left
That is how we deal with health in the game. Do not take that horse
I don't know why they put that horse there unironically
You don't go any faster on the horse to get to the healer
Trying to tip you it says internal server. It's okay. You don't have to give me money. Just hanging out. It's fine
Hey, I'm not sure about the problem is but hey
But don't worry. You don't have to give me money. Thank you very much
For a man of your age. Tisk, tisk
Four out of five doctors would suggest leeches
No leeches
However, I can recommend several good colleagues around the sea
Do you need anything else?
Have fun at work. Don't worry guys. If you ever have to leave stream. I am an endurance streamer. I'm not very friendly
Long time streamer. Um, I do plan on streaming for eight hours or finishing the
Story mode of this game and tomorrow we will 100% it because I've never 100% of the game before but with your
Encouragement, I think it's possible. I think I could 100% this game
When you collect all the board your tower like the flags
um
All the hidden flags that are also in the halls of nero, which I will teach you all about very shortly
So this
Beautiful cutscene is how we unlock sections of the map on the HUD. Okay, they're all hidden at the moment
But we are going to be doing map update as you can see
Uh synchronized view points beauty beauty beauty
It talks on you. I'm listening at work. Oh my god. Oh, those are the naughty naughty
Stinky borgia
We don't like borgia. We don't take kindly to your kind around these parts borgia
100% in this game in two days possible. Yes, sir with autism anything is possible
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I apologize
Um
I am very passionate about what I'm passionate about and if I am like unable to do so
So ie I can just straight up like play this game the way I want to then yes
We're also like 100% in skyrim next week achievement one
I'm so sorry. It must be like really weird. Just randomly come out with it. I'll
We'll refer to the strontism. How about that? So we're currently tailing. Do you see the yellow hit marker or hitbox above these?
This is tailing. It means do not be discovered by them
They can be pushed by NPCs so they can turn around and look at you. It's not um
It's not the best but it certainly works perfectly well
It's absolutely beautiful game
So we're just entailing these guards don't look backwards unless an NPC kindly bumps into them
So we can get as close as we want. We can like creep on the walls
Cece he just turned around there if I wasn't creeping on the wall
Even the game's like uh, you should maintain your distance. You're a bit too close, but we can like creep
Creeping
Okay, and you can also blend in but I am not controlling the movement of this crowd
The crowd will go on a certain path so you can part ways but you cannot be discovered
While concealed in a crown like this guards can walk by me
I can have high notoriety and guards will ignore me as long as I am
100% in the achievements in skyrim, sorry
I don't mean 100% in skyrim because that is impossible as you said because of the repeating quest factors
The achievements I have 100% at skyrim achievements
Uh multiple times and I would absolutely love to share the experience with you and tell you about all the secret
little bits I know
And yeah, okay
I'm also going to mention the multiplayer and brotherhood. I believe the servers are down
Okay. Oh, whoa. That just came out nowhere. Hold on. Hold on. We weren't even at the we were not even at the section
Okay, we didn't even go
We were
And see I didn't kill civilians. Did I kill a human?
Like a non-guard
What is going on?
Oh my god, sorry. The sequence was not supposed to start on that staircase
It's supposed to start by the freaking did I kill him if I'm a citizen?
Uh
What just happened? I think I was too distracted. I apologize
But don't worry. We can always replay and come back for 100%
I can't believe I just killed a citizen
I never make that mistake in this game
Sorry
I too have lost family to the rope
Treachery you called you cuddled off
When you are what the fuck go down
Sorry, you guys didn't see that all these options just popped up on my screen
I was like, these are too many things going on right now. Okay, so
This quest do you see how we are assigned someone with a name?
That is because you're actually killing multiplayer characters
That are in multiplayer. I know it sounds silly and I know it sounds bizarre, but
When you could play Assassin's Creed brotherhood multiplayer
You got to pick between the skins and we're literally about to kill someone who is a skin in the multiplayer mode
100% for this one is just air assassination. Super simple and easy
The guards do attack you but some turn into cowards once you kill multiple guards, which is a lovely
PayPal support doesn't open for several hours
Did I break PayPal?
Oops
Are you guys trying to support me too much that we broke PayPal?
Wait, can none of the girls get donations right now?
Uh, so you can be grabbed but as I said the more guards you kill some of the weaker ones
Like the ones with just a hat will turn into cowards, which is an absolutely lovely human detail
Yeah, see the ones with those like beret type hats they turn into cowards
Beautiful
Beautiful detail. I think that is gorgeous to show human nature instead of the AI
Just being like constantly attack attack attack die die die because you will I just think these are and this is 2010
Development was 20 2008 2008 maybe even as far back as 2007
Um, so you're not allowed to scale the rooftops
Because guards find you extremely sussy, but guards on the floor don'ts like this guy does not care about me right now
um
But like for development that far back to like capture
To even think outside the box to capture human nature like that definitely hats off to the development team
Um, I know it is by ubi soft and there are some very there's a very unique
Ending to this tale and Assassin's Creed brotherhood and I couldn't for the life of me
There's a feather up on here by the way
You can grab
Sightings if you cite something but can't grab it you can go into ego mode and then it'll automatically stick to your map
Which is fantastic. So if you see something but you can't grab it in the moment. Um,
But yeah
This game has also been rated
In the top 100 games of all time
I believe it placed around 60th on recent 100
Game ranking type things
But Assassin's Creed brotherhood always makes it and I 100% agree for me it is first place, but I'm biased
But absolutely deserved it. So we have met marquiovelli. This is marquiovelli. He was the guy
Um, that was in the villa and that was disappointed in us not killing the spanyard
Uh, and he is gonna tell us what's going on in roma because we don't know what's going on in roma
We know the borja is everywhere as we can see them literally in front of us right now
So we are going to get the dirty details on what's going on in roma
Yeah
Borja hate we hate the borja
I'm gonna burp is that okay
That was me popping my lips. That was the actual burp. Sorry. Sorry to mislead you like that
So you need to wait for a little second, uh, because if you go too quickly into the
Blacksmith
Uh, the items won't actually be available to purchase which is your literal quest
So you're buying an armor and a small weapon
This small weapon is what you use against the skinny guards because it is amazing for taming on defending yourself
Now you can survive that's right. That's right. I debated you didn't know. Yeah, you thought that pop was my burp
And
So for some reason even though you're right next to him he gets really quiet in certain voicelines
Cruel beyond the magic
The laws of men mean nothing
He murdered his own brother who takes power. He knows neither danger nor fatigue
Those who do not fall. I'm literally hugging him to get him to talk
Jar of leeches head of the people
What does he intend to do with his power?
so again
Eagle vision to lock in that flag because we can't grab it right now, but that's okay
Okay, so we're starting to learn
That the Borgia has overtaken roma and is completely messing it up for the people
And mark you avail is obviously not very happy, but we have to do what the current laid-out rules are
and
Yummy jar of leeches
The cuttlefish eat leeches. I feel like they probably do
I'll talk after this bit
Water check
large
Okay
Now to very quickly bring you up to speed
The Borgia are forbidding us in this section to use the stables and other areas of development
Also, this is the most fucking annoying
Thing to get 100% on hold on. Oh get off the horse. I hate when they go on the horse
Oh, no, I've made it so much worse. Okay. So this captain you have to grab him and put him in that
Um
Uh, oh my god, that freaking citizen was in the way. I didn't want to strike in case
I can't see because of the camera angles
By the way, this game aged really well aged really well. I promise it aged well
No
Right. I am going to no. He's on it. No
This couldn't have gone any worse
Please I've never had this issue in this game before
Right, just grab him grab him and push him. Fuck him. You can kill
Right. No, right. We're not 100% in this right now. I'm literally bright red and embarrassment of this gameplay
We're fuck you
Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you
Please get off the horses. I hate when they're on the horses. All right, maybe I can do it. Hold on
Oh my god, I can still 100% it. Okay. You need to basically drag this guy to the scaffolding and push him in it
Yes
Whenever you kill a captain of a district always loot his body
He has insane amounts of money on his person
That was terrible, but we resurrected it
The reason and you have to kill the other guards first is so you are free to push that guy into the scaffolding to achieve 100% on this
Borgia tower. My god. I have never attracted those other four guards before
I've never had them jump on freaking horses before
That was terrible
But we did it we got 100%
Oh my god, I'm my face is bright red. I'm like, oh my god
Oh, I forgot to burn the tower off for goodness sake. Okay. We need to call
Not the tower. Oh my god. I'm getting so flustered. Oh, right
So we've just reclaimed this district. So you need to burn the tower to in order to symbolize to the
Borgia, they're no longer welcome in this area and their rules no longer apply to this current district of roma. Okay
wait
I'm an idiot. Marquia Valley hasn't told me to burn the tower yet. Please pardon me for jumping that tower
I'm skipping ahead of the game
Right out my way out my way out my way out my way
The guards make peep you here, but they don't actually get you. Okay. We are now giving instructions
Oh, I might need to take my hoodie off I'm sweating and embarrassment
I was like, oh my god, you guys are gonna think I've never played this game before. I'm like, no
It's my favorite game of all time the guards outside there will peep you but they'll never follow you inside as long as you keep moving
Yeah, the guards will never go for you
Um
Literally xio is exhausted. He's climbed this tower three times now. He's like Jesus woman. Give me a break. Okay
You can ignite to the Borgia tower
Like so
Oh, because all the kill-out
Okay, now this is another interesting part of the game, which you can renovate districts to have an income
The controller vibration on the literally uh, it's crazy
Okay, we have just renovated the stables. We now have access to horsey-worsies
Yeah
No
So we will jump on a horse. Thank you horse VTuber. We love you
He does he's supposed to talk to you through this but it bugs out so he's not talking to us right now
but basically he's like
You can't just do what you want. It's xio. It's dangerous. Roma have been here
The Borgia have like
Settled their ways the people are scared basically too long didn't read. Thank you marcia valley for your input
Uh, it always bugs out. He should be talking to us like right now
You always use the white and gray horse here, I'm gonna say something
Nope, here we go
Oh, he mad at us
Yes, yes brotherhood of the people. Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh shit. Sorry. Sorry
Also, you should always go behind the NPC because that'll happen
The audio is bugging out
Wait, can you guys not hear the game?
Eh
I will wait that he can't be Torio. I need to get contact there. It sounds fit
Give me a bad one. Eh
Why oh
Input what you can turn this feature off. I never fucking asked you to turn it on you twat
Fuck off right
Is it still crunching is it the game that's crunching or me that's crunching
Oh, shit. Oh, fuck. It's chase mission. It's a chase mission
It's the game that's crunchy. What the frick why have to be crunchy?
Oh
Hold on
Why are you crunchy?
Okay, I'm opening up the game. I'm gonna muck around with the audio sentence. Um, you know
Mission failed. We'll get him next time
All right, why would you be crunchy even though I didn't change a single thing?
Am I gonna have to close the game and open it back up again?
Yeah, this isn't gonna do anything
Okay, okay, we're closing the game
We're closing the game
Abort memory. Oh my god. We're in the middle of a freaking. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No progress. It's gonna be lost sure useless
You naughty boy. Why would it be crunchy? I got a notification and the thing was like I am changing
Your input and I dismissed it because I never told it to do anything and I just freaking did it. I'm gonna burp
Who goes there by the pope identify yourself?
I said close game
Did I not say close game?
Would you like to would you like to close perhaps?
Yes, yes, you may close the game. Yes, that's as perfectly fine. You're allowed to
uh, right close
That
Maybe I just need to do desktop audio capture
This is plausible
And this is probable
All right, okay. Hold on. I'll down. I'll down. Look come on. No streamer's gonna go without unhinged
Open
Close okay, it's opening
It's opening drum roll. Come on. You can do it, buddy
Oh
Mm-hmm
Okay. Mm-hmm. Okay. Mm-hmm. Okay. Mm-hmm. It's loading the logo and we can't see it. Yeah. I'm just like, let me just
Calibrate the game real quick
Just a few technical difficulties
Ah
Also me this game stood up to the test of time clearly fucking not
Can you lovely jubbly peeps? Can you
Can you hear there? Is that crunchy? No
Is that still crunchy if not, you're just gonna have to hear my desktop audio instead
Sounds good. Okay. Why is game not on stream stream scream?
Uh game. Hello game game. Would you like to show up, please? Is it because I'm not is it because I'm not in game?
No, no
No, no, don't be shy. Don't be shy. Come on. Let me warm you up
Let me warm you up. Come on
You can do it. I believe in you. That's right. Show your face. Come on. Show you
Show us your face
Come on. You can do it. Get it up
Get it up. Yeah, fucking twat. Why the fuck isn't
Mm-hmm. Oh
Oh, no, I'm pretty sure
Assassin's Creed brotherhood is like really problematic to capture in window and I've just fucked it up because I closed it there
Oh
Thank fucking god, I thought I was gonna have to end the stream to like get it to start back up again
Don't ever do that to me again
Oh my goodness. Oh shit, right chase chase chase
Uh, I used to kill this guy all the get time and not understand why
I'll go at least
That in your life
Rip your ears. Is it too loud? Sorry the guards don't like me yet. They're pushing me away. Don't push me. I'll push you
Stream it. Yes me. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Oh
Thank god. I was so worried
My heart feels full of relief. It is so bootyful
Um, obviously because of it's an older game you can see the distance rendering
Not loud just the scream was ear piecing. Oh, okay. Do apologize for that. Sometimes I get a little bit excited
But I'm sure you like it when a girl screams in your ear
Not now Sean not now Sean go away. Get back here. Give me my money back
Okay, there we go. We made it
Did you liberate your money from our friend?
Week
They are up and time with work. We'll have a few dozen more depends on the the
Subject six you mentioned. We'll do that at the end. I don't want to do subject
Now where is my contact Vinicius? He should have already intercepted the letter
follow me
Okay, we are now riding our horses to roma. Uh, marquiovelli's just kind of spanked us for being like you believe in the people
And it's he goes. Yeah, I believe in the people and then the people just stole a lot of money from us
But we got it back. That's fine. That's the main thing
But it's he is starting the concept of the brotherhood of assassins where you take an ordinary citizen
who is fed up with life who is being treated badly who has
Um, just had an absolutely awful time and you've gone. Hey
Do you want to get back at your oppressors?
And then they go, uh, cc because obviously they're italian they wouldn't say yes
They'd say see you and then the good part that
The best part I would argue about this game starts up from there
Okay, so we're just following horsey horsey around
Uh, I love you excelene because I'm like you don't worry. I'm like you in general
But these are just one of the games that I'm like
I love everything about
Sees the means of the projection mi amici
Astroni can relate to being a precious gosh steady on
Thankfully I was born in a good timeline, but uh, if you didn't know the english tried to eradicate
Scottish people many a time
However, uh, the
Romans built a wall called hadrian's wall
Because they weren't interested in going any further into scotland
They said now you guys can keep it. We're not interested in invading. Yes
That's true. That's actually science
Leave my thieves alone you foul beast. Oh that was a bit steady on it
It's here. What was that? It's so you're supposed to like jump on them
Okay, well we got countered so I'll just be up. Let's just kick the thief
I've never had these issues. Oh my god performance. I say
I can't get up one in three men
Time me at the term the baths. Okay, we'll find you the baths. Okay, we're about to do a major tutorial part coming up
But don't worry. It's like a good part
Um, so we're just gonna skedaddle halfway through this. We're currently in the coliseum
Uh
Coliseum has been wrecked for many a century now. This is very accurate to probably what it looks like going
One in three men, but one in one colfish. How dare you? I assure you my bony
bony can
My pecker
Um, it's so easy to get to get engorged
Oh my god, I'm actually gonna announce it any engorgers anyone getting engorged right now. Yeah. Yeah, I bet you are
Okay
This part if we can do it flawlessly first time so I don't need to be embarrassed
however, the game crashes at this part multiple times for me so
First things first take out your wee knife. Know the big knife. Take out your wee knife. Okay
For this part that comes up
Because you're supposed to not get hit god damn you can see me river and moon walked into that sequence there
We are about to encounter a second enemy not the border
Romulae
Let's see if I can do this without messing up
Okay, pause you have to reselect your small knife because the game always
Right if I don't get hit I am blessed by the gods because you're supposed to do the sequence without getting hit
I hate when they attack that blinking means they're attacking
And you can if they have the red hit marker above their head you can't tell if they're about to okay
We got the 10 in a row serial killer achievement. Oh
We did it 100% of that
Oh
That a bit always stresses me out my heart rate is
Okay, this is a tutorial sequence
This is called the
layers of romulus
Guy or Romulae if you you want to get techie speaking but Romulus
Wow
I swear she killed them all with one knife
So this is timed. Okay. We're on a timer
Um, you will watch me pass up flags and as well as pass up treasure boxes
Because we will have to come back in 100% this section because in order to get the 100%
Um time
Is what this one is. So we're just gonna
Speed on by we're gonna do a little speedy Gonzalez. I am not going to read chat for eight minutes
It takes me about seven minutes to do the sequence. The timer is eight minutes. I apologize chat
I can see you rating my burp in the corner of my eye
You must always do the levers in this order in order to maximize your time
Um
It is possible that you fall in a sequence and you'll lose time
Um, but normally I finish
Roughly 40 seconds to one minute early
Um, unfortunately this game is a bit funner. I've just wasted a bit of time doing that which is a shame, but
Hey ho, it's what happens
uh
Yes, obviously you can tell the music's a bit different the I don't know how compose the music or
Do is commission to compose the music very
Very good
Okay, I can read you for like one second. She hates us. No, I don't need to do the time sequence
I finished early. Oh, I finished early. All right. You want to tell me tell you how early often
I think I've said this before but um
My record is like one minute and like 54 seconds
Roughly and the only reason I know why is because that's how long the preview was for the video
It was a free preview. I'm just gonna admit it. Sorry, but if you guys are like, I'm so nervous to talk to her in chat
I am
absolutely not destined
uh
to be
professional
or whatever
But uh, yeah, that's actually true story. I could probably find the video and share it
um
If you really wanted to see how good that
Um, we're under a timer so we are just gonna kind of
Right, okay
You need to look for the open gate and I get it wrong all the time
But open gate and then take a no. Oh my god. I get it wrong all the time
Do you know how many times I've freaking played this game and I do that every single time?
You'd think I'd learn honestly
One day I'll learn
But I have a fun factoid
That I will tell you later once we get to that part of the thingy
But uh, this will not be the only time we are playing Assassin's Creed on this channel
Uh, Assassin's Creed Brotherhood on this channel in particular
Um, because I um have very much tizm this game into submission and
I don't know should I just ruin it? You know what if you're here right now, I think I'm allowed to ruin it
So my birthday is the 10th of october
Um, oh you must always grab this light
The game will pretend like you can do it. So october 10th is my doughnut on and you'll never guess what date
Uh gets mentioned in this video game october 10th. So we're playing it on my doughnut on
Um, and I get to nerd about the game all over again, and I'm already beaming with happiness just thinking about it
I was like, oh no, no, no, no. I'm going to subject you this twice
You you will watch me play this game twice and be so happy about it
Um
We're getting close to the
Main hall the main hall is where the last major part of the sequence comes in
I'm glad the game didn't crash actually earlier because I've not really had I don't really experience any crashing after the wolf section
Once you've killed all the romuli guys, then
Uh, not once have I had the game crash on multiple playthroughs
Um, this game was literally made for me for real for real like actually though like I mean, how did they know? Like, oh my god, this is
Um for safety, I just follow this. I think you maybe can jump off
There's a fire, but uh, I'm not risking the run. I do not want to play this like
Section again. It's not boring
Hmm, I'm trying to choose my words carefully as if the dev team are sitting here watching. They're not um
Obviously every game section you have a preference for me being timed to claim about isn't
But I understand that they do have to introduce some sort of element like
Not to panic the player, but if you were just to willfully glide through these areas, then it might
be quite
boresome
Any boresoms? There's a flag to the left. We will not be collecting it. There's also a treasure box up ahead again
We're not going to be collecting it. We are trying to get our eight minute timer
Uh, we have entered a cutscene and we will also have a foot sit there. This is the grand hall
This is the last section and it's a nightmare if you mess up on it
But uh, I've done it quite a lot. So the CEO of Ubisoft sitting in here like you're doing what to my game
Um
I always mess this bit up as well. You need to look for this one in order to get inside
This section
um
Now assassins creed was made long before the yellow paint
So they use candlelight and fixtures. I'll show you one section that really highlights the the old candle fixtures
Um, we're about to break this so don't be shocked
I'm quite loud at the breaking
Bit loud, isn't it night?
Yes, so the game will help you in case you mess up because they have been
They know they've made it awkward. So you saw those treasure boxes. You see that flag there again
We're just gonna ignore it. We're here for the speed run and we're not
I actually don't know what the speed run of this game would be. I assume it's probably like under three hours
The first time I played this it took me so long to figure out where I had to go. You have to go on the chair
Literally the chair and then this little pathetic beam. Do you know how long it took me to find this beam as a child?
Like I started asking my mum for help because my mum plays tomb raider
and
And she was like then you look at me straw day and I'm like mum
You're small like I'm a child. You can you must be able to see
You must also grab a lot and to to like save yourself
See, this doesn't look like you should be able to grab it. But if you hold b you can get it. Sorry. I play xbox controller
Uh, I don't know what it is for like ps
uh four
Is it triangle? No triangles. Why?
um
And we're almost there. We're doing good for time. We've not actually made any mistakes yet
Like such as falling off falling off is the oh man. Is she fell off? Okay. Okay, dude. You're done. Um
It's the biggest mistake you can make in these time sequences
uh
Don't worry the game does try to resurrect you. So this is the freaking jump that I've
It's freaking humongous and it's so no you cannot make that in real life
But we are perfect for times
Um, and when you pick up the objective the timer stops
So you couldn't theory go back and get all the stuff you missed
However, I am much more happier to continue on with the campaign
But this is a tutorial section that's part of the main quest line
um for the layer of
Romulus which there are six total
And it unlocks you special armor. Uh, I personally don't actually go
Right, we're gonna pick it up. We're gonna pick it up
So we're picking it up now. So the timer has now officially stopped. We are no longer under the eight minute timer
So I leave my family's armor here one of the finest sets ever made may you who finds it
Receive strength and battle change of handwriting
We have taken it and set it back behind the iron door six keys unlock it spread amongst our brothers
It shall be said to come from your Romulus and they will worship it
And we have a picture of the armor that we may unlock at a later time
Again, I don't normally unlock it through my like first playthrough. It's not necessary. It's a bit time consuming as well
It's probably like an extra hour
So the timer is paused if I pause the game time remaining 133
So yeah, we can pick up all these treasure boxes because we're gonna need it
you get florins in this game and
The campaign actually requires you to have 3,500 florins at one section
Um, and we just want to make sure we go above and beyond because we cannot invest in like
Properties for example that part comes very soon
um
How kind of them to write in clear, uh, yeah detail for us to read their, uh, evil plans basically, but there we go
Ancient roman tomowers. Mmm
Would you like to taste my ancient roman tomow?
Tomato at golden boy achievement unlock. So we've done one as one layer of Romulus
I'm gonna head off. Thank you for hanging. Please don't worry. I believe she be is coming up in an hour
No in 10 minutes. Who's coming up next?
I'm going to take a drink
Is that where the ketchup? No, you're done. You're done. Ben. You're not bad
In nine minutes. Yes. Okay, when she be goes live, please do tell me I will always recommend you guys go watch my gen mates
Because because I'm an endurance streamer. I'd rather you support them
Are you also an older?
Okay, this is a beautiful quest
It's a beautiful quest. It has include revelation. Yes, you play a much older etio
I think you're like 70 years old technically and you're like jumping about paragliding and stuff and it's like
They really stretch the old dates to make sure they could get them in this
um
See you tonight when mercy rates into you. Honestly though
Guelph etio
Brotherhood is etio in his prime for you for it. He's like 42 or 41. I believe in this game a bit of an old man, but hey
Other bombs
Okay, we're about to unlock the next sequence. It's so good
So the map of roma is massive, but there's guards everywhere
So he's telling us if you use the aqueducts, you can move about real quick
So we are going to use the aqueduct right now to get to island tebarina
And this is where the assassins are based on on the map in roma
When mercy airdonstream stroneys just finished the intro yapping of the story
Honestly, oh my god, azurid. It's so well on her 2.0
She's fantastic with all her yapping. I think someone said yeah procorn and I was like, well, that's pretty smart. I like that
He's not really in this at all
Fabio, I feel like he might have been dlc content or something. He has two seeds in this game. And yeah
I don't know what
I'd rather confuse
Her voice is sick
Gee willikers. I wonder why I picked azura. I think we are ready for such an effect for the model
Do you know for instance where the borja troops took katharina's forza?
What are you also unaware that the borja have captured the apple of Eden?
How could you have lost the apple?
So you do not know what goes on with our enemies
Do we at least have an underground here to work with no underground network found
Our mercenaries are ensnared in illusory love. He doesn't even talk to me
We have girls working for us in a brothel frequented by cardinals. Oh my god. It's she be you're in my game
But the madam there is a lot rather attend parties than further of cause
What about the city steves?
Do they have a deal see but they refuse to talk to us?
I do not know why
What are you going to do to make some friends make some friends?
such a good line
Because we're about to make three different allies of different districts. We're about to make friends with the thieves
We're about to make friends with the hoes. We're about to make friends with the mercenaries. Let's go
It's very good
We also unlock notoriety in this as well
um
And we also unlock having little uh things achievement unlock from in ruins
Make friends with the hoes to the window
The fighter the lover and the thief to the sweat drop off my boss. Oh skeet skeet mother
Oh skeet skeet god. You want a scottish cover of that song?
Right we are going to do the eagle point
Right now just so we can kind of see what's going on around island tibirina
Please
Right, so we are going to purposely do the thieves last the reason
For the thieves last is because it introduces notoriety. So guards are going to start harassing us a bit more
Um heralds are going to start talking about the devious
Uh acts that xio has committed and we're also going to have witnesses that have falsified their testimonies
You didn't falsify your testimony to me
We've also been introduced to the bank. Um
Where we can
Get money for investing in the city every 20 minutes
We will get our little twint or cup from investing in these places
um
And we have withdrawn four to eight florins. We are rich. We're rich. We're rich
Any you played that game?
Have you heard about that game that that one game about the the guys that dig in the mines? Right?
We're going to go to sorry. I didn't want to learn the lore of the bridge. Sorry bridge. Not interested
We're going to go to the hose first
Cause there's thousands of liars
Um and do this quest line. This is the campaign quest that requires florins in order to progress
However, you can get a very I think you get roughly 2000 florins for doing this quest if you loot the bodies of
the
What the heck this place is bourgeois. Should we just destroy rest ever just going to go kill the captain?
I hope he's not a coward because cowards run
Oh, he's not a coward. Okay. We're gonna
Excuse me. Uh, excuse me. Have you heard about this? Have you seen about this? Please don't shoot me?
Please don't shoot me. I don't have much
I don't have much uh healing vials on me
Stop shooting me at least fight me like a man
Come in my face and say what are you you just completely dodged that right?
We're going to heal and we're going to loot this guy
We're going to unlock this area because see how the the map is red. That's because the bourgeois one is
Joined by this guy. Okay
This looks bad with how much red is on screen. I will get hit. There's absolutely no doubt in my head
We're going to get hit but it's fine. We're going to deal with it
We get the big guys first because these you want to kill the big guys in sequence
Okay, no, we just attracted the attention of that guard over there, which is such a shame. No, we attracted more attention
Okay, the camera angle gets really bad under here. Oh, no, we attracted more guards not again. It's happening again
I can't see I can't see
Stop it. Stop it. No more. No more. Okay. We're fine. We're safe
No, not the horse. Leave me alone. I hate when they go on the horses
Okay, okay, air assassinate the horse guy. Okay, we did it. We did it. Okay smooth move smooth move
No, get off the horse
Get off the horses, please
You're getting you're getting billeted. Boom. That's right. Get off. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay, and then we're gonna stab him
Okay, yeah, the horse is beating him up getting violence getting violence. Get him horse beat him up. Yeah, horsey
Yeah, okay, we're getting a horse feature bar. Let's go. Come on, horsey
Beat him up horse. Beat him up. That's right. Trap alone
Okay, we're just gonna kick him to death. Okay. I was remembered to let the body of the guards
That was amazing. I've never had the horse help me before
Oh, that's fantastic
Oh in the best of kids
Uh, there might be an archer on the other side, but it's not a big deal at this point because we have
Got the thing uh, right. How do I get up here?
Um, we are going to unlock what's called a leaping glove
Um, which means we can do very very big jumps. Uh, unfortunately we can't do it at this section of the tower
So we're gonna have to drop down and reclaim it at a different area
We unlock that in sequence four. I think at the end of sequence four. I can't remember
Um, but it means we can jump things
Very easily and it makes claiming much faster because right now it's a wee bit slow, but it's fine
Um
Time to work. Please enjoy your work. Thank you for hanging out. I'll appreciate you
I believe she be is going live right now. She be caught him boom
If anyone would like to
Depart deeply departed
I'm sure that's the song
I am the one the only one don't need a gun to get respect up off the street
My enemies your enemies we wet them up like a canteen
Uh, right she be sorry. I'm getting very distracted. She be caught and bum is going live. I am going to get uh
Maybe any lurking mods could post her stream link if you guys can post links
Yes, she be is going live. Yeah, uh
Management, can you post she be's link? Please do not be afraid to join she be stream
I'm probably gonna be online for like the next eight hours. So, uh, I can keep you company after that
Please do support my, uh, lovely gen mate. She's fantastic. She's incredibly witty
Uh, witty on that
Dave give me your money. Oh
That's really embarrassing
He just
He just grabbed over the barrel and rolled over. Okay. We're not even it's okay. We don't need the money. It's fine. It's fine
It's fine
Okay, yes, please feel free to check out sheepsters. Uh, I'm just doing brotherhood for the rest of the day
so have fun enjoyer and
Uh, uh, oh, this is dead end. I always forget the section
Uh, normally recruitment's actually spawning those sections and they're so annoying to try and get them do a barrel roll literally
Yes, oh, I'm getting I'm getting shanked. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, I'm getting picked up by thieves. Right. This wasn't supposed to this
This isn't a part of the
Leave me like, wha
For these skinny agile guys, you must take out your small weapon drapes
Swords as well work, but um, yes
He had so you have to wait until they attack you basically because they're so agile it's such a
And then you can do that
Oh my god, oh, I don't want the guards to see me with this body. We're just going to go straight into the memory
Don't want the guards to make the bodies on me
It was fun hanging
Have fun with sheepster
Bye bye. Thanks for hanging
Molly stream drift. Ayuto. That means help in attack. Ayuto. Ayuto
Oh my god, she got her look at her nose. She got a nose job. Look at that peak on that nose. That's beautiful
I will get her back
Beautiful beautiful. Oh, I really need to pee. Not gonna lie
kind of need to pee
um
Maybe after I finish this act we can go pee
If you see top left it says like I've got 5 000 florins, but I need 2.5
It must be 3k for the banker uh sequence, but that's not yet the banker comes later
Um banker is a later act
We are currently doing the lover the thief in the fighter
um
Okay, now that I've noticed I need to pee. I really need to pee. Um
Uh brain psychology. Have you heard of this? Uh, do you want to maybe not?
I'm a bit rude. We are just going to run. Normally you can just take a horse over this section, but I find
They've spawned a wee bit too much
People to like walk around and the horse really struggles to go in between
Like the streets, especially if there's narrow sections, whereas xio can just straight up jump over
Uh, so we will be just doing that
Self-fulfilling prophecy
I need to pee
Oh my god weapons if we all pee together at the same time, but we like affect the water like flush system
Why did you take out the sword xio? I
He just poked him in that eye xio. That was that was a lot. Oh
Whoopsies. I actually didn't mean to do that. I literally just smacked my mouth. I didn't mean to kill him
I'm sorry. You're just trying to get your paycheck for your wife and kids and I've just like literally made made her a widow
Oh
Don't really feel good about that one. Uh, so this is a bourgeois on
It's actually really annoying
Do we do the bourgeois on before we do this?
Oh, no, we won't I can't be arsed. We'll come back to this zone. It's a lot easier when you have recruits
Have you come for the whore?
close enough
It's what happens at football halftime. Oh, I heard that
What? Oh my god
I don't remember this part right again. No way. Did you see the four things behind me? Soldiers are about to board this boat as well
Okay, you must loot the bodies. Oh, I forgot to loot the bodies. Oh, that's fine. Oh
Why are the freaking
Energy pro, okay
So we're gonna look at the bodies of the thieves because they normally have unique items like elephant ivory
Uh, 200 coins. I thought it was a bit more than that
Yeah, vlad then paler coins. Um, these items can be traded at shops for special items
Who goes there identify yourself? Um
And after completing this quest we unlock courtesans which can distract guards
They are very vital to a later campy a later sequence
Uh, actually the banker sequence, uh, which I previously mentioned is when they are vital and a part of the gameplay
You can also get favors done by them. I don't mean like that because they're courtesans
I mean like
So the base price to hire a group is 150 florins, but if you wow them
Uh, you can get a discount rate of 75 florins. I've made that sound so weird. I know but it's the gameplay
Um, the thieves if you upgrade them and impress them the thieves will pickpocket naturally as you walk through clouds
But it's a little bit more. It's not awkward to get the thieves favor. They just have a few more unique. Um
A few more unique things you have to do
I will explain it when we once we unlock it. We're about to unlock it right now and it'll make more sense
Um, but we're basically making generic allies and soon we will make brotherhood
Allies which are assassin allies and they will help your gameplay
if you feel like you are a weak gamer or you're just not there with it with time in and
Like things if the games are going too fast and you're like, I can't keep up
This is the kind of game for you once you know what you're doing and get used to the controls
because once you unlock assassin recruits
Your life is so much easier from there. It's it's bliss. It's a dream
It's one of those games where not everything has to be on you in order to progress and that these are my kena games
Okay, I don't want to feel stressed out. Uh, if I don't hit that you can quickly loot this little box that's on the balcony here
Uh, 75 for a whole group of them. Damn. No wonder strongy only was 100 for the ASMR
Booth, could you imagine if a con would let us do that though?
I think we'd get kicked out
I'm not gonna lie
Not that I'm insinuating anything would occur in the booth, but I feel like
Things may go hand quickly
Uh
Oh, is there sister and her mom they're in roma now
You cannot close I need your help
Good morning. Good. Good morning. Good afternoon and good evening. Oh, yes. Good morning. Good afternoon. No, good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon. There we go
That's
This is different. What alternative do you have?
So claudia is currently she be cotton bum because she's about to run a brothela
I've been on the blooming rose
Why do these ladies have horns that was the style back and then they did their research
These are the hairstyles
at the time
Good morning. Good evening. Good night. Did I say the wrong way?
far
I'm a wee bit slow
So we are now about to renovate this lovely location
And our sister claudia is going to run it and we now have favor with the courtesans
Uh, the rose that infuriate the blooming rose or something like that. Um
There's a flag at the top. You can actually see it shimmering right now very slightly
Um, but we're about to go inside
but
Jen too called the blooming rose
honestly
There are cons in Glasgow that would let you do xd
We were talking about like actually coming to physical cons
Rosa infior
Um
Okay, this
The border make it difficult for claudia's girls
There are several things you could do that would aid them
You can do side quests for the brotella with your mom or whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
No
No, she assigns you a quest
You do not do a quest with your mom and they get okay
Ah
Apologies
Right. Okay. So as I was talking about you can kind of level them up. You can be given assignments
So right now it costs 150 florins to highlight to hire a group of girls
um
Send 10 guards distracted hide bodies
poison
Assassinate from blind spots assassinate from behind smoke bomb with not unlocked smoke bomb yet that comes later
But you can do these and gain favor with the factions and it makes your gameplay a lot easier
um
Right next we are going to
Actually factually do the mercenaries, which is this one. I'm just highlighting it on the map. So I don't get confused
Yes, it is very far away
Um, however
Well, we can just
Run there
I think I can't take a horse and I cannot take the aqueduct because
As soon as you summon the horse you basically get walled off by the layout of the map
Which is fine because we're literally in an area where people are supposed to be living and thriving and doing things
So yeah, horses aren't really supposed to just roll all the way through
Though this is a lost memory of the girl that got away, but we're not going to do it right now
We're going to do it at the end. I do apologize if you're really interested in the story
uh, what's her name?
Christina is her name
Um, but that sad part comes in later
Uh, it is a very unfavorable and sad memory. So I like leaving it to the end. I'd rather just focus on the happy times
Hey, only 500 more meters to go
Uh, Christina, I knew it was Christina
Yeah, this game as much as I'll meme about the render distance like as soon as you get closer to someone
I've just
Added so much time going this way, whatever. Um
I'm like, I'm trying to find the main freaking road, but I can't find it. It's really annoying
Okay, I found the main road and I'm about to go off it. Yippee
Oh, I didn't mean to do that. I swapped him out a sword. Oh, this entire zone's red and I'm not strong enough to kill him
We are
Then we just run through the area to save us time to be honest
No, no, I'm not stopping. You can't make me go away. You stink
Stinky stinky guard
We'll come back once we unlock recruits. Um, I can't get over your accident. Thanks. I spawned in with it
Uh, if you'd like to visit Glasgow, please do please support our economy because it's in absolute shambles in the UK
Um
Maybe I should do that. Maybe I should like plan a trip if you ever came to Scotland
And I'll be like you should go here and you should go here because I've been here and I've been there
um
That'd be cute
The order is an acquired taste. Oh, yeah
Stinky, uh-oh stinky. Okay. These are the French
What do we think of the French? What do we think of the French? We think they're fish. They smell. Sorry
There's like a football chant. That's like, what do we think of the French? I can't remember it
But it's like, what do we think of the French?
What do we think of the French?
And Glasgow is nice while you visit it glad you didn't get stabbed
The one of the highest rate places to get stabbed. However, rate is one of the friendliest as well in Europe
Of all of Europe. I don't know
But
Okay, we made it. We made it. We are about to meet Bartolomeo
the
owner, I guess of the mercenary guild
Water check
Bartolomeo
You have to meet my wife Bianca. Oh, no, fantasy. Yeah, Bianca's a sword. Sorry
His sword of his name is Bianca
Did you check behind the table? Okay, that's a reference to Assassin's Creed one. Just so you know
Pantasy day. Ah, don't mind the bad dude on Chantay
I still haven't harassed Amy with my French, uh, Scottish French accent
I should force her to make an ASMR French collab with me, but I like purposely put my accent
On and she's just cringing in the corner
Don't forget to stretch. Yes, uh, I will need to educate you guys
On why we need to stretch our legs to make sure we don't have a bit who veins
Our position is weak
Then we can concentrate our forces on the French round
Thank you for disclosing this to me Madonna Dalviano. It is the least that I can do to help her
So I will educate you right now my lovely jubblies
Did you know overwhelmingly the people that suffer from
Hemorrhoids, which is a failure of a vein in your booty hole
As office workers because they sit down for long periods of time. So I always recommend
Stretching often or standing up. We are all about to go for a pee break and I recommend you all get up with me
Um, sorry that I never explained that mission there if you kill only the captain you get 100 percent super simple easy
And you can also pick up a flag on the way
Uh, so yes, uh, we desire to not have any issues with our booty holes
So I will recommend we stretch roughly every two hours
Um, I have no idea how long I've been streaming for but we should probably do it soon
Um, the guards will not harass you at this area. It's super easy and you can pick up this a lot of treasure box. It's full
Yes, um, uh, it's quite interesting like the knee this sounds absolutely bizarre
But the nature of hemorrhoids is quite interesting
Because it's literally just what side am I supposed to climb up? I can't get up there
Um, it's literally just a vein in your booty hole. That's you know failed and there's nothing really more to it
It's just like adios I'm out and then that's what hemorrhoid is and you just get a cream and
You know put it on your butt and then it goes away
It's really bizarre or if you're someone like it's a really a shame. I've like heard stories like people who suffer
Uh, you need to like get on operation on your butt
but
um
Yeah
I don't know. I just
Sorry, I'm just vomiting about like biology and diagnosis and stuff. So, yeah
I am not expecting these topics of conversation and sorry, I do apologize. Do we go left or right here? I actually
I think yeah, we were supposed to go left
Okay
The butthole Lord. Yes, you you will have the healthiest booty hole
Uh, enjoying my streams
because
We will have healthy butts together
Uh
Okay, first synchronize the viewpoint and then ignite the board of tower
Do not ignite the board of tower first because the viewpoint will
Not register and you will have to claim the tower all over again. Once you have done a tower
You never have to go back up it. There is no
Treasure chests added on top of the tower. There are no flags added on top of the tower
um
yes
Don't worry. I love every second of your conversation. Yeah, I do like my conversational topic
Uh, the game will always give you a way up fast if uh, they've kind of put you in a thingy
Because they literally leave you in the water after that sequence and I was like, okay, then I guess
We will call a horse very quickly or we'll steal a horse, but a
A really strange developmental fact is
Um, depending on the horse's color depends on its speed in the game
The lighter and whiter the horses the slower it is
And then obviously it goes up to all the way to a black horse and a black horse is the fastest horse you can get in the game
I don't know why the developers did it like that. Um, but I noticed it as soon as I like started playing the game
I was like, huh, why did they do this? It seems like such a random thing
um
But we're on a dark brown horse, which is the second fastest
So we got here lickety split, but if you can somehow memorize the speed of that horse when we get on a white one
Uh, yeah, it'll be so slow in comparison
Now that the popes dogs have fled we're talking about horses still, right? Yeah
It's dread play the game. I will show you literally. I don't know why the devs don't know
Well, that's a true fact. Oh, I don't that's group
Oh, yeah, I'm all I can got restricted and I had to pass like a 10
Second like 10 captures and I can't be bothered doing it. So my account's just restricted right now
I'm so freaking lazy
It like makes me do like these 10
Things over and over and I failed it the first time and I'm like go ahead and stop playing
Like, you know, Phil will I'm a human all I did was retweet someone artwork of me and then it blocked my account again
I've done it like three times now. I keep getting it like
Horses are like cars red cargo first
Again, uh, same thing as before if we improve the mercenaries they get cheaper
I don't know if they get more effective cannot prove that. I don't know if they get more aggressive and successful
Bit silly in it. Yes, it's silly
BRB got walk home. Please do not get snatched on your way home
The red ones go faster
So
Oh, we're unlocking assassin mission contracts as well you get some florns on the side super easy super quick
If you unlock your assassin signals and do these really fast, not problem
Uh, we will do a pee break in about like five minutes time
Okay
Now we are going to be able to utilize the aqueduct in order to get a lot closer because if you see the meters
It says we're 1000 meters away. We go to the island Tiberina. That's the closest we have unlocked to the thieves at the moment
Yeah, it wasn't kind of the market
Is that that might be true
I actually don't know if they get more plentiful the like higher you under your the higher like tier you are with them
We
If
Jesus almost just killed myself from that board there. You're goodness. All right. They came out near we have
We do have to run for this but again, unless I take this guy's horse. You don't want mine now
Thank you very much
Please okay, my way
So this is the problem if the if you gallop through crowds the horse will fall over
But if you just sprint through crowds the horse won't fall over
Um, literally we committed grand theft horse
Say
Apologies to that guy. He probably spent thousands of florns on the horse and I've just ran away with it
And you get to keep the horse
Uh, I've still not unlocked targets. So we're not gonna do that. We're just gonna swim across the water really quick
We the pirate ship always stays after you have done that. I don't know why
But the asset does get reused in a Leonardo mission. So it's not like a massive waste
So we are now currently trying to run out of range of the horse that's across the water because if we call on it
It's gonna try and okay. There we go. We're out of range. So we can spawn in the horse at any point
But uh, it will try to come over from the other side of the water and it can't
So you need to go out of range to despawn it and then you can respawn it on the other side
Fuckin hell this horse is zooming. My god. What kind of hay did we give it?
It's so fat. Why are we going so fat? I need to help it. Oh my god
That was dangerous. Oh, that was dangerous. Like didn't even got a helmet on. He's not even got any crash pads on
I'm surprised to see you. This is Laval pay the owner of the tea skilled
Horse doping honestly
The answer you always do you want to put my spies to work
Sippy check
No, thank you. The horse be like gotta go fast. Should have made it blue like sannic
a serious allegation
Bang bang
Give a wee baggie to the horse
Wee baggie is slang for
I also know he abandoned you right before the
Yeah, I think you can you can get the rest from there. He is an assassin
Not a traitor
I am not convinced. What a wee baggie means
Care to accompany me
So Laval pay thinks that marquia velly is a traitor to the assassin's guild
Which is the reason why Laval pay refuses to communicate with marquia velly
Can I get a horse please because this is going to take a while to get to the location we need to get
Let's go
Right, let's get out of the way of the humans because the humans are in the way
um
After this we gain notoriety unfortunately, which means they're going to be
Posters put up about us and they kind of pop up on the map a bit too a bit too much and they're always like above
Money
How we are we're at six thousand that's not honestly, that's not bad
Um, we are going to try and get a crossbow ball
You can unlock a crossbow ball just like the archers
But you need to pay for it and I think it's 13 000 florins and if you decide to invest in buildings
Like boot. I keep saying butchers like the blacksmith for example. Um, it does like
It adds up over time, but it kind of is a bit difficult
It's better to like save your money for the quest because you can easily defeat the section after
Oh, you like my twitter picture. Yeah. Yeah, I totally made it myself
I did not
I didn't make it at all. I yanked it
Okay, okay
This pay attention
Look at his body and look at him holding his arm
Please make note of this as his and what sounds crazy
But i'm going to talk about reusing assets and how genius it is in video game development
Okay, so he is hunched over and he's holding his arm. Please keep this in your mind. Okay. Let's see if I can shoot everyone
You first
Right you next
Okay, you know
How about you? Okay. Oh
Oh
Hey, let's go, baby
Do you guys see the behind of the scenes and lord of the rings where gimley's like right you first right you next you'll come to me
I'll beat you up right you next right you next. That's basically what we just did
Okay, now this section is actually super easy. It was really hard at first
We might get caught because i'm it's he gets lost so quickly
But basically you have to hide here and then we're going to wait for a group to walk up
And then they will see that group there
That's coming towards us. We hide in that group and then that's it
We've done this section of the game, but please make a note of his body
How he's holding his arm and he's kind of hunched over
Because i'm going to show you a reused asset you might not know about
Wait, why why is that group highlighted? Hold on a minute. Am I supposed to be with the other? There's too many groups
Please
Please okay you
Okay, I hate this bit because the tree gets in the way. Yes, you heard me right the tree gets in the way and breaks up the group often
But we're just gonna blend in
Don't look at us guards. We're just citizens. I'm a monk
Amen, amen. I don't know what monks say
And then
Oh, excuse me
You are right there and he's like
That could have desynchronized because he got caught on those people. I'm not even kidding
Analysing asset analizing
Will this asset be reused later? Yes, it will
You know how to disappear
Okay, we are going to take a pee break right after we've done this bit because I need to pee
He he he
And i'm gonna get more water because i'm out of water already
So these are witnesses
We lose 75 percent notoriety if we do that
And we are also going to complete a thieves challenge
Which is drum roll, please is to pickpocket 500 florins and a really quick way to do it is by this
You pick bribe him 500
And then yank
Easy come easy go, baby
Uh and then oh, I still have notoriety. Um, that's not supposed to happen. It's supposed to disappear at this point
Excuse me whilst I kill this other witness. Oh, no, there's guards. You know what? I can deal with the guards. Yank
Ah
I'm a good citizen. I promise. I'm just a scary scary monk
You've got the wrong man
Everyone else wears hoodies. Okay, it's not just me. Oh, I'm like running into more enemies
Oh, wait, wait, wait. Hold on. Hold the phone. Hold pause. Pause. Pause. Oh pause pause pause
We did it. We did it. We snuck on him. Oh my god, we snuck up on him
Oh my god, it's normally so hard to do talk about opportunistic killing my goodness
Okay, we've just secured her like a third board to tower
Oh my goodness. I can't believe the timing just happened
Oh, that was perfect timing. I could not have asked for better. Oh my god, I could not have asked for better
Is he still trying to oh he just drowned. Okay
Oh, that was amazing. I'm so happy with that
Okay, we're gonna burn this tower. There are a few archers on the roof, but uh, they're not too much of a bother
All right, you can just kind of you know
Unfortunately, you do have this one's a bit more awkward. You have to like
You have to like kill him and then you have to go up there and kill this guy too
And it's a bit annoying to navigate. Whoopsie. Oh, wow. I made that jump
There's a guard down there, but you don't have to kill him if you don't
Get down. No
I will take your get down get down. Oh my god
Oh
You know that song that Japanese one you heard of this you heard of that thing
Oh, maybe if we get 3d models, we can all do that trend get down
Right, we need to find the synchronization point for the map boom synchronization
Yeah
I used to watch a lot of hadsunimiki MMDs
Like dance and stuff and that was the first ever exposure
Pretty much I got
So I have another sipping tin of cola
Oh, my ankle just cracked. I don't know if you heard that
If I got picked up in the make my ankle just cracked
Because I'm sitting on my 15th
I'm wiggling my toes right now. That's right. What are you going to do? You're going to try and stop me? Exactly. You can't
I'm just a little toe wiggler
Okay, uh, we'll get a horse. We'll complete this next but I think we have to defend the thieves guild and upgrade it
And then that was I was done with DNA sequence three question marks
Ah
There are nine dna sequences in this game
And they're all perfectly leveled out, but we are getting very close to being out of the tutorial section very very close
I believe
after act
five
We are officially a tutorial and his own
What a knight of these has a toe wiggling street
Listen to me. I know what we saw
But you have nothing to fear from Machiavelli. What was the streaming page you watched mmds from?
I just youtube like had to meet you dancing and like tato. I like tato
Um, who else did I like? What are the thieves? Ah, what's the yellow one called?
Goodness me I've forgotten her name
I would like to know it not lin and brin to make sure the border just stay away
Perhaps it could look like I forgot the yellow. No, not kagaman
I like that idea. Teto hats and miko and the yellow one
Okay, renovating the thieves guild. Oh, sorry. I just called on the horse by accident. Sorry horsey. Please don't come
Um, am I gonna? Nero? Nero! Nero! I think her name is Nero
No, it's not a boy
Right type in hats and miko teto and it's like beep beep beep and it goes
Nero! Akita! That's her. Yeah, like Akita
Not Gumi. Uh, Gumi never really appealed to me. Sorry
Nero! Nero!
Yadomiku with a one-point help basically
Uh, I like
Ah, yes, I forgot. We also have gamba. It is a great source of income
Especially, but we gamble all the money before I go for a pee just for the heck of it
Your hair looks like water, man, melon, candy, watermelon, sugar
I actually quite like it. Um, because Amy's ginger. She's our yinya. If you're scouts, she's our yinya
So I didn't like want to have like orange orange. So I'm very vibrant in my clothes
Okay, we're just gonna gamble the money and then we'll go for a pee
Okay, what I yeah, but what I do though, I actually I've never played this game
Oh god, what I do
First rule rule the through the seven seven eleven suck a dick or a ball sack
It wins the game without payroll
I'm all in max wager have absolutely no clue. Let's go
Did I win
Did I lose that all
Yeah
Did I win
Oh, no, I'm just gonna have to play more assassin's creed with you guys then
Oh, no
Oh, well
Okay, is this the end of the sequence? No, okay, we're gonna unlock the place
Roma is doomed literally can't play landlord simulator in assassin's creed brotherhood. I am doomed
The house always wins do not gamble
Did I tell you that one time I got offered a lot of money to do a gamble at
True story, uh, it was one of the biggest sponsorship offers I've ever received
And I saw they offered the money first like in the email. They were like, this is how much we'll pay you
um, and I was like
Oh my god, I've never never been paid that much money before and then it was a gamble ad and I'm like, oh, that's that is why
uh, so yeah
How much money uh four thousand us dollars for a one minute advertising segment of a gamble advert a site
The biggest offer I've ever had
Uh, which was pretty insane. Uh, so we're just gonna finish the sequence and then we're all gonna be
Yes
and
But will it pay for all the fallout? Yeah, literally, uh
I was I'm like
Obviously some people are
You got it from a guard good guess
To terrorize roma
How do I find them? I can give you a general location
I suggest looking for signs of distress nearby. Oh, perhaps you will uncover citizens. This isn't the end of the sequence
I'm gonna wet myself. I'm not gonna lie. I've had like three glasses now
Okay, I think I just need to hire two more recruits and then we can all go pee
Claudia
I have no idea
I can do I can do I can do I can do virtue
Okay, this is the claudia thing you must pay for mario stand
I'll pee right now. I don't think I won
I'm gonna do I'm gonna pee I'm not gonna pee
Opportunity to assassinate the marizas will I take it? Oh, do not repeat your mistake
Okay
It absolutely does not come across like that, but my brain
Okay, it's this act almost done. Yes, we're gonna fix the aqueducts in roma as well. The briefings are right here
Can I say something really bad
I thought about being a don't a son reward a little
apple juice or
homemade slime
I don't know if that's terrible or not
But like I thought it would be funny if it was like you can have apple juice or homemade slime
What would you like from this the cuttlefish?
Um
Because and it would be extra funny because I actually have really smelly apple juice
So someone can inhale it and be like
Okay, we did it fix her upper act four is when we get the brotherhood together officially
I'm gonna let the game run in the background because it'll actually generate us income a den of thieves
I have apps. I can't even remember what's in them
Oh, no, is this when we go to the castello? I think this is a castello mission
Right, I'm gonna let the game run in the background because it'll generate me some money in the background
Please everyone, uh, get yourself new drinks if you need water or fizzy juice or whatever you may drink at the moment
Um, please get up and stretch. I am with your peep. I will be roughly three minutes. I'm gonna maybe get a snack
I actually boil this I boiled some eggs in preparation of this stream so I can grab a boiled egg and eat
There's a snack
Because I don't have time to like make fit fit so I have boiled eggs. Okay, right
I'm gonna let the game run in the background, but I'll meet my mic and all that jazz
I'll open it like I'll open the game back up. So it's not just like pause pause, but I go pee
Oh
La carita
The dragon
Oh
Watch yourself
Right I'm not being funny who here's a doctor because my piss was neon
I'm like, is that really have bad and dehydrated?
Oops, I'm currently eating a meat stick. I was gonna get the egg. Oh, I don't have enough money. Oh
Glowing the dark honestly
Right, we're gonna unlock the I keep wanting to call it the butchers the blacksmith
Did you guys pee and get water and stretch your legs instead?
I don't even drink energy drink
I'm eating meat and trying to play at the same time my mouth is stuffed full of meat. Oh
Oh
Beat your bars when they're trying to like do the most clippiest beat clip of ever hair
Oh, my mouth is so full of meat
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we got it. We get it. We know what game you're playing. It's fine
Okay, I'm finishing up. Sorry for the people that don't like mouth sounds. I apologize
Actually can't remember what happens in this sequence. My brain is blanking
Well, it looks like I certainly should have taken the aqueduct because all right, we're going into the castello. Okay
we're about to go
See katharina of for Lee katharina. What's up for Lee? Um, she's currently stuck in a jail
She's she got the jail. You know polis got um
Say police and scott polis
Actually, that's how you say it in uh gaelic as well. You say polis
What are you eating? Uh, I said like a meat a stick of meat. Um, it's like a pepper ramy
But it's called uh twizzle stick or something. Oh, shit. I don't want to get in trouble. Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Excuse me. Just part. Excuse me. Pardon me. Come through. Excuse me. Pardon me. Excuse me part
I
That's what I didn't want to happen
because I'm literally just trying to get into
a memory right now
Excuse me. Pardon me. Didn't mean anything. Right. Well, that was your fault. You could have ignored me, but no no
Oh, are they still looking for me?
So that indicator means they're still looking but they've not been coded to come down the stairs or something because yeah
They should have came down there, but they didn't
Well, I ain't complaining. I never got in trouble. He
Fuck you now. Do you see that flashbang?
How does Haggis taste? I actually really like it. Um
She whore of fourly
I drinking lots of water to stop the neon
Don't speak ill of the border
It was Haggis. Haggis is a meat dish
Keep your eyes on her eyes
Girl spitting fire
Haggis is a meat dish a native national
It's not a national dish, I don't think
Um
Who goes there? Um by the pope, um
Sorry, I ain't and I had a bit of water. So that didn't work. Um
It is
I believe sheep liver and sheep lung mashed up
Uh, and it's quite peppery and quite a peppery dish. Um, it's really nice
Uh, you might have heard the phrase neeps and tatties. That means potatoes and turnip and it's just like a nice mash together
It's really nice. I like it. Okay. So this one's like don't get caught but I couldn't be
What will do the do not the don't get detected later because I actually don't even know how to do it
So we're going to do it for the first time together. I've never done this section without being caught. So
I assume maybe if I had a crossbow and it can kill from afar and resupply
Isn't Haggis a wee rodent? Oh, I is a wee animal. Um
She cannot waver Haggis is mainly pork, is it?
I don't think it's easily accessible like outside of the united kingdom
Um, it is referred to as blood pudding. Oh, no, that's black. Uh, black pudding is different. Um
For breakfast we do like, um
It's a discus. So on the way I just a discus of um
It's called black pudding, but Americans refer to as blood pudding
But it is made of blood. So I do understand why they call it that. It's just we call it. It just sounds a bit barbaric
But at the same time it's like, well, we are eating
You know, I mean
No one cares
Greetings greetings. You really say greens?
Uh
Right, let's kill him from above. Thank you very much. We are gonna have to come back on this
Haggis is a savory pudding containing sheep's
Sheep's pluck minced with chopped onion oatmeal
Spices and salt mixed with stock and cooked with traditional
I don't know how I could do that in the corner of my eye, but here you go
I actually played this game so many times. I'm like completely sequenced out the weather
But yeah, I'm a bit confused how you're supposed to do this section without being caught without a crossbow
I think we'll get access to the crossbow when we replay the memory
Oh, no, go away. See that's the oh my god. No, no, no
By the skin of our teeth
Did that man not shoot?
Oh my gosh
By this skill
By the skin of our teeth by our gamer skills as well. Yes, I give it to my gamers
Oh my gosh, must have been the wind literally
Their brother and sister by the way
Oh
How it looks so
I'd rather like it open myself
Have you talked to the pope about the funds requested by my banker
He is away from the castello. I do need some convincing when he returns
That shouldn't be a problem
I wish that was me for real for real
It's a little time together
Other conquests
We'll be a thing of the past. I shout baby
Oh
Up at here yonking
We tag this up
We tag the stream up to high heaven. We've got here yonking. We got kissing. We got
Bendest
A lot of things going on
Uh, right. I'm not to go up. I think I'm just swing to the side. Yeah, surely
Imagine if I went the wrong way
Right now, right. So hold B and then yeah, you just grab on to everything you can kind of speak things of it
And
His ball was like one black thing shriveled up or something like that
That spanyard guy
Spanish were well then
To even get to that stage. Uh, not gonna lie. Not gonna lie. Uh
Who goes there identify yourself
What do we need to go up
Square sausage. I miss square sausage if you didn't know
In cheeky scotland for breakfast you do square sausage and it's literally a square of sausage meat
And it's that wish it I have it on a roll way onion. How is the journey to roma?
I can't remember your pathetic lucrezia. What did he talk about his plans for napoli? Did you like it?
I can't remember. Perhaps you will remember this
That's what you in your place
Whamming on whamming violence
It can't be
Oh, you can put like tomato sauce on it's like tomato sauce
fried onion
In square sausage on a roll soon simple simple brave simple
Can you get more simple on that?
Right on the hip as well like, uh, excuse me. Uh, sorry that actually really hurt and I need to say for it
Please that actually really hurt. Please don't do that again
Lucrezia Borgia
Right, I'm pretty sure for this sequence if you time it right you can be like not detected by the guards somehow
Yeah, like literally he doesn't yeah
So at least we know that for when we do play the 100 not detection segment
And then there should be a guard to our left
Well, we we don't need to not be detected right now. So it's fine
The safe word is more
What do you think is still it was being the safe word for
a sheep's skate
Okay, kill that guard first and then kill him and then that'll be how we won't get detected surely
Yay castello crash
Brown sauce and I'm not brown sauce fan sauce
Is a bit of harry polter sauce with hp
It's that sauce or ketchup
I'm gonna say something really dumb
I don't know the difference between
Tomato ketchup and tomato sauce and tomato ketchup
Ain't they the sale? Aren't they the same?
Aren't they the same?
Phil's sink failed. Yes, we will be coming back to fully sink at later thing right now
Um, oh my god that per guy. I didn't even know he was in here. I thought she was the only one here
um
Brand one has sugar one doesn't
I guess tomato sauce is probably what I like then
Uh, this is this section can be a little bit finicky. Uh
I want to sing it from the heavens
Who knows what he would do these holes in loyal
He killed my my husband. Oh
For real for real
Nope ketchup has way more sugar than other ingredients. Oh my god, not kidding
She got a point ketchup has a ton of sugar. Okay, whatever the sugary one was. I like it. Okay, brain says yum
Yes, oh
She playing she said
Guess what? I'm not the only one that's going cheating around here
He loves me. No, I don't think he loves you him. Oh, she's like actually animating the flower and stuff
Hello
Imagine counting flowers and someone just goes
Wow
Oh my god, I think I would have a heart attack
He would have enjoyed this guards
Jump on you and say, oh, that's what happens in the ASMR booth. Well stays in the boost. Well happens with boost stays in the booth
I see that premium pass around your neck. Yank. I'm jumping on you. Okay. Thanks for supporting me
All right, we're just gonna have to wait for these guys to attack because they are such a nightmare
Literally it's just so much faster to let them attack and then
Right, oh
I think I just next
The jump scare
Foxy jump scare
Princesses from castles now
All right, all right, right
So this is really awkward if Lucretia gets away like back to that starting station
She will spawn out of bounds and there's absolutely nothing you can do about it
And you have to restart this section again. It's so annoying
Uh, thankfully, uh, the last few times I've played this game. It's not happened
But when it does happen is so annoying
Oh my god, it's so annoying Lucretia
Um, if you can get excuse me, I wasn't even putting her down and you just whacked me with that freaking weapon. Stop it
You're upsetting me
Don't upset me. Oh my god. Please do not do a finishing move if she gets away because I was busy doing a finishing move to look
Really good
The passing was your hand was finished
And their memories are raced
Oh no, the tombstones are raced
Uh, see she does that see if she jumps out you have to go grab her
However, if the people are attacking you then she'll wait on the side patiently for you to kill them
Oh my god, is she actually getting away? I'm getting nervous. Stop. I'm getting nervous. Okay. No, she's she's saying so
Stop it. Lucretia. Lucretia
Hey, hey, calm down. Let me just kidnap you. I mean come on. Come on. Let me just kidnap you. Okay
Let me just kidnap you
She like it really come on
Look your man's no gaining any attention and look at me. I'm picking you up. I'm throwing you a boot
This is exactly what you're wanting. Hey, look at this. Yeah, I didn't face that
Didn't I? I don't face it
But I'm willing to see them
Okay, that's right. That's right. Just accept that
This is so weird. I'm sorry
My words are wasted. Hippocrita. No, no, come on
Okay, we did it. My words are wasted here. Hippocrita
Salute, Lucretia. Just kidnap me, Strony
Oh
Crank sale. Those are some big words. You're not supposed to say that stuff. Oh bib sweat detected
Strony be taking tips from mercy
That's enough
Can you walk? No
Hey smart camera bin. Yes, we are going out the front
Okay
Do not be detected again another do not be detected, but there's two guards literally dead ahead
How am I not to be detected by them when we play this for real?
Did they come in here?
No, this cannot be. Did they actually come in here?
Okay one
Is
No, okay, how am I supposed to deal with two of them at once when we do it for real?
Uh, you better calm down hen. I'm rescuing you Christina. Didn't get on at me about taking so long. Where are you going?
Catarina
I can't wait to hear your ASMR streams. Oh, it's just absolute word vomit. I promise you
Absolutely, nothing makes sense
Uh, my accent gets a little off the wee bit when I like whisper, but it's not really a big deal. Like I can make it like I can
enhance
All about that
Yes, yes, yes, I know you gave me your hole so I'd protect you. It's oh
Hello. Bye. Bye. Hello. Bye. Bye
Bye
I do be a really skilled assassin
Ready
Don't you dare
He's just like me for real for real. He literally went
We're actually it's an auditory confirmed
Never do that to me again
Man, they didn't even let her put on her dress and stuff. It's all torn at the bottom
Oh, also you can walk on barrels
If you wanted to know that you can like jump up on barrels while carrying people
It's just like a silly little goofy thing, but I like it
Okay, we pop you down there pet the eagle and then we just give a wee stabby stabby the eagle all for you, mate
and we just pick up the lady again
And then basically
If you pop her down in the middle, I think you can access both gates without losing
distance
It will warn you against distance if you get too far away from her
But
Um
No, I was gonna walk away. I was gonna walk away and you forfeited your life
How could you be such a silly you know, I think we actually might have to move her over. Whoa
Did you guys see what I just saw?
Oh, leave me alone. No, no, you don't see me. I'm just going up the stairs. I'm just a tourist. I'm a fissure. Okay. I'm a fissure of the
I thought I was gonna desync there. I got scared. I thought I was gonna
I saw her her panties
And I didn't even have to pay anything. I saw them for free
Wait, can that guy see me again? Oh, uh, I think we're gonna have to do the old uh ear assassination
All right, can we hey, uh, excuse me sir sir. I just moved over to do an ear assassination. Thank you
Okay, there we go
The audio is strange again. It better not be
Why
Why I literally nothing has changed
I'm gonna tab in and out of the game multiple times. Okay, so it's gonna like pause and then open back up and pause and open back up
There's a steak noise sound like a steak review
If I have to close the game again, I will
A decent warning like it sounds perfectly fine for me still there
Do I have to play this whole section again if I quit right now it's still buzzing
Do you know what buzzing means in scott's it means you're really
A feature I know has this you can just restart the audio capture. I mean right hold on controversial move. I know
How does that sound does that sound normal?
I am now capturing my desktop audio instead of the game
Okay, I I can know you're literally gonna hear if one of the girls DM me on discord. That's the only thing
Okay, let's get across rich risky. I know you're all gonna know that I'm
I've I've arranged another ASMR collab
Uh, like literally 30 minutes before the stream started
I like burst into someone's DMs on twitter and I was like, hey girls. Do you want to add me?
I thought I was talking to her about ASMR collab and I've already planned it
It's not a big ASMR it goes on her channel and all that jazz, but yeah
Okay, uh, we have a timer. We basically just have to survive
So this is where you can get the serial killer achievement again, but it gets a bit iffy
It's not the best. I will mess up
And we're the enemies go away citizen. I don't want to kill anymore
Uh, I'm going to try and kill the wee guys first because they grab me like that and ruin my streak
Okay, sorry, I'm focusing
See when they grab you it takes you out of your kill streak advantage and there's lancers as well
I can see that lancer. I'm going to try and take him out in the kill streak
okay
I'm trying to get the lancer and it keeps all into the other guys
Come on
wee guy next
Armor guy next I guess he's probably the best, but okay. I can't break his armor. So I'm just gonna go for the wee guy
Okay
We're getting there. We're getting there 30 more seconds. Do not grab me. I hate when they grab me. Oh
No, no, no, not the horse. Not the horse. Not the horse
I said I'm hiding from the horse get me in the hay bale
I'm scared of the horses. I actually don't know how to take down horse guys
Ah, ouch. Yeah, this is why I don't like the horse guy. We've got seven seconds
We just need to not get hit because we can run away in two seconds
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay
Oh my god
Okay, so in this sequence you just need to get out a range of the yellow on the map if you come on the roof
Uh, you can basically run along it as much as you need
Or if you don't like rooftop scaling there is boats down to the left where you can get out a range
Bruh, bruh get off my roof. No
Uh, and then if we disappear in the water, maybe I think we can hide in the water
You can like literally hide in the water
I'm a call fish. Let's go
Can they see me?
I'm
Physically, yes, they can see me, but uh game development wise. No, they can't so uh, I enjoyed that do that again more game, please
Okay, we're gonna kill this guy. Sorry. I'm sorry mate. Your time is up
Oh
I forget. Okay. If you scare away
You won't be able to right. We're gonna go for this poster just because I don't want guards to attack you on site
Um, if you are the highest notoriety, they will attack you. Um, and it is very oh the poster is down here
I have been I've been fooled. The egg is on my face. Uh
right
We need to now go back to
The island tied out
because
Catarina's forces
and
Then we can unlock assassin recruits and then we're really gonna get into the meat of the game and I love it
And everything is so cool. Everything's so awesome
Uh, we're just gonna all right. Here we go yank
He said enough a young come on for her enough
enough
Is it enough?
Don't you not want to give more?
Okay, this is the only problem when navigating what a horse you have to can
You're like stuck to using whatever roads have passed out and it gets really um
finicky
It's a bit
You know what I mean? Is this a bank? Have I unlocked it?
How would you bother you just gone down to it folks?
If you come on the roof should you click?
I never even said that that was you that said that
Normally, I'm the one coming out with the outrageous. Uh, I just whistled for the horse whilst purchasing the bank
Hey horse, can you come out here? Thanks appreciate it like oh, okay
Oh, we made 1.5 Florence
That's pretty good
I don't think we're gonna get the crossbow before the section that i'm hoping to get it by
Uh, I don't know why we lost all our money. Don't know how it happened something something don't gamble at home people. Uh
But may have lost all our money in that
Uh, right where is the bridge?
Bridge is over here. Okay
Got a stile in them peasants
Horse is the first customer of the store for real for real
Munching on that. Hey
Okay, we have made it to the island
Never gamble with your own money gamble with someone else's that's terrible. Don't gamble all
Save that mula
Get yourself a weave as ages from the corner shop. Maybe are we bakery? Are we scorn?
Looking for it in the bank. What's the cesarean rodrigo?
Cesarei rode out before I could get close to him and rodrigo was somewhere else entirely
That is odd
rodrigo is normally at the castle
Very odd indeed
What a waste so levopey thinks
That marky velly tipped off cesarean to leave the castle
So we're all suspicious right now
Impossible cesarei commands a massive army in romagna. You would never reach. Thank you. I say we work here
What?
They rode the borja's influence while restoring our own
And in fact, I want to make it right now. Yes. We're doing it
Machiavelli, meet me outside
Take care of her
We're doing it. We're about to get the brotherhood. Come on reeflings. I want to turn you guys into assassins
I'm gonna turn you to deadly weapons
The borja rob everything from the people to maintain power
What do you intend to do?
We will recruit him to our cause. You cannot be serious to win this war machiavelli
Win the loyal soldiers. Come on reeflings. You'd let me draft you right?
All right, let's get drafted
I'm gonna be the combat medic on the battlefield. Okay. I'm healing you guys on the battlefield
with my
Oh my god, the cutscene took so long that wait
Whoa, I've never seen this happen for two recruits spawned and the cutscene took so long. They both died in the instance
Oh my god
All right, she's still alive. Let's save her. Oh my god
It's shrek and no, no, no, no. We've just attracted more guards. This is terrible. She has incredibly low health
Oh
Goodness me. Oh goodness me. Oh goodness gravy
Please don't perish. I hope she doesn't perish because we're actually gonna have to okay. We she didn't perish like goodness
Already sold my life
What did you sell your life to?
Sin
It's a lady assassin. You'll never guess what I do to the lady
Okay, we're gonna open up the map and the map will tell us where the next recruit is so we can go recruit this person
And now we are about to unlock
Assassin recruit signals, which means in the middle of a fight we can literally ask the game to help us
And there's also a really fun minigame
Where you can level them up and make them even stronger to the point where they can fight
Incredibly strong enemies and it is so satisfying
Watching their health bars go up. Oh, look, I have it already actually. I'm gonna use it for
This citizen if I can get to them in time before they perish
and
Uh, here we go. Oh, it's another lady. Oh my god. We're like doing all ladies in this
Assassin group. Oh, oops my bad
You can't really oh
Oh, okay. Oh, hold on. Let me go. Let me get up. Okay. We're oh my gosh
This has increased brotherhood more like the sisterhood
Am I right? Ha ha
Hopefully we can get a few guys in here. We need to repopulate roma. You know what I'm saying?
Uh, let's unlock the doctors because we can get more money in general
The strong door calls for aid. Oh, me on Christmas like
Okay, I have a new lead base cure for syphilis
What did he say?
I don't think I've ever heard that. I've got a new lead base cure for syphilis
I didn't know that was in the game
That's outrageous
Right, we're going to go pick up this other assassin recruit because they're like a hundred meters away
Uh, that's absolutely hilarious. Um, and we're also going to send one of our assassin recruits away on a mission
Which is how you level up the assassins and you get a stupendous amount of money for it. Um
So I get 650 florns for six minutes. I send this person away for so this is your biggest money maker is sending your assassin recruits away
Um, so we may be able to get the crossbow ball if I dilly dally and do a few safe place things
Uh, or we can just brush through the it's not really brushing because
It's just playing the campaign. But yeah
I'll have to say nothing is true. Everything is permitted for real
I'm training my reeflings to become weapons of destruction. Where's the citizen?
Oh, they're already fighting. Oh the citizen might die
Oh, why is this building so tall? Oh, can I get them? Can I save you? I'm coming. I'm coming
I'm helping I'm helping okay. We got it. We got it. We got it. Okay. Good. Oh, no, there's more guards that come in
Oh, I don't know how low his hp is
The recruits. Oh the recruits. The recruits are so bad at the game as well. I'm so bad at the game
Oh, come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. No
Oh, oh, oh, come on, you can do it.
Okay, oh, oh, we did it.
I instantly, you want to pick up the recruit
because it gets rid of any guards that are nearby.
Mirigracia, Mirigracia, Mirigracia.
And for the right reasons, it seems.
Could you use another blade by your side?
Weapon of instruction.
Achievements, brotherhood.
If we had gamer score,
we'd probably have like 200 venerals.
Oh, these are the Borja zones that we've liberated.
We've done three places,
so we're allowed to have three recruits.
We've done four places, excuse me,
so we're allowed to have four recruits.
I literally just remembered.
We can go to the main quest, which is down here.
There's actually someone we can recruit over here.
Nah, we'll go to the main quest
and we'll pick up recruits on the way.
We've got a fill bar of recruits.
Unfortunately, they're very weak,
so it's not very good.
I'm chasing after you, my recruits.
It's not very good to send them to battle
without kind of leveling them up first,
because your recruits can perish in a fight,
unironically.
Yeah, your assassins can die.
It's very dangerous.
Across the bridges are our first mission.
These missions are all based around calling
your assassin recruits in,
but the bar does take exactly 60 seconds
to refresh from when they disappear,
not from when you call them in,
from when they disappear off the map.
And some of the missions, they take a hot second.
It's good to get multiple bars of assassin recruits,
so the more Borgia towers you destroy,
the more recruits you're allowed,
and you've got a maximum of three bars,
so six Borgia towers.
Where the heck am I going?
Oh, this one, I remember.
Hello, sorry to swing in about that over this very sad scene.
Oh, my fatal.
This is another multiplayer character that we kill.
We must follow the hose.
So they will point to where we need to go,
but I have played this game many a time now,
so you can't just keep running in general.
Running, running, running, running, running,
running, running, running, running.
Yeah, we do have our recruits ready to assassinate this guy,
and we should get a taity sum of money for doing so.
So running, running, running, running.
I've actually never tried to break this sequence
and go outside of what the girls point you to.
Um, yeah.
So I've called my recruit.
I don't know where she is.
She's taking her sweet time, right?
There you go.
Get him!
And then we've 100% of that already.
I'm going to shower.
Hold on, let me pause the stream for you.
I'm teasing.
Enjoy your shower.
Don't forget to do your belly button
and behind your ears.
A lot of people forget.
And make sure you soap all over,
even on your booty hole, soap cleans itself
due to the nature of it.
Not that you're expecting a visitor any time soon, are you?
Eh?
What?
Ehehe.
Um, do you get a lot of money if you loot?
No, you don't get anything if you loot the multiplayer.
Ooh, new recruit, let's get it.
Oh, oh, oh.
No, they're fighting.
Stop fighting before I even get there.
My goodness.
Stop it!
I'm coming to hell.
Give me a second.
Let me cook.
Oh my god, I've just invited even more guards to come over.
Oh, please don't.
I don't know how damaged it is.
Please don't do a cutscene.
There's too many enemies around right now for this.
Oh, oops.
I am actually going to pick up these bodies
and put them in the hay bale.
Because if you put five in a hay bale,
you do a cortisol challenge.
I'm just going to do this now.
So I'm not going to talk to them.
I'm literally going to save his life and then just be like,
excuse me, I'm just trying to hide the evidence of what
we've just committed together.
Mother Mary.
No, not the sword, the body.
No, the body.
Thank you.
No requiesce de parte.
And one more body should do it.
No, not the weapon, the body.
Taking up the trench.
OK, there we go.
You know what always bothered me?
When you kill some evil bloke and then
Exo is cradling like a babysitter recipe, he has.
Whoa, what was that?
Was that scaffolding in that cutscene?
Can you help me?
I would gladly fight for it.
The camera is so good in this game.
Like it's so busy.
Do you guys remember the asset repeating?
I'm going to show you an asset that was repeated right
in this next quest.
So remember how he was holding his arm and he was injured?
Well, guess what?
This is where they reuse the asset on this little crying kid.
Don't worry, there's not a random kid crying in your headset.
It's part of the game.
This is a shrunken down version of that guy that got injured.
Not at this stage, but it's the same cause and all that.
And when he walks away, you can see it.
OK, so stare at him.
We know you use reused assets.
You be soft.
We know.
Sleepless.
You are scary, but you look very brave.
Can you bring my mama back?
Right, now watch him walk away.
You think you can distract me, video game?
I'm on to your secrets.
You might as well have me on the dev team.
Look at this walk.
He's injured.
I can see it.
You can't hide that from me.
I've played this game far too many times.
That is the injured thief asset reused.
You can't get away from me.
Honestly, I wonder if there is behind the scenes development
of Brotherhood, because I actually
haven't consumed any of that.
And if there is, I know what I'm doing the moment I go to bed.
Among other things, after looking at Marshmallow.
OK, we do have two assassin signals, which is really good.
But I should probably send the recruits away just to get
stronger.
But not right now, because we're in the middle of a secret.
I'm just going to start upgrading stuff as I find them.
Injured thief number 312.
OK, camera angle, please.
Ow, I just bumped into those guards.
They literally could have reprimanded me for doing that.
But I guess not.
Right, we have two assassin signals, which is good.
Actually, I'm going to send them a fight
to get some experience, because I need to get them strong.
So we're just going to watch them do their thing.
Hopefully they'll hurry up and get some XP.
Yep, take your time.
They get XP every time you call them into a battle or send them
on missions.
It's not a problem.
There we go, and the respawn.
It's all good.
We will keep another signal to do this mission, though,
because to get 100%, you have to send your signal
to kill the person.
Again, another multiplayer character,
which is why they're so designed.
Out my way, you moth head.
I can't really remember.
He looks behind you on the bridge a lot.
And I like to write on corners.
It's quite funny, actually.
You don't ever use the recruits.
Are you joking?
That's the best part about this game.
If you suck at video gaming, you can literally just
call in the recruits to do everything for you.
He should start running in a second.
No, around the corner, he runs, because we're
to go over there.
He's like, yes, there's absolutely no one on this bridge
that looks threatening to me whatsoever.
Me just standing, not even hiding in the crowd or anything,
and stops.
Oh, see, he's bumping into NPCs.
That's the biggest thing about tailing.
If that NPC bumps them, they can turn around
and look you right in the eyes.
And you're like, oops, you're not really supposed to do that.
He literally has a knife out.
And we're going to, I think he looks back here.
And then, yeah, I remembered.
He looks back here.
And then he looks back after he does a sprint
on top of the stairs.
You're getting all the strats.
So he doesn't look back anymore unless he gets
bumped, which he shouldn't.
No, he didn't.
He didn't.
That's good.
And then he's about to break out in a sprint.
Hey, that's right.
And then you follow him.
And then the game wants you to say,
ooh, I don't think he should have turned around at that point.
No, he shouldn't have.
I don't know why he did.
He's not coded to turn around at that section.
He's coded to turn around at the top of these stairs
unless the sequence broke.
OK, the sequence broke because he's
supposed to do it at the top of those stairs.
My goodness.
I thought we were about to desync there.
Not a game.
You gave me a heart attack.
We must ensure the kidnappings continue.
No, there will be no kidnapping.
He, he, he.
Requies, got the badge.
And look at his hook arm.
Yawing, using that for a design.
I've got two sets of recruits.
Can they hurt these guys without dying?
I want them to get XP for fighting.
Can they do it without Persian?
I think they can.
But no one leveled up.
Not one person leveled up doing that.
Nah, you're done.
You're naughty.
Users supposed to level up.
Did I get into the multiplayer?
No, I didn't actually.
I can't quite remember.
I think it was like you hid among the, oh, someone
did level up.
We'll give her a weapon.
Look, we've got so many assassins.
I'm going to send them on missions.
Sorry if this looks like chaotic mess on the screen right now.
It's just I've done it so many times.
You need to look for difficulty level one missions
and then send the recruit on it.
And it will automatically make them level two
so they can at least have a bit more of a fight into them.
The pigeon's eyes.
They're a bit, look, the game's from 2010.
OK, it's an older game.
I'm not going to steal a horse.
That's not nice.
Committing Grand Horse, uh-oh.
But we'll do this.
Have you played Unity?
I haven't.
I played Assassin's Creed, Ezio's storyline.
And then I played three.
And I didn't really enjoy it so much.
And then I played Black Flag.
But I suck at it because they changed the controls.
And I'm absolutely awful at it.
And I've never actually successfully completed it.
I have no idea where I'm supposed to go.
I think I'm going to go on to the Tiberina Island.
I'll just use that bridge there.
That looks right.
You enjoyed your night?
I know Odyssey came out.
I never played that.
The newer Assassin's Creed, I'm absolutely not familiar with.
At all, I do apologize.
I mean, maybe we can play it for the first time together.
I think Odyssey got a really good reputation.
I know there's that Japanese.
Where the heck am I trying to go?
Sorry, I'm getting so distracted.
Talking and playing at the same time.
I'm sorry.
Guess who we're about to meet?
Are you ready?
Ezio.
Who are we about to meet?
Come here.
Ta-da!
Ezio.
Leonardo.
Leonardo da Vinci himself.
Ta-da!
It is good to see you, friend.
Come here.
Pat, pat, pat, pat.
Hello, Leonardo.
Long time no see, buddy.
The Gorge have commandeered my services.
Actually, they would have killed me,
had I refused.
So remember when Cesare said
the gun was crafted by a friend of mine?
It was crafted by Leonardo.
Because he's my friend.
Oh, congrats if your name's Leonardo.
You're also...
He wanted to chop that thing off.
I don't think any of the modern Aces...
They don't have charm.
Yeah.
That apple.
Um...
Don't say that.
What's 100% thing for the tank mission?
You're making me scared now.
Is it hard?
I thought this game was pretty gamer-friendly.
You're making me...
I'm starting to break out in a sweat.
We ain't even played the tank mission yet.
Stop!
Is it bad?
360 hours for this stream?
I'm sweating.
Leonardo, he's drawing, he's doing his thing.
Did you know Leonardo would eventually like Twilly?
That's a true fact.
You're getting educated with me.
The tank mission?
Oh, you're making me nervous.
I'm getting scared.
Is the tank mission where you have to claim all the towers and stuff?
I like to get the thing.
Okay, we have a long double blade.
We can now do double assassinations, which is one of...
That was me slapping my leg before anyone claims that it was a fart.
I already know what I'm doing.
Fart and Donovan?
We're just unlocking new weaponry.
The next thing we're going to unlock is a leap glove, which is fantastic,
to make jump-climbing much easier.
I can't remember the tank mission.
I'm getting fucking nervous.
I'm making me scared for when we do it.
I was going to leave the missions all to the end,
so we're doing story mode,
and then all the side quests, stuff tomorrow, and then 100% sync.
Right, I don't know where we're heading next.
Oh, okay.
800 meters!
That's so far away.
I don't know if we can take an aqueduct.
We can take an aqueduct to...
Where the heck are the aqueducts?
Okay, behind me.
We can take an aqueduct to the mercenaries,
and then we'll just have to horse on the rest.
I'm getting nervous in case I can't 100% it.
It's literally in the title of tomorrow's stream.
I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting shaking.
Okay, I'm getting a bit funny.
Where am I trying to?
I'm trying to teleport.
Okay, first I need to go inside the guild,
and then I need to go to the mercenaries
on the map, and then we're going to do
the first of the Leonardo missions.
Where the heck...
Oh, there.
I'm literally right here.
Here, right here.
Yes, we'll do the Leonardo...
First Leonardo mission.
I will do the others at the end,
because I think it takes far too long to do them,
in my humble opinion, although I can't remember them.
The layer of Romulus are pretty good for climbing,
for those interested in clan.
Where's my horse?
I have summoned my horse.
Come here.
You're teasing me.
Okay, right.
We will very quickly skedaddle over to this area.
We actually still haven't unlocked the full map yet.
You don't unlock the full map until sequence 7, I think.
Act 7.
So we might hit a boundary wall.
I'm not sure if I'm going the right way.
There's multiple ways you can make your way to the location,
but I think I've done it right.
Yes, the boundary wall right there.
So we are doing it right in quotation marks.
Is it up or down?
Why are you sitting on the horse like that?
Explain yourself.
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
We're here.
I think we just have a really basic mercenary hire,
and then we will do the first Leonardo mission,
which I hate because we've actually not got the crossbow bolt,
which makes it so much easier if you have the fricking crossbow bolt.
But it's fine.
Right, the mercenary should spawn in right in front of us.
Three, two, one.
Hey, that's right.
Come with me.
You're going to beat these people up for me.
Thank you.
And you just tell them to fight like that.
And that's how you utilize the mercenary recruit.
Sorry, I'm itching my eyeball.
I have a rogue eyelash again.
Okay, and then basically you just do all the work.
I can call my assassins and...
You know what? I'll do it for the XP.
Oh, I just unlocked an assassin.
I'll take it.
No, I can't do that.
Uh...
Oh, okay, done.
Yippee!
Okay, we now are going on a mission in a different location.
Map Retrieve from the Overseer.
I cannot read that fast, but thank you, Game, for having faith in me that I can read that fast.
But the truth of the matter is, I can't.
Don't do that.
Don't let that happen again.
Have a little drink of water again.
My voice is dying.
I don't know if you can tell how messed up my voice is,
or if it just kind of sounds like my normal voice at this part.
All right.
I'll get with the machine gun.
So, this 100% is don't kill anyone.
I have never done that before.
I always kill people.
And it's like really...
It's so much easier if you have the crossbow ball,
because, like...
For goodness sake, it...
Because the crossbow ball doesn't give your location away,
but the bullets of the gun do, it's pretty bad.
I'm actually not wanting to move yet.
That's why, because they turn around.
I'm gonna yank him.
I'm actually wanting to go back and kill that guy,
if I'm being honest.
Maybe don't have to, question mark.
There is a rotating guard ahead, which I don't need.
Oh, he's coming!
Are you joking me?
I've just missed him.
Just missed him.
We need to shoot him in order to get where we need to go.
There's two bullets.
Whenever there's a pigeon light, that means you can do a leap of faith.
Your enthusiasm, the game's cute.
It's just such a good game.
So, as long as he doesn't turn around.
If you run, it'll notify the guard of you.
So don't run when you do these kind of things.
Or else the guards just...
The AIs basically gonna be like, I have found you.
And then you're like, please don't do that.
I would like to be uncaught,
because I don't want to redo this entire sequence all over again.
Right, so...
What is he running for?
Okay, this is a bit of an issue.
There's a guard that rotates around the century of the wall,
and that one up there.
I need to shoot both of them, basically.
But I need to wait until the other one rotates away.
Why don't you just hypnotize the guard?
For real!
But they can't see me from this distance.
I'm potent, but I'm not that potent.
Right, so we can do that, at least.
And then...
Maybe...
Wait, there's a guy there.
Oh, I don't like that.
Sorry.
This part, you can fuck up so easily.
Okay.
Okay, we didn't fuck it up.
Burn it, and then we get this checkpoint.
Okay.
Ta-da!
We have achieved the checkpoint.
We no longer have to sneak around.
We can just do our thing.
Phew!
I don't ever want to do that again.
She says as she has to do it again.
You can just drop down.
It doesn't cause any damage to you.
But the music creators for the speed-up song,
like, that is so terrifying.
It strikes blood into the hearts.
It strikes fear into the hearts, not blood into the hearts.
I mean, that's what hearts do.
They pump blood around and stuff.
Get all oxygenated again.
Okay, this is the part I freaking hate,
because I don't know how to, like, not get it to lock on.
You can literally go side-to-side and evade,
and you will still get...
Why are there people there?
Like, I'm evading, but I'm probably gonna get hit on, like...
I don't know how to not get hit.
I've played this so many times.
Although I did evade all of those,
so maybe my swirling is doing much better.
Evasive maneuvers!
Ah! See? I don't get it.
I'm literally going side-to-side.
I wonder if it's a distance thing as well.
Like, if I get too close, the game's like,
you're not allowed to get that close,
and, well, sorry, you didn't really explain.
Like, pardon my French,
but je ne sais quoi, on what's going on, mate.
Okay, there we go. Next sequence.
This is actually pretty badass.
I can't seem to have to admit.
Blech!
Stabbed and throw SFX. Blech!
We will use the tactical camera,
because it's literally, like, if you're down in here,
it's, like, so close.
And you can use the map to see who's coming up,
so I can see there's one on the right,
and then we're gonna swing back left,
and then we're gonna swing back right.
You don't need to worry about the archers at all
in this part of the mission.
They don't hurt you. I've never been hurt in...
But you can see left side again on the red dot map,
which I'm covering up! Lovely!
I just realised I'm covering up the entirety of the map,
so you can't see any of that that I've just been commentating on.
I do apologise.
Again, the horses always get up.
Please don't worry. The horsey-worsies are fine.
You can pre-fire when the red markers spawn in.
You can get to it.
And you can, like, hit them before the markers actually show up.
God, that's really loud.
Hopefully that's not too loud for you guys.
Um, yeah.
The horses are fine. Please don't worry.
All horses get back up in the game.
Ooh, if they aim a bit too close, they're gonna get me.
Ooh, am I gonna get away with that?
Shoot them down!
That wasn't bad either.
Wait, he got back up on the horse.
You better stop!
Stop!
Boom, boom, boom!
This is, like, sniper-similar, honestly.
Oops!
Oh, no, I'm gonna get shot. I messed up.
Ah, wait!
Hello? Rote? Esio?
Ugh.
Esio actually wanted to perish there.
He said, I like feeling pain.
Sorry, I'm, like, really focusing.
I don't have the best aim on analogue.
So, I'll try it.
But, yeah, this is the first mission.
It's the easiest out of them all.
This is still tutorial section stuff,
because the Leonardo missions are main game.
So, this is technical tutorial.
We still go in there.
I'm trying to remember the axe.
Maybe axe.
This is the order.
Oh, can I hit the barrel?
Yeah, I can hit the barrel.
How many are there?
Okay, we've almost done the sequence,
and then we're back into the main game.
I might get another cola, actually.
My voice is feeling it.
I don't know how to extend the stamina of my voice.
I'm not really sure.
Other than, like, be quiet five heads,
but, like, I want to stream.
I want to have a good time.
I have so much lost time to make up for it.
Like, you have no idea.
I saw you spawning.
I saw that.
Hydration and practice.
I've been using my voice for years now.
Just speak smaller words.
Okay.
I work as a co-center agent.
Water helps.
Bang.
Oh, actually.
Hopefully none of the girls are in here.
I want to do a short with them,
so apparently girls can't make, like, good weapon sounds.
Like, I'll make the sound of a gun,
so I'm going to ask all the girls to record
an audio of them making the sound of a gun,
and then we're going to put it in a short.
It's just like a goofy, funny-ha-ha thing.
It's nothing serious.
800 yards from the location
of where I'm supposed to go, are you kidding me?
So I was going to do a shotgun
and see if they come up with, like, pistols,
or maybe an AK.
Right, we've got quite a few levels up.
We've got a level three, which is fantastic.
We're starting to get a bit more serious with the recruits.
They're starting to get a bit more, like, they can survive.
I'm actually going to send them on a bigger mission.
I'm going to take the level three to go level up
Can I send them on level twos?
But the level two missions are quite long.
Wonder who's going to be the best?
I'm going with the classic shotgun, like the
this time over. Wow. Okay. I guess I will go back to the the mercenaries to use the aqueduct
there other than aqueduct there as well. Is that closer? I think so. You can rule your
roll your Rs if you're Scottish. I know some languages like at all don't use don't roll
their Rs like I was gonna say something and my brain completely blanked I'm
now gonna pretend otherwise he he oh I'm out of bounds hard and what can I
still get to this aqueduct it not aqueduct the it's not cistern what is it
sister in access oh my god new name for needy fans just dropped cistern that's
awful I'm sorry I shouldn't have said that I would that's the dumbest thing I've
said all day my views do not reflect that I'll be alert my views are my own I
do not reflect the company thank you I'm just playing a saddler's group please
what does your 11 killstree sound like I don't know how to make like sounds of
names or like weaponry
whatever watch whoever you enjoy so okay I'm gonna say so someone sent me a
marshmallow and it was a link to someone from an agency and not gonna name the
agency and they were like please save her and I was like what do you want me to
do they're locked into a contract like yeah we have a non-compete at VLR you can
like literally jump straight into a VTuber agency once your time's up here
or if you're finished but like what do you want me to do seriously you want me
to like mess you want me to message the company and be like hey can I buy her out
thank you for your faith in me but what am I supposed to do I mean sure I would
have a kid but you know I want everyone to be happy and having a good time while
they're streaming but can't can't help everyone set them free no that sounds so
bad because it's like where have you been it sounds like by and like
hydration check thank you Machiavelli by the company my goodness all right no
chance to deal with the border VTuber Moses oh that is the funniest thing I
have been called in a long time VTuber Moses set them free the hilarious
Agostino Kiji is the Pope's moneylender but Chasarita's business with some hijacked
the company now all we know is that he is called the banker let companies cook
you'll see eventually senator Higidio Trofe comes in all the time and let my
people go okay we're getting assigned our next act the French
on the bridge there's only if you're a French prime it's not in personal me
not in personal you know Viva la France and all that and say la vie and what
other words do you see in print I will have my thieves as I retain his location
je vais  la bibliothque there you go look at listen to that beautiful yeah
I have no recourse to send on a mission because I've already sent them on the
mission je voudrais une croissant avec jambourg wait are you going for me that's
the Scottish French sounds like and the way that I am Swiss I totally support
all the French propaganda
I wouldn't buy
ables
I'm listening to other
I think I'm gonna have to go back to scuff tracking my iphone's at 20%
scuff tracking here we go unless I can get it to balance with the charger in
oh my god you're hearing everything connect okay can I get it to balance
we're getting a bit horizontal right this is dangerous i'm gonna put you in front of a glass
and I'm gonna wedge you in between my keyboard
okay this isn't working I'm gonna wedge you in between uh my teacup
let me just oh pardon me
okay uh-huh oh yeah mm-hmm okay yeah are you still tracking
oh oh hello yes yes I did it okay what actor are we on the banker or uh the french one I think
we're in french one what broke I didn't break anything if ain't broke don't fix it uh right
we're gonna see how much and we're gonna see how much it costs to buy the crossbow 1200 800
I don't have that I look away for a second
well you'll be wedged in between a body part how dare you insinuate right what mission are we doing
memory start up here
is it the banker that we're on I kind of think we may be on the banker mission but I can't really
remember and my wife had a baby
it's trony turn golem I want to try and do that but I think I would destroy my voice in like 20 minutes
it's ink in the back of my throat it's your ink in the back of my throat and
we're gonna rebuild we built this city
we built this city on Florence because that is the currency
inks on here actually I need to do that audio keep forgetting post it I need to make it uh I think
I can probably do it after this stream yes it's a free audio it's just on the
I'm golem posing whilst gaming I mean if you want to get technical
should I be a donors on reward you get to pick it's just a picture like obviously I'd edit my face out
and all that it's just a picture of me like buck-ass naked because that's how I normally game
on my chair in the golem pose and everyone's like what is this and I was like just just just means
I mean certain the adventure is
no so they're like what is this pale creature oh wait it clearly is golem no questions asked
oh
Amy's eyes are currently rolling out of her skull right now
how much oh yeah I decided on strong e clips and strong e r just to be strong r
and strong clips cuz I couldn't think of anything else although someone sent a
really good suggestion on Marshmallow I might change it I mean we're super early
days like I can literally change it I have something else okay this is the
banker this is the banker act sorry I can't sing and do the golden voice
my only wish I said like March from homey oh I can't sing in the golden
my only wish to catch a fish so juicy sweet oh the homey
that's terrible that's awful I think Amy is cool back away she she is a how
you say a un tabernac and yeah she doesn't count she doesn't count as a true
Frenchy true French fry French fries are European Frenchies the Swiss or the
and the cubaic was the cubaic cubaic
honestly her cubaic wa is unlike something I've heard before and she says
she's not very confident in it but I'm like as long as you can form sentences
like the best I can say is like I can say I would like to say I can say I
which is I can say I don't think I know any more doing words in French any more
verbs all the French fries are like oh okay here we go I'm back what did I miss
we're memeing on the French like everyone else no will you believe you
with me oh my god my voice correct I think I can say the colors in French
rouge rose ol my
French, uh, ver, juli, noir, blanc, blanc, uh, marron.
What a French.
Yes, yes.
Not the French ones, yes, yes.
With fish in the bags.
Yeah, what did you just make me say?
I can like kind of half read French.
I have no idea what I'm saying, but I can kind of read it.
Like with the letters and stuff.
The French aren't real, it's a line made up by the English.
Je suis mont, pardon.
I think chichons means boobah, chichons.
Uh, yes.
We will protect you.
Hello gentlemen.
May I please double assassinate you?
No, double assassinate.
Oh, don't be detected.
Don't be detected with the mission.
And the first thing I do is go up and kill some guys.
I'm not very smart, am I?
Oh well.
Eep.
A little over say, but hey.
It's fine.
Morning.
Good morning.
Good evening.
I really don't want to send my assassins on, like, the Lancers,
but as long as they kill the right guy first, this should be fine.
Right, sorry, the senator's currently complaining about his money issues
and how he hates the Borgia.
I'm talking right over at him.
Oops.
Well, thank goodness they came in then.
Uh, hello.
Whoa.
Yeah, see this, the citizens become assassins.
They get scared.
Why do you not do double blade?
I have a double blade.
I'm pretty sure there's, like, busted to double blade stuff as well.
I really appreciate it.
A few different skills to do.
We should probably get rid of some of our noray.
This is where we start now.
We're doing 100% tomorrow.
We're just doing campaign mode right now.
Wouldn't be good time zone be easier.
Good time zone, everyone.
That's awful.
Uh, we may be able to get ignored.
Yes.
No.
I was gonna sneak by them.
I like how he's continuing to talk whilst being beaten up by a sword.
Are they not attacking him?
Assassin recruits, are you so for real right now?
Can you attack him?
What's going on?
Oh my god.
Oh, they've attracted more guards.
What?
And now someone's grabbing the guard?
Hello?
Right, no.
This isn't my problem.
Sorry.
I don't know what is going on over there, but...
I don't think they will attack us.
They're so far away.
Okay, so the assassins are dealing with them.
I think the AI was like, no idea who to target first,
so it was just going for like everyone.
As a Spanish speaker, it should not be that bad.
I can understand quite a lot of Spanish.
That's the best I got for Spanish.
Sorry, but man's not got any Spanish.
Hmm...
I'm trying to think of a better name.
Puta Matvee!
Oh wait, no, I did it wrong.
That's my Espanol.
We're going...
Guards, guards, guards.
No, a horse.
Anything but a horse.
I'm sorry, but you're getting targeted first.
I don't want any horse problems.
Oh, the senator's under attack?
No, they should be attacking me.
How much health has he got?
Oh no, he's still like not even lost a square health.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Assassins help now.
Okay, we're good.
We're good, we're good.
And someone got promoted.
Smells like promotion, boys.
Can I...?
I don't think I can sneak past these guys, so...
We're just gonna go for it, we're just gonna send it.
My assassin recruits just take too long to come back and...
I'm dumb, so...
Time to get some sleep.
Please rest well.
Sleep well.
Sweet dreams.
Do you know other Italian words?
No.
Only like Spingy for push, Ayuto for help.
Katso, to swear.
It's Emmy at piano.
Aw, is that me doing piano?
She tickling them ivories.
Thank goodness I have ivory skin,
because my goodness, I'm in for a good time.
They're attacking me anyway.
Then his friends take me to him.
I will bring you all the money you want.
I've not played this game.
I've played the game in Dutch once.
Just so to say, follow me in Dutch.
You say, volg me.
But yeah, not really.
It was just subtitles and stuff.
I knew it.
Why in Dutch?
I wanted to learn Dutch at one point,
but I gave up.
I only know Scots in English.
Family.
I will follow you to the banker.
Yeah, Dutch is one of the easiest languages
to learn if you're English speaking.
It only takes apparently 40 hours
to get the basics in all that jazz.
20 Florence.
That was it.
In that chest.
It is a very goofy language,
but it's so easy to speak and learn.
If you're ever bored and you're like,
I want to do something,
just learn some Dutch.
Learn the animals.
The animals are quite funny,
because you can see how literal it is with animals.
The title is Shield Poddin,
which literally shielded,
and then padded.
Shield Poddin.
Got to learn German since my sister moved there.
Hallo, Leute, ha, was, geht?
To be good, ja.
Is das Gras road?
Nein, das Gras is groin.
There's some German for you.
Right, if we don't touch the floor,
we get 100%,
but it's a bit finicky, honestly.
So it's not a big deal if we touch the floor.
Ja, das Gras groin.
Ja.
Dein en maht ha.
Is a lovely lady, ja.
Sorry, I'm like completely goofing off right now.
I'm not even explaining the game anymore.
I'm just having a good time.
Most English people have difficulty with the ch.
I assume that's what you wanted me to say.
Ja, in Scots to say a lock, which is a lake,
you say a loch.
Loch.
So, kinda, ja.
And then we also roll our r's,
like it's not girl,
it's girl,
girl,
so Scots kinda naturally have a buff
for other languages,
which is pretty handy
when you're trying to impress someone.
I think to say all day every day in...
All day, took one Taiwan,
all day every day in Vietnamese.
Nah, I don't think that's right.
Please perish.
Give me a clap, Papa.
What?
I'm gonna like clap them cheese.
Sorry.
Ja, this is just a classic tailing mission.
You're not to be out of their POV for 25 seconds.
We are tailing the banker.
He currently has our juicy, juicy money,
which we do get back at the end of this mission.
I thought it's he was about to jump on the floor there,
and I was about to inhale a big inhale.
Khef me in clap, Papa.
Me spank me daddy.
Oh!
Khef me in clap, Papa.
There you go.
To the one Dutch person listening in right now,
he's having the time of his life.
He is absolutely on it.
He's like, I'll see your belief.
Oh, no, that's please.
How do you say thank you?
Thank you, Bill.
He's like, oh, thank you, Bill.
Strawberry.
Thank you, Bill.
And his reactant.
It's me.
Like, I know like the other stuff,
like Iquil is like I won,
like Iquiline.
If you are a human, you say Iquiline.
If you are ainvral, Iquil...
Is he gonna get me in trouble?
I don't...
I think I can like kill this guy from the box.
What's inside the box?
Nothing.
I'm stuck.
Please get out.
Okay, that was funny and unique.
Please don't do that again.
I always forget how to navigate this part.
Are you a fish?
I'm a cuttlefish.
I'm a little piece of paper.
Because I do hypnosis.
But I've yet to actually make a hypnosis.
Well, I have a hypnosis audio coming out,
but like an actual free to view one,
like ASMR stuff.
Oh, can I need to get on that?
We got called again,
but it sounds terrible.
I'm kind of glad because I literally have so much
more stuff I need to edit.
And basically I need to wake up
and then work before stream,
because after stream I can't do anything.
I don't want to kill the...
Someone's up there.
I really don't want to kill
because if you put the bodies on the floor,
sometimes the bodies desync this...
Please stop.
Are you kidding me?
This thing was don't be detected.
I messed that up.
My goodness.
No, don't fall.
Okay, it's fine.
The senator's right there.
The banker's over there.
Well, failed anyway.
It doesn't matter if I touch the floor.
I know on Twitter on YouTube,
but I've got three ASMR videos I need to come out
and be like, thanks for 3,000 subscribers.
Subscribblers.
Yeah, basically,
my stats say that I've been subscribed to
over 5,000 subscribers.
But obviously,
because we've been getting called,
it keeps going down again.
And I was like, oh, okay, I guess.
But, oh no, I can't leave.
Oh, I don't have to leave.
How do I get up here?
How do I get up here again?
Well, if you're the only streamer on YouTube,
it would be Twitch streams.
Not really interested in Twitch,
because of the arbitrary,
like, you're fine,
but you're not fine.
And, yeah,
whereas, like, YouTube, at least,
it's kind of like, there's definitely an open status quo
with YouTube.
And that's much easier to, like,
it's, you know,
darling,
hen,
you're stressing me out.
Get up.
Get it up.
Don't be nervous.
One in three men, get it up.
What do you mean I'm putting more pressure on you
to perform?
Get it up.
Maybe that would be a really funny audio.
Like, I'm absolutely desperate,
and I'm like, get up, get up, get up.
But I'm feeling that would be really unner-
Maybe for a meme audio, I can do that.
I don't think that would be a really funny audio.
I get, like, really aggressive,
like, come on!
I've never been auto-insub before.
A lot of people have been.
Yeah.
It's okay.
The culling stops once, like, more content comes up.
So, once I've finished the stream,
YouTube is gonna have to admit to itself
that I have 8,000-
8,000 hours.
No, I have 8 hours in Assassin's Creed,
and, yeah, people were, like,
actually interacting stuff on stream.
So, yeah, YouTube.
Strongly won.
YouTube zero.
And the girls have been absolutely fantastic
about the culling as well.
Like, they have been...
I asked them,
like, I do not expect the girls
to stream every single day.
I've told them countless times, the only reason I can do it
is because I have rotism, your honor.
But I did ask them, like,
hey, for the first week,
you're most likely gonna have the most views,
like, you'll kind of, like,
the deba...no, buff from debut.
And, like, all of them were like,
yeah, I'll give it my all, like,
I'll stream as much as I can in the first week,
and I'm, like, so freaking thankful and grateful,
and, like, I really think it will, like,
completely help with the culling
and all that jazz.
So this mission is bizarre.
You basically have to guess
the path of where you need to go,
and, of course, I haven't unlocked the map,
so I've freaking done it wrong already.
Is it this way?
But you're also timed as well.
Um...
Aw, and I don't think I can remember off the top of my head.
I think I have to go up the stairs.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh...
No, right, I'm going the wrong way.
Yeah, so they get, like, suspicious of you
if you go the wrong way, and it's, like, um...
I'm sorry.
Oh, I know, like, the general idea,
but I don't know the right way, 100%.
I don't even remember going past these portons, honestly.
Um, I think we go right of the church.
And there's, like, upstairs, right of the church.
My brain is telling me.
Goodness.
Yes, and then take a left under here,
and then the bridge that's up ahead.
Okay, I think we've already nailed it.
That is literally how much I've played this game.
Um...
The noise keeps putting me off,
but, like, I know where I'm going, okay?
Jeez.
Literally, this is the correct way,
in the games, like, I was suspicious.
No, this is the correct way, and I know it is.
I've played it enough to know this is the right way.
This is the way.
Anyone watch Mandalorian?
Grogu's adorable.
Grogu. See? There we go.
We did it.
Uh, yeah.
That's all we have to do.
And we have completed this section.
None...
More than an angry squirt.
Oh, yeah.
PayPal...
I don't know what's going on with the PayPal
and the business, because we literally submitted...
It has been established
for months.
Like, all the stuff we've established for months.
I think, unironically,
you guys were supporting, like, AC
and me so much
that PayPal's like,
this is suspicious!
And then the PayPal's now blocked.
So thank you for all the support you've shown
the girls already.
You literally got the account
suspended.
You've literally, like, so much support.
You've suspended being
able to support the girls' monetary.
Like...
Which is hilarious if you think about it.
Um, okay. We're just
tailing the guards.
This is the court's on mission I was talking about,
which is necessary to have them.
Um, if you avoid the guards as much as possible
to hold on to the group for as long as possible
because you have two sets
of girls
that will go out to distract guards.
But if you get too close to guards
and you didn't want to distract,
they essentially get wasted.
And it's about me
literally suffering from success.
Um...
I think
management managed to pay everyone
for the watch-alongs
in time before that happened.
Uh...
But I hope so, because there is a lot of money.
I think, like, the total for sponsors...
No! We lost a group to that.
To the hay bale.
Um...
I think the total of, like,
sponsorships was, like...
I don't mind talking about this.
It was, like, roughly in the 5,000 US
dollars mark for everyone, like, compiled.
Um...
The original budget
was, like, 20,000.
But hardly anyone
was replying
to the agency.
So shout out to Umi Plus
and shout out to
VNU agency.
Don't be surprised if you see us
collaborating with them.
They were fantastic
and lovely, and actually
gave us the time of day.
Um...
Yeah.
So don't be surprised if you see us
working with those girls, because their agency
was kind enough to give us the time of day.
Whereas, pretty much, everyone
else ignored us, so...
Yeah.
Happy it went well, yes.
The watch-alongs were a complete success.
Special thank you to everyone
who did them
and all of that jazz.
Uh...
I'm currently listening to
flirting in my ear, because I just heard
you say, Priest of Confession
or something like that.
Oh my god.
What happens
if we had a nun
design, okay?
But then, she had
a real design under it, but we
promote her as a genuine, completely
covered up nun.
And the promo artwork, her
voice lines are super conservative
and everything. And then on debut
she reveals her real design.
That'd be so cool.
I'm allowed to say this stuff out loud,
but I don't control the design, so
I'm allowed to say this stuff.
Um...
I've got none to do with it.
I love having no more responsibilities.
There's not going to be a Fond de la Buse
because I don't have that responsibility anymore.
Yay!
But admit it,
you love Fond de la Buse.
I'm allowed to do it.
Seeing you all to come alive was so fun.
Did you like seeing the behind the scenes
of how we all looked?
I am very
interested in getting a Celtic design.
I'm going to say something
controversial, Karen.
I actually don't like having
booba out on Vichubama Do.
And not my thing.
And like the cleavage
and all that. No, not my thing.
No!
He got yo-inged by two of the
freaking girls. Are you so dumb?
Why would you do that?
Grrr.
Vee sucky,
my fave ages.
Bruv, it was
rough.
Development was rough.
I'm very happy I never have to develop
anything ever again.
Like it's completely off-handed.
I no longer have to do anything.
And it's such a good feeling.
Right, we're just going to hire
these courtesans to make sure
all is good.
But I think we're pretty
safe.
Make yourself flat.
Honestly, I might.
I might have costume or something.
Design.
Alternative outfit, that's how you say it.
Target is on the move.
I repeat.
Tango is on the move.
Alpha. Bravo. Charlie.
Delta. Echo. Foxtrot.
Gamma. Indigo.
I don't know if that's alphabet.
Right, right, right.
Girls, girls, put your arm down.
Put your arm down.
Into the hei bail we go.
The hei bail of shame.
A big plus for you.
Behind the scenes and the info.
Yeah, like, I really
not really bothered for secrets.
It's like, how do you do this?
Put a lot of money behind it.
Okay, how do you do that?
If you ever want to start a VTuber agency,
I'm going to say this to you.
Whatever you think it's going to cost.
Double it.
I then give it some more.
Whatever time you think it's going to take.
Double it.
And give it some more.
I had a lot of
issues with
like,
artists going
past deadlines.
So everything
slid back into me
and it was horrific for me.
Which is why
I don't have a lot of things done.
My ASMR audios are recorded,
but they aren't edited for you
that go on YouTube.
And it's a shame because I wanted to have that all done.
But, you know, things happened and stuff happens.
But everything's been fantastic.
The reception the girls
received, I'm just so glad people are
loving on them and just so happy
with them.
Like,
it was not easy
because I'm freaking sitting on a wall.
It was not easy
to
assign people
a pre-made model.
I saw some people ask,
why don't they just create the models themselves
that they like?
I understand that I don't
do that. You have no idea
how freaking hard it is to coordinate
X amount of
modelers to come together, to come make a concept,
come to this, come to that.
I am not doing that approach.
Please do not think the viewer is going to end up doing that approach.
However, the girls are more than
welcome to... Hello? Hello?
No, we missed a...
We missed the opportunity
to assassinate them.
Bruh. Come back here right now.
My goodness. Come back here.
Oh, right. Well, just do it later.
Pfft.
Are you supposed to walk right in front of us?
I think the court is on its path and maybe
messed them up. Bruh, get right back here.
But yeah, I am more than happy for the girls
to tell me what they want for alternative
outfits and stuff. That's not a problem
at all.
But
to do a debut
that has input from the start
that's
being signed on in
development is like six months
in the making. No one wants to be
hanging about six months
waiting for their new job
to start. Yeno?
Oh, Mero. Hi, Mero.
How are you doing?
He has a gun.
Emi's gone live.
Okay. Emi... Oh!
Oops, I wasn't paying attention. Hold on.
I'm getting walloped by a frickin' lance.
Oh, no! The hay bale!
Oh!
My ankles!
The hay bale!
I missed... Oh, that's more guards!
I'm... I'm hiding in the corner.
There's so many guards around me.
I can carry it!
Oh, my God!
How did they all follow me here?
All right, I'm calling in the assassins.
You're stuck.
Oh, my God!
There is so many!
It ripped the ankles.
I know.
Oh.
Funny you come in here, Mero.
I was just talking about your agency.
I was seeing how Yumi Plus
is one of the very few
agencies that responded
to the watch-along offers
that VLR made.
Suspicious shout-out to Yumi Plus.
We love Yumi Plus out here.
They found us in two seconds.
I was like pinned against that wall.
Like, please don't find me, please don't find me, please don't find me.
Oh, what? Yeah.
Hardly.
We were talking about the watch-along sponsors for VLR's debut.
And your agency and VNU
were the only two agencies
that were kind enough to respond to us.
Where are Claudia and Maria?
We can talk with the money.
They followed us all.
Sorry, I was trying to go to Amy's room.
I have good news for you.
I want you to go to Amy's stream.
If any mods, you get one
speaking permission.
Amy's stream link.
That's your only time you're allowed to talk.
Whoa, what's going on with the code in there?
I don't know, I've seen that before.
All those numbers.
No more talking mods.
Silence!
Silence.
Thank you.
But yes, please enjoy
watching Amy Bizzou.
I recommend you watch any of my gen mates
when they go live because I myself
am an endurance streamer.
And I will be here for many, many an hour.
I will be trying to finish the
campaign mode of this game.
So please, do not feel any type of way
if you go to watch any of my gen mates.
I absolutely appreciate it and love it.
Please always consider
liking and scrub-scribing
to their channels.
I would love to see them
get ahead of me sub-wise
because the girls
are fantastic and they have
so much potential
that I see in them
and I just want them to...
I did not want to take your horse.
Please get back on your horse
and leave me alone. I apologize.
We're still short of the crossbow.
Maybe we can make enough money
if we send the recruits.
We kind of need the crossbow
for this mission that's coming up.
If you do not have the crossbow,
it is a heck on earth.
It's not a fun thing.
Mercy's laugh is so good.
You're running the content. You didn't say content too.
Yeah, tomorrow we do all the side content.
Today we do campaign mode
and like go back to like 100% stuff.
Yes, see look at that money.
A thousand florins,
thousand, thousand...
Oh, that's also another Scottish slang for you.
Sometimes you can drop the T-H
and make it an E.
So the number 30
becomes the number 30.
I don't know if you can even hear the difference
but yeah, with an F. Very.
Whoa, we have 15,000?
That's like so much money.
I didn't expect that much actually.
I'm going to send the assassins
on another contract just to get them
more XP
because obviously the higher
they are, the more
likely they are
not to fall in battle.
I really don't want anyone to fall in battle.
We should get a level up if they come back soon enough.
Right. Someone say gambling time?
Wait, why is Amy doing it on her stream
for you to say gambling time?
Is she being a naughty?
Oh, there's a thief down there.
Oh, I did gamble
with all the money. No, we're not gambling
with the florins. I need it for
crossbow ball.
And then we're going to go and travel
to the barracks.
Come.
Crossbow ball.
Best in slot
which is BIS.
Best in slot or biz for short.
Any biz.
She's doing ASMR.
Oh, that's why she DM'd me asking
for that. Okay.
Yeah, it makes sense now.
You may enjoy Amy's ASMR
for no
particular
reason.
We gamble.
It's supposed to be ASMR.
Yeah, I wonder if she
did that ASMR.
She DM'd me.
She's like, am I allowed to do ear licking?
I'm like, you know what? Just go for it.
I said, I told her, don't breathe
while you do the licking.
What does she mean by this?
Miam, miam, miam. Hydration check.
But still no.
Gamble to impress
or discuss the course.
We have them in a retreat.
They seem to be getting closer.
What does that mean?
Ear licking.
Yeah.
Don't take any down close.
Oh, I should have bought smoke bombs.
This is bizarre.
They spawned in so many enemies
for this section.
I get it's supposed to be that you're overrun
but, my goodness.
Hold on.
You can disengage from fights
by just running away and jumping.
For some reason, jumping makes the AI
cry. The AI will not swing for you
if you jump.
The other entrance.
Wait a minute.
That can...
It has a double meaning.
No, no, refling the other entrance.
The other one.
Now we destroy all
of the baddies.
I do love going on a kill street
because it's really satisfying
that everyone...
The baddies are running
signals from the field.
Oh, bonjour.
Come closer and say that.
Soon all of
Italia will be speaking to you.
Valic sensibilities.
It's so nice of them to wait
one by one to attack you.
I know they have such good manners, honestly.
Mommy,
want to explore that?
I read the funniest
thing ever
and
if you know, you know.
It was like,
what happens if you take my boy cherry
and it was like,
I'm playing Brotherhood.
I'm going to watch the stream later
until all of you
have fun watching.
Look at the speed of this horse.
These horses
are so much slower.
What did you mean by that?
Development team of Brotherhood
by making the white horse
the slowest
in the black horse the fastest.
What did you mean by that?
Do you want to elaborate? No?
No, okay.
Something rather odd.
Rather odd about that.
But then again, it could just be coincidence.
But then
is it coincidence
if you go up
to like,
the tan horse is faster than the brown horse
is faster than the black ones the fastest?
Hmm.
Should we be offended
by a game that was made 14 years
ago?
Don't let the game journalists
hear we are now.
It's candle to be.
I
I miss when they can gallop.
You can still gallop, you have to hold A
but the problem with galloping is if there's like
people in the way your horse can fall over.
Canceled on first game stream.
Wait, why would I get cancelled
if I point out what the development did?
Why am I getting, hold on a minute.
No, no, no, you can't cancel me.
You just do not reflect to failure agency.
I just scream that.
Right, this is my only gripe.
This is my only gripe
with this mission.
You get left at the gate here
only, I repeat, you get left
at the gate here only
to have to horsey your way
back to the villa when the last
mission just got you from
the barracks
to there.
I'm just going back to like what you just did.
That's my only gripe.
That's right with that.
On the end.
Oh, I should do ASMR
like just me going
for like 30 minutes ear to ear.
What was that noise?
Is that a door?
It sounded like, ooh.
Once inside, your men can overpower
the camp patrols, correct?
Yes, but especially if the patrols
are taken completely by surprise.
Yes.
My ankle.
I'm sitting on it funny. I can't believe it.
That person grunting?
Literally, man.
Cody, you're truly a man.
I'm going to burp. I'm so sorry.
Oh, that was a little maybe burp.
Should have been a frog feature burp.
It would have been very good.
Oh, it could have been a hypno frog.
Honestly.
Do you ever sit normally?
No.
I honestly cannot sit in a normal chair.
Maybe I should do a foot cam, like a thigh cam stream.
And it's just me showing you
how badly I sit like the entire time.
I thought a foot cam stream during a
horror game would be funny because you can
watch me shake my ankles.
And I also have a thing where I
press my toes into the ground.
Like I literally have like little
indents on my toes
from where I press them into the ground
because of the way my toes like
form over on it.
I know it's interesting, but
you know.
Sometimes you don't pick the rotism.
And the rotism picks you.
We've got three so far.
That would actually be funny.
Okay, I'm down for it.
Okay, my guy's already gone.
How about if I send people on you?
I don't want to get caught because we can easily
100% this.
But the assassin recruits take so long.
Okay, thankfully they got caught in the
whoa.
We're getting action shots, like the horse.
Okay.
They're a new recruit.
Let them get up.
Is the other assassin going to try and
help or?
No.
Let them get absolutely lanced.
Right, I'll help them out.
Oh, she's losing health.
I don't like that.
Right, go kill the other guy now.
No, I got these.
I got discovered because of that.
Okay, whoa, we need to help.
We need to help. They're too strong.
This guy's too strong.
Whoa, whoa, whoa. Not the horse.
Not the horse. Not the horse.
In the boss. In the boss. Get him in the boss.
Hit him in the boss. Hit him in the boss.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's fine. I don't know how to go against the horse.
Please leave me alone.
I don't know how to deal with horses.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, we're dealing with the crossbow ball.
Jeez.
Rank 10 assassins are so good,
honestly.
We are very slowly
leveling them up.
I'm wanting to try and pick a fight.
Can I pick a fight?
Ooh, feather.
Look how daintily I jumped over that.
That was beautiful.
Are you okay?
Have you heard about this? Have you heard about this jump?
Hey, there we go.
We're going to upset these guys.
Wait, that's a barrier?
That's a barrier.
Can you jump over them?
I've never seen that before.
We're going to upset these guards on purpose.
So we can... Ouch!
I didn't expect that.
Oh, geez!
Oh, my goodness.
I just got double whammy right off the bat.
Oh, my...
Okay, I need to take the big guy.
Thank you, big guy,
for perishing.
Can't handle you.
Okay, how about that?
Yeah, big...
Oh, we need one more.
Who's going to perish? You are going to perish.
See, the horses are getting stuck here.
I don't know where I'm supposed to go now.
I predict a riot.
Ooh, do you not want to go down there?
Because it's such a nightmare getting out there.
How many steps is that?
I don't even think I've done a double kill yet.
I'm probably going to have to wait till the air stops.
I'm going to have to go back to the barracks.
I'm riding a horse and I'm going to go back to the barracks.
Oh, I'll most likely do
like a full playthrough of Itu's
storyline.
Where am I going?
Have you seen this?
Okay, wait, I'm just being deaf.
Ooh!
Right, we're going to do this Borgia Tower.
That's a lot of guards.
Hmm.
Are we going to hit by Border Patrol?
Wait, we're going to get you.
And then we're going to just
sneak up here and kill you.
Okay, I'll take that.
Do you guys need help?
I'll give you a second recruitment beam
and let you guys fight it out
and I'm going to climb up here
and do this.
Do we skip up here?
I cannot play Assassin's Creed 1.
I absolutely suck at it.
I am so sorry.
I cannot do it.
I've tried Beyond Belief.
I ended up watching someone else play it
just so I know the storyline.
Beyond Belief, I'm absolutely trash.
I probably...
No, I'm doing variety,
but what I'll probably do running up to October 10
is
I'll play
Assassin's Creed 2
before it, then October 10
play Brotherhood again
and then after play Revelations
and then we'll get the full Ezio story.
Sometimes it doesn't engage in combat mode
and then the enemies get like a free hit on you
because there's nothing you can do.
I mean, I know why it does it
because stuff and things, but...
We're level 4,
we're kind of getting a little bit decent.
It's not the best.
We're really not that strong.
I'm just plumping it all into armor
because I get so nervous for them.
I don't want to do a level 4.
Maybe a 3?
Send 2 on a level 3
XP, which is like 100 each.
Yeah...
Oh, a second one? Okay, we'll do that.
That's some old saying to get...
Oh, my tummy rumbled.
My tummy rumbled.
Make me to get some...
Oh, my tummy rumbled again.
I don't know if that's getting picked up in the make,
but I think I'm getting a bit peckish
for actual things.
You know, sometimes a meat stick doesn't do it.
Sometimes you need more.
But...
There's so many jokes I can make,
but they're too easy. I'm just going to leave it.
Actually, I'm going to buy smoke bomb pouch if I can.
It's 9000 Florence!
Who has 9000 Florence?
Unreal.
Unreal Engine.
Who has 9000 Florence?
Not me.
Yeah, to me, say.
You know what they say?
I'm in the pink.
All in the stink.
Who has 9000?
Okay, we're going to get smoke bomb.
Excuse me, excuse me.
I want a smoke bomb pouch.
Smoke bomb pouch?
Smoke bomb pouch, yes.
No, not the knife bell.
Okay, we have smoke bombs almost.
We, a viewer, are not serving the talents.
Okay.
I can't believe...
I actually don't get enough of a cut
or a split that I can't even afford to...
Oh, there's an assassin recruit down here.
Yes, I will help you.
No, let me help you.
Oh, it's a lady. Oh, my lady.
We actually need to
smoke bomb.
Because we need to kill people in a smoke bomb.
For...
Why?
What?
Why do they just get aggressive on us?
Sometimes you need a group of meat sticks.
Ace Marbuth.
Who said that?
Just put them on a warning.
Whoever insinuates that the Ace Marbuth
is going to be utilized for anything but tingling.
Put them on a warning.
Don't.
Teasing.
I'm teasing.
I actually think I might need to get...
I like, I never notice that I'm like hungry
or NTP and then as soon as I notice it,
I'm like, ah!
I'm perishing, I'm perishing.
Mods.
File this man's tax return.
Oh, my God, I cannot wait to...
I have a funny short coming out about
like what you can get taxed back
in a beach of our agency.
You know my Donut-Thon rewards?
One of them is going to be
a length chart.
I get to submit that
for tax back
because it's
what I needed to do
in order to operate.
Like, it's crazy what you can get in tax back.
Like, obviously it doesn't mean I get
the full price of it back in taxes.
No, it just means like...
It's like, okay,
you can get like two dollars back
on your tax return.
I appreciate it.
But like, yeah, you can get taxed back on models,
get taxed back on equipment,
get taxed back on internet,
get taxed back on...
rent as well, I get taxed back on.
Paying your tax
the stream.
Oh, I don't even want to think about
taxes, honestly.
Although it was pretty...
pretty...
Yes, it doesn't mean I'm going to like
get the full thing back.
Sorry, sometimes when people talk about tax
back,
it sounds like they mean
you get the full thing back, which is not the case at all.
Everything is a business, right?
If you can justify it
100%
because I can imagine a vealer
got audited and I have to go like,
oh yeah, you know this special artwork
that was part of the business
because we're an entertainment business.
It would be hilarious.
ASMR girl Iris
Agent
interrogates you.
Wait, what am I doing?
Oh, right in the balls.
Wait, why did...
Oh, did I just
freak? Oh my god.
I'm sorry, I really just
like the last men.
Small
poles only, please, my goodness.
They're so hard to defeat.
The company
has an account and does everything legally.
Okay, dude.
Management. Actually, there's an account
and that's true.
Small poles only, so ogre.
Wait until he'll tell you about my doctor's visit.
That's for our later stream.
You tell it in like raw 4k detail
about the walkers.
Right, what am I supposed to do?
Follow Bartolomeo and his mercenaries.
Okay, he's about to activate this next
thing.
I am now to perish the guards
of my own deck guild.
So this guy
can go first
and
then I can do
you.
And then, last but not least,
I can do you.
No.
Don't be silly,
it's your
aim on the guard, my goodness.
By the way, this came
deaf. What?
Hello?
I got desynchronized, but I did
what you asked.
I did everything right
and I still lost.
Wait.
This isn't the original checkpoint.
We still, wait, we hit the checkpoint
and it let us go through.
Okay, okay, I'll take it.
Okay, next
guard checkpoint.
One to our left.
I might go kill him the new.
Good day to you.
Please stop walking.
Thank you.
Okay, there's a second guard
there.
I really want to get
I need them to
split up.
Focus, focus, there's a pizza on your
focus.
I
was too
in range. If I can time this right,
I'm not going to desync.
I did it.
Did you see that though? The AI
looked at me. Oh my goodness, right?
What way are you going Bartolomeo?
You're going this way.
That was the way.
I'm French.
I'm not Italian or an assassin.
I don't know how.
We didn't get desync to do in that
but we made it.
Right, we've got a guard on the
outside here.
I actually don't remember this part a lot.
You,
I've got two guards next to each other.
I don't like
Oh, he's coming this way.
Oh, there's a dead body.
It's fine.
Oh no, he's gone for the dead body.
I didn't think that through.
That was very lucky that we didn't desync all there.
Phew, we did it.
The hard part is over.
Now it's for the easy part.
So we just walk up to this gate
and then we get to learn how French
people say Italian dog
which is
Italian.
Are you going to have any European
friendly streams?
Like, you mean
starting earlier than the time I stream
right now?
This is probably going to be
my stream start time until
Daylight savings
kicks in for some places.
Which part of France
are you from?
It's EU friendly.
It's 8pm.
It's a bit late if you're like
German ahead one.
Is this a European friendly stream?
Do we not like them?
No, we do. It's just time zones.
It's 4am when I start streaming.
So,
I'm trying my best.
But I'm an endurance streamer so
I do hit a lot of time zones.
And it's unlikely
that reeflings have
8 hours to set through
an entire stream.
Maybe if you work from home
or you're listening at work
but it's a bit dangerous listening at work
because sometimes I tease a lot.
Especially in ASMR streams
I tease quite a lot.
This is me just having
a really good time.
So, I'm pretty tame right now from Brotherhood.
Yeah.
If you live in Turkaya
Arcadijim
means friend
and
Turkay.
I think.
Arcadij.
I work from home
and your endurance streams probably end when your work starts.
So,
I'm definitely going to be...
How can you focus on work and listening at the same time though?
I feel like I could...
Unless it's like background noise.
Arcadijim.
I learned that from Assassin's Creed Revelations
because it's set in Turkey.
Never learn.
Pfft.
These guys are like the hardest enemies you can kind of get.
But if you just jump at them
you can get away with it.
Oh yeah, you just got to break their stance
and just look that down.
That's back to me.
The trick is, I don't really work.
So, this cutscene
is a glitch that was never patched out.
This is a full edited cutscene
where he like, go get my wife.
It never loads.
It will never load in time.
I have no idea what it looks like.
Well, I assume it looks like him
screaming at you
and then he gets his sword and goes off screen.
It will never load.
It doesn't matter what you do, it never loads.
Unless like maybe someone went into the game data
and like I went into free camera
possibly
and then you could definitely do it.
I said small poles only!
We don't want them being...
No! You've ruined my screen!
Okay, we did it though.
It's fine.
Can I open the gate please?
Become anonymous to open the gate.
There's no one attacking me.
Right, that's what I thought.
I was going to say, there's literally no one attacking me.
You underwaste my lack of shame.
I'm pretty sick of stuff that worked before.
Honestly, whatever helps pass the time
like I'm sorry but work can be so mundane.
Like the best work days
are the times where you're super busy
because you blink and it's the end of the day
but you are shattered, that's the only problem
like you're absolutely exhausted
and it's really...
So you're actually
on a timer in this section
and I only have six crossbow bolts
which I do not like at all right now.
Um...
You can.
I might mess up the sequence.
I do it quite a lot.
Don't look back, don't look back, don't look back!
Okay, we did it, we did it, we did it.
You need to air assassinate him for 100%.
Hold on.
You have no clue how many arrows I need to kill in the day.
I'm respected.
Yeah, I'm straight respected and not purchased.
Oh, you should probably go to sleep
if you need to be up in six hours.
It's healthy to get eight hours of sleep.
Digi, no!
Men need eight hours of sleep
where women typically need ten hours of sleep.
But yeah,
actually, don't risk your health.
Sir Shameless, they call me.
I'll be honest, all your girls
make my work day go by real quick.
It's lovely.
That's amazing to hear.
A.P. Gall confirmed the Lord.
What is sleep?
Baby, don't stream more.
Don't stream more.
No more.
What is sleep?
Streamer.
Oh my god, a VTuber streamer parody of that song.
Let's go.
Okay.
Then you can collect both of these chests
if you're fast enough
whilst it's telling you this act is over.
I swear they purposely did this
because no other act takes so long
to complete the sequence six.
Like the ending bit to tell you it's over.
I decided a long time to destroy
my sleep schedule.
Practically, gal.
Excuse me.
Forget Pali.
Worth it, feels good.
Sleep, what is that?
Oh, she caught me.
If I can remember this sequence,
we might have to
do...
Oh, that reminds me.
There's actually a thieves challenge
which is to dive
200 meters, which you can do
off the top of this building.
So we might as well do it now because we're pretty high up.
Ready, steady,
whee!
There we go.
That's a thieves challenge done right there.
Dive complete.
Oh, I've got a hiring discount on the thieves.
Fantastic.
I enjoy that.
I need to level them up a bit more before they pick pocket
but we're getting close to the point where we don't
like
mula like that. Where'd any go on the map?
Where are we?
What's our heading?
Okay, we've liberated
that Borgia zone which is fantastic.
Where's the mission?
Is it south?
The mission's in the thieves guild
which doesn't have a Borgia place
on the way but we'll start
trying to get all the Borgia towers.
I'm just going to use the old
teleport feature.
Yeah, yeah.
And we'll send the assassin recruits on the way
to get leveled up a bit more.
Watching your streams of high level.
Can you stop that?
Try and make me blush.
I literally just memed my bot off
playing a really good game.
Okay, we've got level 5
so we're starting to get a bit...
weapons now just so they have a few
more things.
We need to destroy a tower in order to get our third
signal.
Can I send you guys?
I'm going to send everyone
for the purpose of levelling up that level 1.
Like to get them really levelled up from the start.
So if they do end up in a fight
it's not a problem.
Is it working?
Yes.
Have you been killing people
with your horse?
Maybe they do.
No.
They're not buying it.
He's like...
He's out there.
He looks like the...
Oh no, the words aren't working
in my head.
Please don't shoot me.
He looks up and
he remembers.
Ooh, I love birds.
Not at the bird and
people die everywhere.
People die.
I don't know the words.
But like I know the tune and everything.
Mmm.
What's Johnny means?
The most important meal of the day.
Mmm.
We're going to not grab that thief
because he's already claimed the wall.
I never chase thieves.
If they go up the wall, I cannot be bothered.
I absolutely cannot be bothered.
That's probably the only thing in this game
that I'm just like, it doesn't matter.
It's just like if you wanted to pocket the money
and whatever item is on their persons.
What am I doing?
What?
You guys want to do kegels together?
Are you ready?
Hold for three seconds.
One, two, three, release.
You know what?
You know what I learned about guys?
I learned this a while ago.
If a guy wants to jump start
his Eiffel Tower, he has to close
his end.
Which is crazy.
A little twitch there.
A little twitch there I guess.
Crazy lore for guys.
Absolutely crazy lore.
I don't know
if I was too generic with that.
In order to
achieve sword art.
Oh, and also
when you go to the toilet,
you're a poor little...
What do we call them?
You're a poor little...
I don't know
double eyeballs can touch
the toilet and it's super cold
and uncomfortable.
I only learned that super recently
because I saw a meme about it and I was like
wait what?
You're a poor little guy.
They're going to retract
and save you. They get too cold.
They're going to go straight back
up to your belly button. No!
Kill all the attackers.
Sure, sure, sure.
Wait, why are we in this? Oh, it's a fight.
It's a fight. And I just sent
all my assassins away.
Wait, who's the...
Wrong guy.
Wrong guy. You're hurting the wrong guy.
Where are the enemies?
Got an enemy.
Enemy, enemy, enemy, enemy.
Enema, give them an enema.
Do not give them an enema.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa! That was so cool
that attack. The double splash over.
I really enjoyed that.
What? What? Where did that come from?
Eh, eh.
Go away.
They scare me. That's a renise.
Bad boy, bad boy.
Bad boy.
Oh, it missed.
Okay, let's get this big guard.
Oh, wait, I thought I killed him.
I wasn't paying attention, I'm sorry.
I think I'm going to have to get food and refill
in a second because I'm starting to
get a little bit delirious.
I'm going to get some egg
and I think I'll go ravioli.
Yeah.
Maybe a wee bit longer.
Maybe a three minute break.
Three whole minutes away from stream. I cannot believe it.
I cannot believe it. Absolutely unprofessional.
Unacceptable.
Oh, that makes sense.
Everybody wants to be in the Assassin's Creed
and Brotherhood does really
quite work for the timing of the song.
She hates us now.
Hello.
How many hours?
Five hours? Oh, it's been five hours already.
I've been gushing about this game.
You know what, Reeflings?
Life's good.
Full stop. Life is good.
Got to do my thing.
We having a good time mimin' along.
I'm rambling away about any old shite
that passes my brain.
Life is good.
We're about to go get some juice.
I think I'll make a tea.
Yeah, I'll make a tea.
You'll get some food.
Maybe some snacky too.
I don't think I need to pee.
No pee yet.
Actually, I should probably get up so I'm not that far behind him
because he is like so far ahead of me.
Oh no!
I think he has perished.
But thieves are ours.
Yunkers, you're mine now.
They are...
I...
I don't really want to kick him to death.
Make it quick. See, don't make him suffer.
My goodness.
It's a bit morbid.
I think I'd rather make it quick
and painless, not drag it out.
Oh, he got the horse! How did he do that?
I don't know how he did that,
but do it again.
It looked like he did it with sort of.
Well, it's 1am, so I'll take my leave.
Please, rest well. Anyone who does have to rest
or to sleepie bye bye.
Please don't worry.
Odds are. I'm actually still going to be streaming by the time you wake up.
I said it.
Yeah, it's true.
It's true. I might finish the campaign
and I might want to do some more. It's true.
It's true. The accusations are true.
So don't worry if you have to go to bed.
I might see you when you wake up.
So sweet dreams.
See you in the morning.
Jump off wall. Get kicked into wall.
The accusations are true.
I'm addicted.
But not as much as I'm addicted to you.
You guys might have the nicotine patch
on your head, but the truth is
under these bangs
or fringe,
I've got a nicotine patch too
and it's covering my entire forehead.
I wish I didn't send my sassons on that mission.
Whoa.
Okay, there we go.
This is the Roman bath house.
This is based on reveal, please.
They are public bath houses.
Okay, there's a lot going on. Hold on.
There's a lot going on. Hold on.
Big armor guy.
My notoriety is going
up.
I like how he just swings that air.
Can we get him while he's on the floor?
Get him on the floor!
Ow!
Lavolpi!
Old man.
Put your Glex on.
It's me!
He plays in the first danote.
That was definitely a VA.
They had used the law and they were like,
please just use any other voice.
It's going to be so obvious it's you.
So he had to go,
and play tonight.
Or a V sucking.
I don't have nicotine.
I have B.L.R.
That's so good.
Sleep is for the weak. I don't know.
Sleep is very healthy and apparently
you sleep regularly.
Then it's bad for your longevity.
And you might expire.
We don't really want...
I don't really want you to expire in all honesty.
I'm going to tell you the truth.
I'd rather you didn't expire.
So, please don't.
We're getting some strawny time though.
You're getting strawny time
for a very long time every day.
You're going to be sick of me.
Yeah.
Benenene.
The music's so good.
There's also a feather on top of the Colosseum
but we can get that at a later time.
Mananana.
We are...
We expire.
Survive for a moment.
Not only am I putting you at war,
I'm now expiring you manually.
You have been expired.
I literally glanced away
and he was perfectly hidden behind Ezio.
And I was like, oh, where is he?
Enemies. Enemies.
Give them an animal.
Give the enemies an animal
for how much?
What the fuck?
I don't know.
I'm definitely using a quick
a quick five minute break for you guys.
I'll maybe read some Marshmallows
and we'll take a five minute break.
I'll eat and restore my
hydration levels and stuff.
Getting a wee bit delirious.
Just a wee bit.
Why is there so many guards this time?
I don't really recall this game.
Like this part having so many guards.
Look at this guy on the edge
over there.
Oh, what?
Are we all going?
Okay, he's stuck.
There. Okay, there we go.
All good. All good in the head.
She's got enemies on the brain.
Freudian slip.
Enemies. Enemies.
Sorry, I stuck them out.
It's like a really dumb...
Can I summon Leonardo?
I can. So on these benches
is where you can buy more of Leonardo's
inventions.
Um...
Is there a thing up there?
No, it's on the other side.
Leave me alone.
Never.
What did you ask the scrawny animal
marriage when?
You expect me to come in the middle
of the night? Do you think I would?
I drank a good stretch.
Right, we'll finish this sequence
because
I think this is a quick sequence.
I think we're already, like, pretty much getting through it.
We're about to claim the costumes
off of enemies.
Do you think my assassin recruits
have finished the mission?
So, Lavalpe is now convinced
Marquiovelli is a thief.
It is a traitor
because the events
are synchronizing up too much.
Cesare leaves the castle
when
he could have got tipped off.
Marquiovelli uses guards
to tell him secrets of the Borgia
and
Lavalpe finds it
just far too suspicious
and he's basically
telling us
if you do not put an end
to Lavalpe
to Marquiovelli
I'll do it myself.
Which is
scary biscuits and scary bean.
I'll leave the toes out of the blanket for you.
Oh my god, did you hear my voice there?
For you.
Would you still love me if I send it?
Like, oh.
I'm
wrecking and decking.
We're on sequence six.
Act six and
there's nine acts again.
Yes, I write you would.
Which was an accident.
Italy lore, Italy lore.
Can't believe it.
He said I'm getting rid of Catholicism.
I
have friends that try to tell me that
Assassin's Creed
this Assassin's Creed brotherhood isn't a good game.
There's so many kill mechanics
in brotherhood. Wish they didn't
steal the DLC though.
Yeah.
It's a shame.
DLC was really the height.
Oh.
He said no one else is allowed
I obey.
Oh, that's what we should say to Sheebie.
We obey.
We obey Sheebie please.
Okay, now this horse
constantly gets turned around
so you really can't be too close to him like at all.
We obey Sheebie, we obey.
We do not question, we obey.
Just taking
our time with this guy because
he's so,
he spins around so easily
and you can desync so quick.
Taking our time.
Easy.
Use it.
This might be the longest hailing mission
they've actually put in the game.
Ah.
The entire act is just
hailing missions.
Now don't get me wrong,
I'm not one of those people that complain about the gameplay.
If I complain about
gameplay I would rather suggest
something else that's supposed to happen
but if you consider all the different
types of mechanics
or subjects
that's put in the game, for example
like the lair
of Romulis
or Leonardo's missions
these are completely alternative.
If you're gonna be like
I don't really enjoy the hailing missions, I completely understand that.
I'm not dogging on your comment by the way
I'm just discussing it from
if you ever wanted to
review it. Oh by the way these guards
useless. Absolutely useless.
You can just walk straight in.
I think you can also walk past these two
if you get
into that hay bale, they just forget you exist.
They like think you're a far...
OOOH!
Woopsies! Woopsies! Woopsies!
Woopsies! Woopsies!
So it doesn't matter if the guards
spot me, it's not a problem.
Although if I run it does fulfill the
can you go in the hay bale?
Jeez, my goodness gravy.
It's evil. Are you okay?
I'm a little nervous now, honestly.
You can, if they stop looking at me
yep, okay, yeah.
You hardly have to kill anyone
in these kind of things.
The game is so forgiving, that's why I absolutely
adore about Assassin's Creed Brotherhood.
It is so forgiving.
Now don't get me wrong, you'll still get a few
things where they're like, that shouldn't have got me, but
yeah.
It's so forgiving. So if you hide in the hay bale
wait for this guy to come up and then
send in a... oh he doesn't come up.
Well wait for the guy to go
away and then... yep, there you go.
Boom! Cluster McCord.
Boom!
So...
he gets on a horse
you're actually supposed to go over here
to get on a horse
to continue to follow him.
But it's not really obvious
like most people would just chase on foot
which is completely doable
but for some reason they put the horses
a wee bit to the left and
uh, yeah.
It's a bit harder to
recognise, but yeah definitely this game
if you've never played Assassin's Creed before
I would actually...
you'd miss out on the plot of 2
which is the start of Itsu's story
but mechanic and forgiveness wise
if you're not really a strong gamer
Brotherhood definitely is one for you.
Ah my tummy's wumbling if you heard that
You probably can't over the gameplay actually.
The fact that you're passionate about the game
it's just...
you latch onto something, you can play a game
and you have absolutely no idea what to expect
and then you just adore it like a binding
of Isaac is another game
I didn't know what to expect
and like the first time I played it
I think I played it for like 5 hours and can't...
He did the turnaround thing
he's now supposed to do
and now he's chasing me!
Leave me alone!
Oh my god...
that was... that was gonna
he sinks so hard all because he freaking
turned around!
I knew you were gonna do that
I warned you guys
he always turns around in this tailing mission
he gets caught on NPCs
and spins around
and it scares me
every time I never expect that
he was chasing me though
I don't normally expect them to like turn around
and chase but I guess
if you're close enough they will
I'm also visiting your mom
Have a nice visit
sorry I was gonna say something really mean
but I refrained
I was gonna say
I saw her earlier the day
Oh he's done it again!
No way I'm reading chat! Don't do that again!
Don't do that again!
You're giving me a heart attack
Goodness me
This Johnny's off to visit his mom
Doing your mom!
You know he's strictly doing your mom!
So
Oh!
Please don't attack me
Let the recruits deal with the
Oh this isn't the right way!
This isn't the way to victory
to victory to victory
This ain't the way to victory
My assassins are now fighting it out
I hope they're leveled up enough
to deal with them
to deal with them to deal with them
I hope they're leveled up enough to deal with them
because I don't have any more recruits
Oh no I needed recruits to
100% this mission
Can I just stand about
and wait for them to reappear
because I am patient enough
to do that
Destruction! Destruction!
Hmm
Oh I want to play GTA 4 actually
I need to go
I want to go bowling
Oh they didn't come
They
One more minute
Oh look they've lost the health bar
See that's why I always put it into health
because they can make as many mistakes as they need to
Wait why
am I getting yellowed
Why am I getting yellowed
My assassin recruits are going ham
Am I not going to be detected? I bloody hope not
Right that's fine
I can be detected
Who is shooting?
What is going on over there?
Do you not need to reload?
Hello?
They just despawned
Okay well as long as they're not dead
I guess jeez
Strudy!
Why not name your
Bro
Someone in chat has named himself
Fondle of bosom
Frickin
I can't see it anymore
Did mods time you ever for that?
That's hilarious
I read that
Fondle of bosom
Gen 0 be sucky
I don't see it anymore
Mods timed out it was funny
Unless you were spamming then get bonked
I have to admit
I almost ran out of time there
I'm too busy reading chat
I literally sounded like a monkey there
I'm not even pretending
I almost ran out of time
Alright do not turn around again
I'm going to be so upset
I don't think he does it too much in this sequence part
I don't know
It's the ghost of Christmas pass
Oh my
My voice
Literally can't right now
Oh he's getting really far head actually
Hold on sorry I'm just really enjoying
Reading chat with you
I apologize
Because I remember that people enjoy
When they get their stuff read out
I never did my high
thing
Could I do the high thing?
Like so sometimes
When I started upstream I would actually
Read everyone's name out just to try
To be super thankful
Maybe for the ASMR stream
We could try it
Because I understand
People want to hear their
Name be said by me
Because it's nice to be acknowledged
Let's not pretend
It's not nice to have
Strummer reply directly type thing
Orally generally discuss it
So maybe in the ASMR stream
As a one off I will try my best
To say hi to everyone
You there
Perish
That's a lot of enemies
I got enemies
I'm calling in my recruits
Okay let's get to the fight
Take this
And this
And that
And
I actually
I'm gonna heal up
And try and pick up a medicine vial
Real names or username
I would never encourage anyone
To use their real name
On the internet
I name yourself
Something funny
Or a meme or after
A video game for example
There's no way I'm getting
Is he gonna leave me alone or doesn't he hurt him
I'm gonna hurt you if you come any closer
It's you you're aimbot
Your armor is not that good sir
I know for a fact your armor is not that good
Give me my crossbow bolt back
Right now I know you have some on your persons
Not the knife
It's not a knife
That's a sword
You gave me my crossbow bolt back
That's exactly what I thought
You're not that guy
I started doing a marathon
Imagine if you did Arkham Knight
I do play Batman and go play the Batman
Please don't stop
And look at me
The assassin should kill that third guy
What is going on
Why is it so loud when you guys
Kill people
Okay now the whole
Of like
Roma knows that you're like shooting
Guns over there
Oh my god it's Fond de la Buzum
I can't believe it are you gonna like roleplay
Zero in chat
Damn hope to see it
Long as please
I am much in your debt
He acts on stage
One of my men will
I guess you would go through the live chat participants
Wait I can see a list of everyone watching
No that's only on Twitch
Like maybe at the start
Of this ASMR
As a one off cause like it's just not plausible to like keep up
But just as a thank you for like showing up
Still being here still meaming around
Um
I haven't played Assassin's Creed
But it seems similar to Arkham Knights
I
Wouldn't entirely disagree
Very agile
Um
Very agility based
Definitely
Um
You know hunting around
This 100% is just don't kill anyone
If you scoot your bot all the way
Along the coliseum
Absolutely no issues
You shouldn't run into any guards if you do
You can literally just hang off the ledge
I wish I had the climbing glove though
That Leonardo bench would have came in clutch
For this part of the
Section
But unfortunately
I don't have that where am I supposed to go
Uh
So the watch point is all the way
Oh my god that stance
It actually looks pretty funny
Okay
We're gonna go for this
What
Whoa I didn't even realize that guard could see me
What? How could he even see me
We'll go for the viewpoint
And then we will
Continue with this mission this act is getting
Very close to being finished
And then we will have a five minute break
I will read any marshmallows
So if you want to ask any questions
Or more than can
I did miss some like during
The 2.0 and
The exposing
Just because
Not that it wasn't good enough
But maybe it wasn't like on subject
Or didn't quite necessarily relate to me
Like for the 2.0
So I just sent it
I might give that a good week
But you're welcome to ask any questions
We will rehydrate
I'm getting a T
My voice is perishing
Where am I supposed to go
Over there
There is a feather on top
Of the Colosseum but I'm actually happy
To just climb up again okay that's where we're supposed
To go
Couldn't see it because of the
Render distance but that's okay
Because this is an older game
If you look at the three dots
Where it has time stamp and reactions
And option to pop out chat
It says participants I think it's just chatters
That have typed in chat
I was just going to get you all to be like hi
And then start reading your name
Ear to ear
Senor
I've been going away for the last hour
No you haven't missed a thing
I'm giving away we are on
A sequence
Six
Which is
My god
Why has thou forsaken
Mhmm
Right heading out
Thank you for hanging again
Anyone who is watching you've done so far
You've done well so far
It's five and a half hours
I don't want to expect you to be here for the film
Please rest when you can
And also
Emi is streaming ASMR live if you'd like to check that out
Emi Bezo she has linked below
In my description
Thank you so much
Uh
So please don't be afraid to check out her ASMRs
We are about to finish up the sequence
We just need to eliminate
These three guards that come up
And then deal with the poison sequence
And then I believe
That the sequence is over
We are getting
Very close to finishing
The campaign
Very very close
Just run all the way around the call
Until you get up to the hay bale
There is a treasure chest I always ignore
We can always come back for it later
There you go
You can instantly assassinate the hay bale
And oh it's four targets
Excuse me
Such a fakey gamer
Again crossbow bolts are
Completely silent
They will not
Allure anyone to what has happened
In the area
Which is very nice
Unfortunately I'm running
Rather low on crossbow bolts
We are going to wait for this last guy
To come out on his own
Because if you actually go in there
There is a high chance of him just like straight up
Turning around and looking at you
And then you have to replay this little section again
Don't recommend it up to you
But he will notice the body
And then you get the perfect kill
I'm going to loot his body
Just because again we are a bit low on crossbow bolts
What the fuck is
And then you just need to jump down
On this little
How do you call it
Hanging
Okay
Or just don't touch
Any of it and land on your ankles
Perfectly fine, don't need them
Just completely ignore everything
My goodness
You saw me reach my armor
Just fall to the floor
Literally splat
You may notice that our health bar
Is increasing even though I'm not
Buying any new armor or anything
That's because after every act
You unlock a new health bar
So it's not necessary to use your
Florence on
Armor but
If you definitely are new to the
Assassin's Creed it helps out so much
It's fantastic and please
Utilize the tailor's
Shops because tailor's shops
Have pouches that increase
How much medicine you can hold
How much throwing
Knives, how many crossbow bolts for example
I cannot recommend this game
Seriously
It's about 8 hours total
For campaign if you just ignore everything
If you want to have a good time and explore
You could easily pump
Maybe 16 hours
It's good
Good game
My knees could never do that
No, I don't think anyone's knees
Could have accomplished such a feat
Although I could have sworn
I saw some videos
Of like
You know in Portal 2
The apparatus that's on the legs
To stop any fall damage from occurring
I'm sure someone was developing that tech
At one point
Like maybe for super soldier
But yeah
Are you on steam?
Yeah, I'm playing on steam right now
I was gonna try
And do
Do an Xbox Game Pass
But it's not currently on it right now
So
We don't get the gamer score
You cannot say Pietro
Yeah
The wine he drank was poison
As I promised Cesare
Poison stinky
Can anyone look up
If Cuttlefish have poison
I don't know my lore
I did not come here to kill you
Maybe my poison can...
Oh, well I do ink, but is ink poisonous?
No, it's a deterrent
Cause I can be preyed upon
So ink is to hate me
I can be
Heck yeah I can
You know see my teeth
This was not in rehearsal
I wish I had aim like that
That's cool
Actually that's a really
I would
No
Maybe
Do you think we could set up axe throwing
At a VTuber convention?
I feel like that would be so fun
Legend of people
Like can hit the spot or not
I feel like it's so specific
Whoa, whoa, whoa Jesus
Pick him up, pick him up
Quite literally Jesus
Oh his health is going down
Cause of the poison
I've never noticed that before
Other way
Sorry assassin recruits
I'm gonna need you to like hurry up and perish
These people like right now Pietro is
Oh
That's a reefling
After I'm done with him in the ASMR booth
If you team up a company that does axe throwing
Me next
This is me giving you cola
To make you feel better
Give me the keys
The castello
Oh did I tell you that
After
It's the real traitor
It's not Marquia Valley at all
It's you
Random thief from cutscene
Oh no
No, no, no, no
Horse, please
Please
I can't chase my horse right now
I don't know
I think if I fail this section
If you jump you can jump past the guards
In the AI no longer targets you
I don't know why
I'm scared
I can hear the horse going
Please
Please leave me alone
Leave me alone
Okay, I think I'm safe from the horse
At least
Come here
Come Heather
Move on
Oh
That's awful
Where'd I go?
The green on the map
I can't remember the section very well
I think I can run
If we do not stop
Lavofi
No
To 100%
You're not to swim
No, don't pick
Jesus
Goodness
Gravy
Oh my god, I'm taking the long way
Around
Panic
What are you doing
Why would you randomly grab
That poor man's horse
Climb the wall
And steal
Please, that's a tamed machine
They stress me out so much
Please, I just want 100%
So I never have to do it again
Please, please, please
Why would you randomly take that poor man's horse
I get too stressed
I hate them
Oh my god
This is good news
More than you know
I am once again in your debt, Ezio
What debt is that amongst friends
Trust one another
Yes
Thank you for relaying the message to me
That poor man's horse
Okay
Lavofi and Markioville
Now trust each other
It seems Jezu Cristo was
That is erected three days ago
Ta-da
Checkpoint reach
That's not the end
It is the end of that
We're just being teased
Crazy man's
Steal's horse jumps off and runs up wall
Literally if you hit
Like a graphic thing
Like this at an angle
Ezio refuses to climb
In the wall and it gives me a heart attack
Every time
Look, our thieves are in the
Our recruits are in the background
Look, it's you in the background
It's you in the cutscene
Not right now
I can't see them
It is pain
Claudia is going to become an assassin
We work in the dark
To serve the light
Yeah, absolutely
Cannot say any of those words
Do not ask me to recite that
I can say that part
We're in our training
Oh my god, look at you all reflames
There's so many of you
Like, reflames is my system
I'm reciting it right now
I offer the choice to you
Join us
Oh my god, they're going to hold hands
Yay
She's an assassin
If you get an assassin, you have to be branded
On your wedding ringer
Wedding finger
Where the ring goes
Is your sister single?
Hi, Claudia
You and I have not seen eye to eye on many issues
But you are exactly what the order means
We cannot promote it
You have led the charge against the Templars
And rebuilt this brother
Now we must put Ezio where he belongs
A refling
Oh my god, his reflames crowning me
As their Ushides
Ezio Auditore da Fivenze
You will now be known as Il Mentore
The guardian of our order
And our secrets
No, I can't be Kama Oshi
I don't mind Oshi, but Kama Oshi is impossible
To live up to, that's not possible
Remember, nothing is true
Everything is permanent
Where other men are limited by morality and law
Remember, everything is permitted
Everything is permitted
It's Ezio before or after, he is after
Altair is like
I don't even know what century Altair is
Why this sudden change of heart?
I'm a cameo assassin
I always should buy
I was the one who brought you to Roma
And the one who caused the explosion as you fled the Castello
What?
The mercenaries who protected you at Il Colosseo were mine as well
You just did not know it
Maestro Mattiavelli, Cesare has returned to Roma alone
He rides for the Castel Sant'Angelo
Thank you
The decision is yours, not mine
Niccolo, you better not stop telling me what you think
Why else would I seek the opinion of my most trusted advisor?
Go kill them, Mentore
Finish what you start
Good advice
I'll tell you right about the book about you one day
If you do
You might wish you since day one just accept it
I don't get how
You tell me you consumed all of these content creators
And you're like
Yeah, that one
Out of them all
We have finished sequence seven
There are two more sequences
And then we've done the campaign
It's actually finishing a lot earlier than I thought
I've still got a couple more hours in me
Okay
When it clicks it clicks
You don't pick the Oshi, the Oshi does pick you
When you know you know
Wait, the game is really that short
If you ignore everything and do campaign only
Send it on the campaign then
On it's way
Pretty, you can wrap up
Real quick
I am going to destroy another tower
Because I want to unlock this third signal
And then we will
Actually, you know what
I'm going to send my assassins on a mission
I'm going to pee and make a cup of tea
And get some food
And we can just take a little five minutes to ourselves
A little tea break
Let's send some of the wee
Like everyone for that one mission
No ideal, but it's fine
Can you 100% not?
You can, so that will be a level up
Right, everyone
I don't want to be too close to the pigeons
Because they literally go
In your ear
Hopefully that's not too bad
For ambience
Everyone, please do consider standing up
And getting your legs and blood flow going
Or wiggle your toes
If you're that lazy
Stretch your feet and pull them back and forth
So your muscles and your calves
Like come back and forth
Go for a peep, get some water
Some snacks, some juicy juice
Hypotenuse
And I will be back in roughly
Three minutes
I'm going to try and heat up ravioli
Like fast as anything
So I will be a moment
I would like to watch Emi while she does ASMR live
Her link is in my description
You can do that right now, okay?
I will do the old pretending to sleep
And then I'll open up the game again, okay?
So don't worry
Don't worry about it
It caused my eyes
I had no idea I alive eight aid
Oh we already had endocrine come back as well
back as well. I've got me, I've got all my food. I have a bowl and it has rice
pea snacks. It has two stick meat and one egg and two eggs. I'm just gonna send this
assassin away to get like even more stronger and because we're caned again
Jesus is there any level 3's? I'm like absolutely feasting. I've got fruit juice
with me. I've got a bottle of water. I've got cup of tea with honey in it.
Like, ah, um, oh, not again, would you stop doing that? You're embarrassing me.
We're driving this controller. Yes, eh, so I'm gonna like munch and play but I
didn't bring any napkins so I might have to suck the egg out of the bowl which
sounds bizarre but can you say the second drink again? The fruit juice? It's like, it's
got mango in it. It's like super healthy juice. And a cup of tea. Wait, you can't, what?
Bottle of water. Oh, bottle of water. I didn't say it like the British say it. Well, I consider
the British, English, and the memes like kind of about the English say the bottle of water.
I don't know if I need to slurp this egg because I really can't be bothered getting,
where am I supposed to be going? How far away is this location? Oh, it's the castle,
right. I'm gonna try, I'm gonna get rid of this. Oh, says he's a coward though. It's really annoying
trying to get keywords because they actually run away. Actually, give me one second, my room is
on fire because of this PC. Oh, it's been robbed! I look away for five seconds and it's been robbed!
Oh, right, I don't need the money that much. It's fine, it's fine, great. Let me put my head
down because I actually can't hear the game right now. Did he just run up to me and like,
rob me? Right. Not seeing my room's hope, but too hope it's just came in through a ring in it.
Honestly, I'm sweltering. I don't know if that's the Scottish word, sweltering. Do you see that?
I'm sweltering. Sweating my beats off. Although I feel like sweating my beats off probably comes
from like, is it Mardi Gras? Like that party that Americans have where you unveil yourself and you
get beats as a reward? Like, I think that's where that saying might have came from because that just
makes sense. Like, oh, I'm sweating my beats off because I'm like showing the goods so much and so
often. Right, where on earth has this captain? I really don't want to mess it up because if you
mess it up and he runs away in time, you have to wait until the following day. Oh, I think I know
who this one is. I think he, oh, oh, oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. No, see, oh, you know the guy
that can see you right now? I could actually, wait, I can't lock onto him, but he can lock onto me.
See you stinky AI. Perish. Oh, beats of sweat that come off your head. Oh, you know what? Yeah,
now that you've said that, that makes more sense. Yeah, probably not Mardi Gras really is. Okay,
where's, yes, I knew it was this one.
Do we assassinate him from above is my question? I don't know. I normally have three signals at
this point, which means I can do a raining down effect. Did he really say where did I go?
Great. Right, if I can ear assassinate him, this isn't a problem. If I can lock onto him,
I am very tall up to lock onto him though. No, wait, no, wait, lock onto him. Yeah? Uh-huh.
No. Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh, that was so good. Oh, and none of the guards want to defend. That's
hilarious. All the guards are like, that, that man just came out of the sky. We are not, we are
retreating right now. Does your room have per ventilation? That's horrendous ventilation.
Unfortunately, I'm renting. So I have like absolutely no input or like anything I could
really do about it. Rip in pepperoni. He craves the drop. Okay, I shouldn't get too distracted
because my tea's gonna get too cold and my fruit juice is gonna get too warm. I am going to ignite
the, gonna light this place up and then we're gone. Oh, you're edging me and not the good kind.
Are the windows open? No, the window's freaking broken.
Like the landlord has been really nice to me and he's like left me alone. It's not like one of
them annoying landlords that are like trying to like trail through your place all the time. But
obviously whenever you visit somewhere to rent and you like inspect it, you don't actually know
what's wrong with the place until you move in and like they're obviously, I discovered like
windows are broken, the hot and like cold, I don't know what the word is, is not like ideal.
Are you guys okay if I hide in this table whilst I drink my, oh, I forgot to shake my fruit juice.
Whoops, that's like real one of having fruit juice. I might just drink it real quick. I apologize.
Oh, that shit's so good. It's apple banana, lychee mango juice smoothing. So I'm getting all my
fruit in one drink because I don't really, I don't really eat fruit that often. I like
waste fruit, so I feel bad. Oh my god, it's mimosa, mimosa spotted.
Guys, you'll never guess who I arranged an ace marco club with this morning.
They've just showed up in chat.
It's very likely. That'll be my first official club with a VTuber. I've got DEMP on the list.
I'm hunting down everyone with 3DS. I'm serious about that goal. I'm arranging them all. We'll
make it nice and easy. Gonna be doing my best. So hopefully you guys eat good and you can sleep
to my soothing Scottish accent. That's right, wee laddie. Time to go to sleep. Are you tingling,
tingle, tingle, tingle. Oh my god, she must be so cool to be able to collab with you.
I should actually do like 4 Scots accent on an ace marco club. That would be hilarious.
I've almost finished my Juicy Just hypotenuse.
What should I eat first? Should I eat an egg? I think so.
I don't really like the idea of eggs sitting out too long.
To say something was delicious in Scots, you say it was braw and that was braw. That drink was
delicious. You keep mocking your accent. Oh, I don't think people find the Scottish accent
hot. I would say like hot accents like unironically like French Italian or normally like rated quite
highly. I have taken a bite of a meat stick. I apologize for anyone who doesn't like eating.
I need to eat. I want you to read Go The F to sleep in your accent. That'd be good.
Is Valley Girl scrawny real?
Hi guys. I'm so totally excited to be here. Yeah, I'm Valley Girl. I laugh at everything.
Yeah, that's the best you can. Yeah, you like that? Is that what you want? I'm scared.
I want to perish. Valley Girl scrawny. Say in it, brav. Can you do a Scottish Valley Girl?
No, I don't think so.
No, I don't think so. I didn't think so. No, my brain is like unable to compute what I need to do in
order to keep the accent, but make it different. Brain kind of. You're not hypnotizing us. Scottish
accents are hot. I'm eating the meat. I'm now baiting the egg. I'm just going to touch it.
I just said fucking delicious. I have earned, oh my god, a bite of the egg and the meat at the same
time. I have earned this, okay? I have earned this. As I almost choke on it, hey ho, there's a first
time for everything. It's like a pepper ramy if you're a British. I don't know what the equivalent
is in America or it's a twizy stick in Australia. Xio is literally, he's like, I need to rest. I've
been at this for hours. He's sleeping in the hay. Oh, my mouth opens when my mouth...
Ah, that's cool.
Like my mouth is closed right now, but because my mouth opens, well, yeah.
A slim gym, probably.
Would you like some sweet chili pea snack that's been baked?
Okay, open up.
Mm-hmm. I hope you guys stretched, because if you haven't stretched, that's you sat for six hours
and you're supposed to stretch. If anyone's in a wheelchair, you're exempt from these instructions.
Mm-hmm.
I stretched and all my limbs dislocated.
You're not going to fall for that one stare? Well, you're going to split, aren't you?
Ah, the stare.
Oh, my God. I don't know if I can read that out.
When is booty inspection day?
A faint sound of munching emanates from the car.
I've got sweet chili pea snacks that are baked. Two meat sticks and two eggs,
and I've got one meat and egg left, and I'm just munching on the peas.
Oh, my God. So for years, I had no idea what Charlie horse meant.
It's just called the pulled muscle, and I was like, what on earth is a Charlie horse?
Like, is this a famous horse named Charlie? Why is it happening to people? That's not possible.
I was like, it's crazy. And then I finally figured it out because I watched like a meme,
and the guy like fell over, and he was like, oh, oh, Charlie horse.
And like, because of his body language, my brain was like, oh, my God,
he's having a muscle spasm. That's what it means. Like,
oh, I need a burp. I'm so sorry. I'm eating, so it means I burp a lot. I'm jammy, if you don't like it.
I don't think a zero or mercy burp. I think they have manners and weren't raised in a barn like me.
I was named after Sir Charles of Horse.
Ooh, money. We've got 3,000 in the bank right now.
Some say that Charlie's still in pain to this day.
Was that a meme on Family Guy? I don't know what it was. No, those ones are the different ones.
I learned from Mercy the other day that saying be there, be square is because you won't be around.
Wait, what? Be there or be square is because you won't be around.
Oh, that's so smart. Like around in a circle. Yeah. And like, you won't be around in the area
if you're not there because you're a square. Yeah. Oh, I just got that too. That's good. I like that.
Mercy smart. Shawnee, it's not manners. It's your cuttlebone. You're just into buoyancy. Yes,
this is my first time on land. Sometimes.
I'm careful. You don't want to make me too smart. I'll start coming up with new names.
Fond de la Bism. I'm never going to live down Fond de la Bism and be sucky.
What marshmallow did you want to see Anthony specific? Oh, I didn't open up the marshmallows.
Well, we do it at the end of stream because we're actually really close to finishing the game.
Like, we're really close to finishing the game.
Alright, you better be scared of me cooking again.
I'm sorry, but I'm going to suck my fingers. I know some people don't like it
matter-wise, but I don't have a napkin. That remains me. I need to make the audio.
Okay. I inhaled the meat and the egg and then I finished my tea and then we're going to get
straight back and finish the stuff. I need like more charcuterie snack stuff for longer streams
because I don't have time to actually make food.
Maybe a cold pasta dish? I can pre-make.
The crunchy thing is the meat stick. It's got like a skin on it.
That's the meat.
I've got protein from the egg and protein from the meat and fats.
And the pea snacks are carbohydrates.
Yum yum yum. I'm going to get tons of hydration.
That's way too crunchy to be. It is meat. It is meat. I promise you it's meat.
It's like an outer skin, like a pepper ramy.
Okay, all the food is finished. I'm now for the tea.
Honestly, depending on how fast we go, we might actually finish the campaign in less than two
hours, but I'm quite happy to like fart about and do the Borgia Towers after.
Maybe like so we can like streamline tomorrow for doing the DNA sequence run.
I'm gonna let a big burp. I'm sorry.
That was good. Such good food. I really needed that and I hit the spot.
Mmm, a battered Mars four hand counts room. It's a honey tea.
Sorry, it all comes back up. I was going to record is tomorrow like your girlfriend for like
forgets to turn off the make. So it's just me munching and crunching because some people
like really enjoy like other people's like munching sounds. I'm like, if you are telling me that I can
order McDonald's and eat it on the mic and people would like be happy with that.
Like, uh, you don't got to tell me twice.
Shawnee, if you're looking for a snack that's easy to prepare, great.
I can't believe it. I can't believe you're telling me to eat healthy and look after myself.
Oh, cruel. Honey tea. You boil those per beat. No, I love to be. I get to buy my honey from like,
I like smaller shop and I like supporting them on their own.
I sip my tea. Oh, yeah. That's roasting. It's still quite warm. Not gonna lie. I thought it was
gonna cool. Be a bit cooler. I'm okay. I'm okay though. Right, we're gonna go and get our
wanted taken off of us. Put that on the Herald. Thank you very much. You're about to stand in
some serious matter. Chicken nuggies ASMR. There's eating 100 chicken nuggets. Still a challenge.
I feel like you starve me and I could probably do that like in one go.
Have I bought this bank over here? I haven't. Investments, people. Investments.
That reminds me several years ago back when Tumblr was an important platform that some vegans
actually thought bees were physical harm for their honey. Oh, vegans just doing their thing.
They're nice, I guess. I just, yeah, vegans are vegans. I completely understand like the stands
no one actually wants any animals to be hurt or all that jazz. I just, you know,
I ask have you ever seen a healthy looking vegan when they're like I've been vegan for five years?
They look ill. I had a close family member that was temporarily vegan for a couple of years
and when they finally started to eat meat again, they were like healthy overnight. I'm so sorry.
I apologize if anyone is a vegan here but please seriously take your supplements,
look at what you need to in order to get what you need because please be careful. It's very
dangerous. I don't, I'm actually being serious for like for one millisecond. It is incredibly
dangerous to genuinely choose to be a vegan and a lot of people don't realize until it's too late
that like you are, like if you really want to get into it, like there's the caveman times before
we discovered what cooking, what cooked meat could do for us and like it's like, you know,
once humans had access to cooked meat, the brain power of humans like went up. I can't
remember what all like the details and what it's called and all that but like this is what I've
been taught and like I genuinely believe it. I'm sorry but if you've ever looked at a vegan,
they just look like a husk of a human and I'm so sorry if it's offensive but like it's just my
opinion but I never said I was smart and my opinions don't reflect the agency. I'm sorry,
love you, bye. I'll stop talking. I'll stop talking. Okay, this border district, you have
to scale it from the rooftops. It is impossible. You have to do it via arrow storm. If you do not
do it via arrow storm, you're just like hurting yourself like it's so bad and you can get a
flag on the way so so literally drop down arrow storm instantly and just like that done.
Easiest, literally you don't even annoy any other guards that are in the vicinity. There is no one
on the rooftops as long as you have arrow storm unlocked which is what the um which is what the
three recruits so you need six previous Borja towers destroyed in order to get that but once
you've got it then you are you're smooth sailing through the game. If only Leafs had protein. Yes,
I know deeper green coloured vegetaibals are like really really good in general um what way
am I to go? That looks too big for me to yeah I don't have a glove yet. Okay this looks like the
way I need to go. Did anyone get their what is it what's that organ that blows up that was used
for grass eating? Like it literally kills you. I'll always forget the name of it. An appendix?
Did anyone get their appendixes removed? Did you get wrecked with your appendix?
Okay tea time. Rice and beans. I can cover you for the most. Yeah.
Yours burst? Oh you must have been deathly ill. If it bursts it can result in death
because it's just straight poison to your organs. Holy crap someone said my tonsils
they stole your tonsils. Give them back. I thought appendixes were for built. I thought appendix was
for when we used to eat like grass grass like back in the old day. I'm taking a sip of tea I'm gonna
try and finish out my my apologies. I hear gallbladder I'm scared my mum had a gallbladder issue
and so did my gran genetically I am predispositioned. Like one day on stream I'm just gonna start like
screaming and being like gallbladder gallbladder but uh hopefully that doesn't actually happen
but I can't say I'm the healthiest being around.
You can die of death did I say that? Yeah you can die of death.
I don't wish that pain. Wait you know how you know how you guys are guys? Um have you guys
ever passed the kidney stone? For anyone who drinks an energy drink have you passed the kidney
stone yes or no? I'm very interested in that I wanna know. Never maybe? Did you ever really
sort of pee pee at one time? We are not 100% what it is used for. These range from filtration
to breaking down fiber to appendix to a mystery organ. That's so cool. Like how do we not know?
We've got so much history. No. I hope I don't yeah it sucks. Oh.
I've heard stories from women that are like I've had a kidney stone and I've had a baby I'd rather
you know do the baby again and I'm like I see that's biology in play. Did you know
the brain actually tells women that their birth of their... Wait where the heck am I going?
Can I climb up here without the glove? I don't think I can climb up here without the
glove. Playing? No? Okay I can. I can. Jesus. I was like oh I've just missed out.
I love stronticolors and I heard her kidney stone perils. Oh my god. I do have peril. I have a
peril in a very special location. Hmm are you doing mersey? Are you streaming later?
Are you streaming and one hour, two hour, three hour mersey stream? Question mark.
I'm finishing my tea please pardon me.
I need a burp it's like stuck in my throat.
I have finished my tea.
Requiem. Requiem is the debate. Okay.
Is Azura... Is Mama Azu streaming the day? Wait where the heck am I to go?
Sounds like I need to go up here. Oh that's because I do need to go up here.
Only energy drink I've had is Calcius. Calessus? What? C-E-L. Calcius. Oh I got there in the end.
I got there in the end. You just gotta let me cook on some words okay? Some words are like huh?
Huh? And then you just gotta phonetically spell them out. Everyone is streaming right now aren't
oh my god overlapping corp I can't believe it. I literally tell everyone like go watch everyone
else's stream because I'm literally just sitting doing like an endurance eight hour stream type
thing. I'm just having a blast. But don't worry when you go live in Mersey I always recommend to
the girls please to go... No I always recommend to the brief links to give you a chance and check
you out. See we work because odds are I'm still gonna be streaming by the time you... Oh I wasn't
supposed to be discovered. Oh well so we over... It's fine we're doing it to... Look at that. Look at
that combat cam. Is that Azura live right now with that link? Or is that Imi? Or is that just
everyone's link all together? Silence discord mode. Oh you're not discord mode at all. YouTube mode.
I'm just kidding thank you for moderating for free I really appreciate it. Actually all the girls
really do appreciate it because it's kind of like one of those like jobs you know like the
silent unrecognized work but I actually genuinely like thank you to everyone who like applied to be
a mod and like thank you for everyone just being like cool at the mods and all that shiz.
Really appreciate that. But then again, silence mutual. With all that said and all due respect.
Oh I'm just getting spotted by everyone right Azura. We're just in a big fight. Oh no they have guns.
Calling the assassins. Calling the assassins. Okay I'm not dealing with them all you can kill them all.
I'm not dealing with them. Whoa they literally... Is he going to see me enter in the castle? I think
he might. I simply have all say you tell the girls to watch the girls. No I said it wrong.
I said it wrong. They do it for free. I mean literally Azura and Imi are Azura's online as well.
Oh if there are any Azura delay she is officially online as well if you're an Azura delay watcher.
I ordered a fresh batch of la cadore la last night. I'm just going to go and get you out of here.
But the pope has taken it all. Where is the pope? He meets with Cesare. Strange. He did not tell me Cesare
had returned. Imagine being a Mortarator. Imagine... Okay now what? Sorry I'm starting to lose that
little bit. I was like imagine being a Mortarator. Okay now what happens? Danny did anything else.
I'm imagining. With my mind only I'm imagining.
Okay I'm getting a bit delirious. I think it's like...
Bro I know I said this like yesterday. We were so delirious during that group collab.
But I'm so excited for our official like group game collab together. I hope you guys like the intro.
I'm gonna script it when we start up the streams. And literally everyone's gonna be streaming it.
So you can see all six POVs at once.
Oh I'm burping away. You've been at this for six hours? Honestly.
You come here so I can assassinate you. That's right come closer. I can sense thine penis.
Okay sorry I shouldn't have said that. I like that.
I ain't gonna actually do this. I'm starting to lose a little bit. But hey hope. Such a sleep.
Let's go. Oh I don't know why I said that. I'm remembering just like. Oh I'm notorious.
I didn't lure my notarite. Oh it sucks. I almost got caught. Well actually it doesn't matter if I
get caught by him. He doesn't come. How do you not see me? I'm literally on a bookcase.
Okay so. God he's so armored out the woods.
I have something on my mind. Like all I'm saying is that the marshmallows have been having a good
time on the marshmallows. Oh whoops I wasn't supposed to jump down here.
Oh I'm getting in trouble. I don't remember all these enemies being here. I'm gonna have
to remember like when I'm doing the like do not be detected. Like you put that away.
I literally did lead and I shot first get wrecked.
There's Tony big enough for the both of us. Cowboy. Oh I got 6000.
We're getting so near the end of the game. What has happened here? I do not know what you mean.
I want to take. I take. If I want you to die.
That's his dad.
What reason could I possibly have to kill him? Was he plotting against me with my brilliant
treacherous captain general? I do not have to stand for this. The assassins murdered him.
Why did you not stop them? As if I could. It was not my decision to attack Monteriggione.
It was yours. It is high time you took responsibilities for your actions.
My accomplishments. Despite the constant interference of failures like you.
You are not going anywhere. I have the peace. Out of my way old man.
Get out of my way old man. I gave you everything and yet it's never enough.
Chesere the intent to poison you.
You will not listen to reason. Father do you not see. I can kill all of this.
If I want to leave. I live. If I want to take. I take. And if I want you to die. You die.
I'm so good. It's so good. Where is the peace of Eden? Stop. I know where it is.
And you did not tell me he had taken it. Chesere. It's me. It's me. Your queen.
You are my sister. None more. Where is it? You never loved me. You never loved me.
Where is the apple? Tell me. Tell me.
Oh. Voice acting so good. Tell me. Tell me.
Oh. It's just so good. It's just so good. Thank you for letting me freaking share this game with you.
Fun fact. You actually don't need to like hurt any. Oh no. No. Go over it. Oh. It's it. Oh you're
giving me a heart attack. It's the oh. It's the oh. Little sister. I owe. I owe. I owe.
Fucking all of us have no heart. It's like. Do you see that? They're related. Yeah. It's based on
history. I could see. I know where that bastard is going. I know where that bastard is going.
San Pietro. The pavilion in the courtyard. The pavilion in the courtyard. Hmm.
Exit through the front gate. Wait. Am I still going to get attacked by guards? Oh. Oh. Wrong way.
Oopsies. You've just got such a big palace. I'll come back for you later. See you later.
I like this.
Asasino.
I will come for you. Later. Later. Come for you later.
I just like doing that.
I'll come back for you later. Later. I'll come back for you later. Yes, I will.
Who's a good refling? Have you been a good boy? Is it time for your daily milky-wilky?
Oopsies. Oopsies. Oopsies. Wait. He was in my way. Am I supposed to just ignore him? I think I am.
I will remember that for when we redo the mission. Spiral scape. Right. So that you can grab this box
because the timer don't start until now. You have to leg it for this entire next section. Okay.
You have to do it for the entire next day. Fucking let's go. Well, you're stuck in the cut scene.
Give it a second. Let it cook. Let it cook. Let's go.
Don't worry. Leave a faith. Leave a faith. Don't worry. Don't worry. Leave a faith.
Promise. Promise. Ta-da. See? It's right there. And then if you go in the street of the pavilion,
it's the easiest way to navigate to the place. Okay. And then you need to do the jump thing. Jump.
And then just take the main street all the way up to the pavilion and just jump every time you
see an agility at the bottom of your screen. You just jump and they can't get you. Jump. See?
The AI unclogs you. Jump. Jump. Jump. And then you'll be perfectly fine. Jump. Now you might
have to fight them at the end. I honestly don't understand what the development team actually
wanted from you at this point. Please leave me alone. But oh, he almost touched me. He touched
my ankle. Oh, he's touching me. He's touching me. Okay. And then they opened up. And then we just go
inside. And then sometimes you may have to come outside and fight, but it's okay. It's okay.
Okay. So we were... That's a lot of bad guys. Okay. We got one.
Oh, I'm getting ganged on. I'm getting ganged up. I don't like it. Take this. And this. And this.
And this. And this. Okay. Unfortunately, we are in range because of that yellow on the map,
but we might be able to stand here. It should time out because they're not supposed to actually
see us. There we go. There we go. Now, did you guys remember the pineapple? Did you remember the
pineapple? We did a little eagle vision. The pineapple is glowing.
I was right there. What? I was there all along. Excuse me.
Hydration.
That... Those armor clinking sounds. Good sound effect.
Gods! Gods! Oh, Chesery. Your time can't last. Not while I come in with the apple. Okay. So,
basically, just run. Wait, hold on. Let me open the map. Sorry to bring down the energy. I need
to open the map because I always forget which direction I need to go in. So I need to keep
going dead ahead and then take a right. Okay, let's go. It is just a waste of time trying to stop and
get rid of all these enemies. There's no point. So just outrun them until you get to the water
and swim like your life depends on it. They keep... They're jumping me. Get off. Get off.
Away. Naughty. No. If you follow this street, I think it takes you to the water.
Oh, I don't like those brute guys. They're actually pretty strong.
When the moon hits your high like a big pizza pie, that's a mooring.
And that's how you get away from that sequence. Jump on that boat and get out of there. You
do not have to attack anyone. You do not have to eliminate any enemies. Jump in that boat and you
are safe. Over and thank you.
When the moon hits your eye, that's a straw knee.
My men were to throw the zithi, but we might be the naughty. We am one.
It's blinding. Oh, my model's not reactive to what happens on screen. I need to put that back on.
I love that. That was like the funniest thing.
And my eyes. We do have no variety. A sight to see us known.
Flashbang.
I think for the loser guards and touch the pineapple without heart and I know you just
pop a smoke bomb and get in a crowded bench. I wonder that may be the solution.
At once. I do not care how. We cannot on our own, you must help us. I am here. Idiot. Idiot.
And then you will see how quickly the asasini fall.
Oh, right. So the apple is a bit funny. Do you see that white one? That white line means imminent death.
The yellow means under my control.
And so we want to basically the apple will take your health. So I have to wait until it restores
and then wait. And then it kills the people who we want to kill. And then the others are either
under my control or will fight for me. It's a bit finicky, but once you learn it, you get it.
We're teleporting all over the map. We're at the blooming
rose. Yes. Under stress.
Any anyone else under stress? Anyone feeling about A.K. needing a bit of a
I'm not gonna say it's too easy. Too easy.
So the point of Assassin's Creed is to get rid of the apples of Eden. However,
Ezio is a good, good boy and his DNA communes with the apple. So his bloodline
kind of has been chosen. I'm pretty sure the guy's around this corner, actually,
and I've gone too far. Yeah, there is.
Fail at the cardinal. I think he just runs down this hill and then that's it. You do not have
our access to your recruits at this time, but you don't need it because you literally have the
apple of Eden. I will say one thing. The more, oh no, actually, it doesn't affect with the more
armor you have. Also, on the weapon wheel, you can't select anything when you hold the apple of Eden.
I won't even let you take it out.
Take anything.
So we just need to follow him into the Colosseum.
Fuck it. No, no, I'm not here. No, no, you didn't see me. No, you're actually a liar.
And I, oh, you guards just spawned in. Don't lie. You just spawned in right in front of me.
Is it safe?
My bikini affairs have been mentioned enough. I've unbinded everything,
so there's no chance of accident or bikini show. I apologize.
Borgia? Mind Control Apple?
Okay, again, same thing. Unfortunately, this is very awkward and you can call in your recruits,
but it's not very good at all. I'm trying. Okay, this isn't working.
Wait, he attacked me and he died? Did you see that? Right, I'm just calling in my recruits.
They're not very strong, but we'll try. We'll try. I don't normally like doing it because
recruits can definitely die at this section because of the overwhelming amount of enemies
that come in. But again, white mark around who you would wish to eliminate right off the bat,
and hopefully my assassin recruits stay around. So he's coming straight for me,
so once I've healed up again, you just need to do the white. You can also see the white line
on their, the horse knocked him out of range, so we'll need to try that one again.
So they're now fighting each other actually. But again, white line, I got him. Yeah,
I see my assassin recruits are getting damaged on their health. I really do not enjoy calling them
in on this mission. It is dangerous. You can lose recruits here. If they're not leveled up enough,
I really did not spend much. Where's the apple? Whoa, he's like slow mo getting me. Okay, we've got
two more to go, two more to go. Let him get up, let him get up. We'll go for him first because you
actually, no, we won't because my assassin recruit just did that. Oh, someone's low, not good, not
good. This is why I really don't want anyone to perish. Did he survive? I didn't get a notification
saying that one passed away. I think we don't know. I know very much of an ASMR enjoyer, but
Amy changed your mind. That's fantastic. You just got to find someone that fits your groove and they
can interest you into something new. Johnny, Miss Ma, how are you doing? Have you been good?
We played assassin's recruit up in this house. We're literally about to finish the game after an
amazing gaming session. You can ignore the guards here. The campaign should take over once you approach
these guards here. So very good. Another time here. Did you stream today? Or have you streamed yet?
Or are you taking break today?
At least ASMR was great at Dozed off. That's fun to have.
So now we get our cool Avengers moment where everyone's with us helping us.
You can actually successfully kill all everyone in the sequence. Oh, I can't use my blades. I'm so
used to using them. You're still playing? Absolutely. We're just about to finish the campaign. I'm so
excited. Oh no, that recruit is so low. Oh, I feel like I need to help him. Oh no. Okay, okay, good
catch, good catch. Oh no, that. Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm dead. I only have one HP. Oh, I needed to regen. No, I don't want any assassins to fall.
Stop attacking her. Stop. I don't have health to freaking use the apple.
Please gang up on him. Thank you. My goodness. Oh, no. Oh, please. Okay, yellow. Oh, someone's
going to pass away. I don't want anyone to pass away. Okay, so we've just finished that. Oh, no one
perished. Oh, wait, that was so lucky. So we've now finished the sequence and we're all waiting.
All five of us avenger style.
On your arm, Cezare Borgia, the Coletus troops must behind me. We will take back my city once and for
all. This is not your city anymore. By order of Pope Julius II, I arrested Cezare Borgia for the crimes
of murder, betrayal, and incest. No, no, no, no, this is not how it ends. James will not hold me.
I will not die by the hands of man.
Was the manner in which he said it. James will not hold me.
Didn't know that was a crime back then. Honestly, true question marks because all we hear about blood
lines is, uh, you know, about royals and that. So was it like royals are allowed to do it, but
the common people aren't allowed to do it, you know, as peasants?
I must go.
I need to leave. My people need me.
I built this brotherhood to last with or without me. What do you intend to do? Plant a seed.
This is goodbye. Then keep your money. I do not want it. We will see each other again. You have my
good luck. Take the money. Your meager salary. You will need it.
My patron has been arrested after all. You've got a lot for tuna. Oops.
There was a limit. Cousins and relatives seemed, okay, direct bloodline off.
Yeah. Oh, why is my tracking, is my, why is my tracking stopped? Hello?
Uh, uh, uh, is my PC dead or is it just my tracking has gave up?
Hey, you want to recalibrate real quick?
Uh, uh, uh, I need to play, but my thing is not working. Woo. Hello? No, it's not. I have my
iPhone on fire. Oh, my iPhone is burning. Uh, let me just pause that real quick. Oh,
did you see all of them? Uh, oh, okay, hold on. Uh, that, am I back up to sync? Okay. Uh,
just yeah. It's like in so fast there. Oh, oh, then a cannonball should appear. Yeah,
there you go. Cannonball and it got me as well. My iPhone's on fire.
Hidden blade only. Let's go. I'm a hidden blade. Some people enjoy the source. Some people
enjoy the heavy weaponry. Uh, a double assassin blade for me. I died there. I better not have died.
The phone's about to explode honestly. I hope not, but it's very hot. I think because it's charged,
like I've charged it, um, this entire time. Like it's got charger input, so.
Oh, the iPhone better get used to it. Uh, you better not be, uh, better raise the stamina levels for me.
Mm. The cinematic, uh, like when it does, like, the cinematic kill, it looks so nice on, like,
all the different weaponry. I have to admit. So, like, obviously not mad if someone prepares
something else. Not the whole. Oh, wait, no, I lied. I lied. I thought all the horsies got. No!
I completely forgot. I thought all the horsies got back up. Why would they do that at the end of the
game? Assume I'm allowed to be spotted. Doesn't matter if I get spotted or is this one of the
ones where I shouldn't be spotted? No, I can be spotted. That's absolutely fine with me.
Ooh, but they're heavy. Heavy infantry. I'm trying to say they're heavy infantry. Right,
doesn't matter if I get spotted, so I'm just going to send it. Oh, I can't believe I forgot
about that horsey-warcy. I do apologize. I don't like when they do that. He's just taken an app.
He's just taken an app. I mean, I'd take one too. You know, he needs to sleep it off. He needs to sleep
off what happened. No, you've not seen me before, unless you know it's the only time.
The battery swelled up? Who are you doing? I left my Android phone on charge for a year and the
battery swelled, like, like, popped like a balloon-type swell? It's as dangerous.
Honestly, pretty brutal scene.
Huh. Leave me alone.
Unfortunately for this section, both factions will target you.
So the best advice really is to go at the checkpoint and destroy whoever goes for you.
Um, they will always sign, but you can't progress until they leave you alone. So
just, I can't actually see what's going on, but thank you. Okay, there you go. You just need to
wait for them to leave you alone. You need to water my battery. Make sure it's not too cool.
Yes, so the smartest thing to do is to claim the burning siege tower. You're so smart. The
wooden flammable siege tower. I'm not sure about that one, Enzo. I like your accent. Thanks, Spondyn with it.
Spacey phone pillow keeps your pillow nice and warm.
Do we need to take the rooftops? I actually...
Well, that was a lot of enemies to appear on the screen. This section is the same,
where both factions will target you. You need to become anonymous. Can I hide behind this and
be left alone? Oh, is he gonna attack me?
Okay, okay. I was trying to see if I can get away with it. It's just a bit like, why would they both
randomly target me? I have no fight with them? But I don't even know who they're. They're fighting
each other and they're the same. They have the same uniform on. They found the traitor.
I know what's wrong when I'm going to guess. Leave me alone.
Right, let's try again. This time, it's not on fire.
My world's on fire. How about yours?
The water's getting warm, so you might as well swim. I don't know the words. I can never remember
words. I can never remember words in order of actual songs. And then the best I can do is go,
the back streets. Hey, never go on. What you gonna say? What you gonna do? That's not the word.
Hey now, you're an assassin. Get your game on. Go play Caesar's gonna. His name's not Caesar.
Chasery's gonna die. Kicking in the balls. Oh, dear. Hey. That's right, baby.
So much to kill, so much to do, so much assassinating. On the spreadsheets,
never know when I'm gonna strike. Hey, don't know if it's good advice. Hey, so much to
pew, so much to do. Gotta disarm the guard. I can't do that, so that's fine. I'm taking out the double
knife. Trying to pistol whip. Try again with the tip. It's actually much easier just to shoot
Chasery. There, if you shoot him, you take a health bar.
And removing his armor. He wishes he was a farmer. Oh, he got me first.
You can't spam it. No, run at a time. He broke the armor. Oh, that's not good. Oh, that's not good.
Okay, I actually don't want that. I'm taking out my double blades.
Take this. Take that. And this. And take my knee to your boss. My knee to your boss.
Denny, wanna put my boss on your jaws. It's my knee. Oh, shit. Right. I'm actually
kind of messing this up. I may need to try hard. Hold on. Hold on. Let me get rid of these guards
first and then go for Chasery. But then, whoa, wait, wait, wait. You can't keep spawning new guards.
I mean, maybe you can, but like, you shouldn't. You should give me a chance to kill. Oh,
we're getting a bit crowded. We're getting a bit crowded in here. There aren't too many of yous.
This is starting to get a bit, he's gonna, can I do this? Okay, Chasery is, that's fine.
I expected that. Okay, Chasery's like one. Seriously, he's like one. Okay.
One more. Reload faster. Okay, there we go.
Actually, how much Nick armor do you have?
The throne was mine. Wanting something does not make it your right.
I love your mother, babe. That the true leader empowers the people he rules.
I will lead mankind into a new world.
No man can murder me. Then I leave you in the hands of fate.
The throne was mine.
What do you know? What do you know?
Get dunked on. I will lead mankind into a new world.
We take it literally in these parts.
You cannot kill me. No man can murder me.
The apple.
The vault. Oh my god, we're playing Borderlands 2. It's the vault.
So Ezio has put the apple of Eden away and the vault left behind by the gods.
So it's not in the hands of man.
We've got it. We're about to go to present day.
Gravity cleaves another victim. Full damage buff.
Perfect recall.
Oh my god. It's gold.
It's kind of why I'm saying it out now. I'll be quiet. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I'm getting too excited.
Like that European power grid. Ah yes, Italy. The only country in Europe you've got.
Problem is he's dead.
I can't believe we're stuck here.
A few cutscenes up ahead so I'll try and be quiet. I'm just getting so excited.
So I do apologize for talking over like so.
I'm just a bit of a silly belly.
Hey, maybe it has something to do with this.
A symbol matches the one on the door to the vault.
1419, 1420, 1421. What if they aren't dates?
1419, 1420. Oh my god. What?
God. Tell us already.
I am. I am. The tetragrammaton. The 72 names of God. You see?
They're all contained within three verses. Exodus 19 through 21.
And to get this your likeness, if you arrange the four Hebrew letters in God's name within
an equilateral triangle, their numerical values add up to the same number. 72.
Are you absolutely sure about this?
That's kind of why I'm saying it out loud, Rebecca. Yeah.
But I haven't lost the kicker yet.
Construction on the Colosseum began in the year 72.
I think we have our password. Sean, go get the van.
We now know the password to the vault in order to get the apple of Eden.
I'm a Calibri again. Hold on.
Okay. I calibrated. No, my my friend.
You know everything. I really like this game.
That's right. I've seen your car.
Base the Assassin's Creed said women bad driver.
That's terrible. Dev team, you know exactly what you're doing for nothing.
There's a lot of dialogue up ahead, so try and be quiet.
Lucy, I'm making my way toward the entrance.
Okay, good.
Can you see any gladiators? My advice would be like it.
I'll keep that in mind.
I can't believe I'm actually going to hold the apple.
It's been a long time coming. You've earned it.
I wonder if it'll change things, whether it can tip the scales in our favor.
Me trying not to read it like say every quote that I remember.
I was going to say tip the scales. I don't know if they might pick that up, but it's a little bit.
What do you think we'll find?
Hopefully a map of a temple.
The apple's just going to give it to us. Is it? Yeah? Who's Elvis over there?
Hey, maybe this time we'll be lucky.
On my first playthrough, I never found this for ages.
It's so slight and cheeky.
So much construction. This place is like a maze.
The hypergeum house, the cages of the gladiators, and the machines which raised them for the service.
The whole area you're in right now was originally covered by the arena.
Good to know.
So at the end of this, there's a quote from the gods.
And I said a message.
Oh wait, hold on.
My birthday! So that's why we're playing this game on my birthday.
Because it's October 10th in the present day!
Um, okay. If I don't move, the cutscene's not going to begin.
But I just want to say there's a quote from the god at the end of this.
And she says go forth.
And I may or may not have said be embraced by the six because of that quote.
And I hope you understand it when you hear it.
So be embraced by the six.
It's because it's all my love.
And the allure is the six.
Just wait for it, okay? Just wait for it.
I tell you, I tell you.
I show you, I show you.
But I hope the six have embraced you dearly.
Embrace those by the...
No! Set six! Number six!
Numero en dos tres, cuatro, cinco, cinco, seis.
I know it's kind of hard just...
...to keep his path forward.
I'd save the world we leave behind.
Who are you?
Jino.
Nothing.
We're getting close boys to the end.
I don't want it to end, but...
That's been a fan past the cleanest campaign.
Sorry, I went the wrong way.
Daphne, I know what we'd go through.
I'm getting really close to getting chills
because I know what's up ahead.
In the beginning, we set our truths to parchment.
To stone.
To the memory of men.
These proved impermanent things.
Oh, sorry, my mouth's open.
Lens by fire. Lens by famine. Lens by blood.
All the world is in this and all the more.
Innocent and ignorant.
Oh, cleansed by fire.
Cleansed by famine.
Such like, good dialogue.
Just to show that history cannot last on parchment.
Like, it's just such a genius.
Yeah, you think you found an entrance after the, like,
the freaking floor the pavilion opens up?
Okay, yeah, entrance, okay.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, I'm getting chills.
Let me in.
I'm coming.
But on what can it last?
Took you long enough.
What is this place?
What happens if it didn't have to last?
What if we just enjoyed every moment we could get?
I like the ceiling.
Dude, you like the ceiling?
You are a fascinating traveling companion.
Mm.
Look how detailed this is.
Like, 2010.
Like, look how accurate it is.
Please, can we do history games?
Where we can all just nerd about history
and, like, the things...
Like, they even bother to do the text and stuff,
like, under the paintings to be like,
this is from...
Like, ah!
Ah, it's such a good game!
Just appreciate everything.
It's so good, it's so good.
I'm so glad I get to share the game with you.
And hopefully you maybe play on your own sometime.
You have to experience all...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That guy is sassy.
Sean is a very sassy character.
A very British, uh, deadpan.
Wow.
Ready to speak to the gods?
And now they are our final, vaulted hope.
You are they.
Hey, actually, I'm a he-him?
Sorry.
You have the best understanding.
But you broke our tools, or turned them against one another.
We have destroyed what we could.
Sealed away what we could not.
This is...
Destroyed what we could.
Sealed away if not.
What?
Oh shit.
The time...
Time he roads us.
We can distract him.
We can see past him.
He ain't left when he strikes right.
But his reach is so very long.
He's stamina unending.
We cannot evade his grasp.
Not forever.
Wow.
Here goes.
So she's telling us why the gods perished.
Because something constantly is getting them.
Just like Stony Stamina.
Yeah, I'm refling you like that.
My stamina's unending.
It's a shame you have a refractory period.
It must come in with the blood of me.
I'm... I'm shone in this one.
I'm holding onto the little knob in the middle.
Oh, we're doing it.
If you want to kill us, mate,
you're going to have to try a little harder than that.
Wow.
We're here.
Music.
And just the beautiful scenery.
The details.
Statues.
Sean's right, that is.
I'm always right.
About that dead end.
That never happened.
I was misquoted.
Music picks up and you can hear the voices.
Oh, just ethereal sounding voices.
Just in awe and just awe.
This not the door.
Is it?
Am I being pranked?
Why does this look like the door?
I'm being pranked.
There's really a secret behind that.
That kind of looks like there may be a secret,
but maybe it's just a reused asset.
But all the music.
You think it speaks English?
Just say it.
Okay.
72.
Wow.
After you, I think.
Music.
Now you guys have to see this.
There's ethereal.
The apple seems to be in the center.
Time to find out where those temples are.
Okay, no.
This is where the sad part comes in,
because I always mess up the sequence.
I'm really.
Always mess up the sequence.
The orb.
Big lady.
Knowledge.
Oh, no, wisdom.
No, knowledge.
Sorry.
Wisdom, wisdom.
Oh, no.
Close enough.
Fake gamer.
You hear the words, but you do not know.
I have played this game so many times.
I always end up failing the levers.
I didn't know you could eagle sense the lever.
I just literally, my brain said maybe one's highlighted
and the other isn't.
How many times have I played this game
and never done that before?
I always mess up on the levers.
It is hard to stay contained.
Right, I'll be quiet.
Knowing as we do, we wait for you, Desmond.
You will come here.
You will activate it.
You will not be late.
Did you hear any of that?
I sure do love all my friends equally.
I love Rebecca.
I love Sean.
And I love Lucy.
And I'm sure all will be fine.
Wait, where did I go?
Oh.
So where are the temples?
You want me to ask it?
Or think it or something.
You sure you asked it the right thing?
I know this.
I know that symbol.
That, that's a Phrygian camp.
It stands for freedom.
And that, that's a Masonic eye.
Now those two come together in only one place.
What's happening?
I can't move.
Your DNA communes with the apple.
You have activated it.
Let me go.
On the 72nd day before the moment of awakening,
you, birth from our loins and the loins of our enemies.
The end and the beginning, who we abhor and honor.
The final journey commences.
There is one who would accompany you through the gate.
She lies not within our sight.
The cross darkens the horizon.
Shhh.
What are you doing?
The path must be opened.
You cannot escape or part in this.
The scales shall be balanced.
Name the map.
Stop.
Please.
You know very little.
We must guide you.
Oh.
The Mason or struggle.
No.
It is done.
The way lies all before you.
Only she remains to be found.
Awaken the six.
Go.
Alone.
No.
Really don't like that.
For those of you who haven't played Assassin's Creed 2 and don't mind spoilers.
We were in Abstergo's headquarters.
And she broke us out because she was pretending to be a Templar.
She's actually an assassin.
And then we have just played Assassin's Creed Brotherhood.
Which is the sequel.
And she got identified as a double crossing agent twice over.
Which made no sense.
Because why would she break us out?
And if you want to know the real reason why Lucy is killed off in Exio's story.
Oh yeah sorry.
In Desmond's storyline.
Shit.
He's gone into shock.
Put him back in the machine.
It's the only way to fix this.
But the Animus did this to me.
Am I the expert or not?
Do it.
The reason why Lucy's character was killed off is because
she asked for like the revenue.
Not for like a payout for her voice.
But for the revenue split thing that they do.
I can never remember the word.
Like where you get like payouts constantly.
Like for your voice.
And royalties.
Yes royalties.
She knew she was onto something.
She was an Assassin's Creed 2.
Then she's in a second game.
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood.
And she said royalties.
And that end sequence was then created.
Because at no point do the gods speak of present day issues.
And if you listen to the gods words.
It was like you don't understand.
We need to teach you.
The gods should not interact with Desmond on that level.
Lore wise.
And because she wanted royalties killed her.
In plot.
And they said yeah well we don't need you anymore.
So thanks Ubisoft.
Absolutely destroyed Lucy's storyline.
And yeah I hope your shareholders are happy.
Because you ruin it for the people.
But other than that.
Other than that really annoying fact.
Otherwise incredibly good game.
Incredibly good game.
I elect to pretend that Lucy is still fully alive.
And acting as an Assassin.
And all of that.
So yeah.
Oh and the VA for Rosa passed away.
I didn't know that.
But yes.
That is the story of Assassin's Creed Brotherhood.
It's absolutely 10 out of 10 game experience.
If you ignore the very ending dialogue and occurrences.
But that was amazing game.
And I absolutely love Nerd and Abode.
I'm probably going to do the Borgia towers.
I don't think I'm ready to go off stream just yet.
So sorry for anyone who's perishing right now.
And their eyes are bulging out of their skull.
Because of how much they need to sleep right now.
I'm very sorry.
I'm really enjoying this game.
And yeah.
Are you still doing the second stream?
Yes.
So today I was to finish the campaign mode.
And tomorrow we're going to 100% this game.
Because I have never 100%ed this game before.
Always wanted to try.
Never did it.
I believe I may have 100%ed Assassin's Creed 2.
Achievement wise.
Which was like a nightmare trying to get all the feathers.
But we can talk about that when we play it.
On June.
June.
On October 8th.
I'll keep going.
I've got a couple more hours in me.
Oh yeah.
Damn.
You got the stamina in it.
Hmmmm.
Yes.
All the feathers took so long.
Schedule set for October.
So my birthday is October 10th.
Which is when I will do my donathon.
And for my birthday I would like to play Assassin's Creed Brotherhood all over again.
But I'm gonna play it utmost line.
So on the 8th of October Assassin's Creed 2 campaign.
then Assassin's Creed 2 again for 100% and then Brotherhood on the 10th and the 11th
and then on the 12th and the 13th would be Revelations and we will complete its use storyline.
I'm not very well versed in Revelations, I have played it a couple of times but I'm not as well
versed so I probably can't Japanese about the best strategies for the game.
Are you doing the strong new passive and you present it? I don't know, I've been looking at
some ASMR challenges like the 8 hour ASMR stream challenge, maybe I might consider that although
my voice breaks pretty quickly for ASMR and whispering is the most damaging thing I can do.
You should watch Embers after Revelations.
I would make a reminder for those days. I'll be posting my schedule like I've posted my schedule
for this week um after the needy streamer overload I think it's like a two hour game
question mark um I actually need to go and buy the American candy um and those European
sweets because I don't buy them and then I need to like clean my desk and stuff uh because I'm
doing a hand cam stream. Um Strani, if mummy goat is our mum are you the granny? Don't look into
the lore too much of how velour came to be. Technically there are five children birthed from
my loins. Whispering's bad for your voice but yes I may or may not need a really big pee now that I
have just been aware of my bladder. I just sat on my foot uh like against well you know against what
and then my brain was like oh by the way sensation I'm like ah yes yes I believe I need to pee.
Oh mother mary virgin birth uh no sorry it was the reeflings doing oopsies.
That is the marabout going wild that's all I'm saying. I don't know how we got it we didn't get
kicked out of that convention. So I am taking drinkies of water which flows this track and
then puts my hypnosis on. But yes we'll take a very quick pee break. Um I might make a second
cup uh well be my third cup of tea but my second that I'll drink on stream with you. Uh I just need
water and drink I actually don't need any food that those snacks really satiated me. I have been
satiated I thank you for letting me eat on stream. Stream elements is how we pitch child support.
Yeah I don't know what's going on. I unironically think you guys were given like so much money
collectively to the girls once the tip page was up that uh you guys broke the paypal uh
yeah. So thanks for giving us so much money that uh paypal is now investigating the account or
something I don't know. Uh but yeah if you want to support the girls you can always buy the merch
they get 100% of the earnings. None of it goes to the other and all the girls will uh say that they
own the ubu market uh accounts and all that they have logins and it's all their stuff we did not
touch it nothing to do with us. So yeah uh hopefully monetization on youtube stats
statistics uh update because my statistics were like yeah you have 80 watch hours and I'm like
are you sure about that? Are you sure youtube? Because I don't think so. All the merch is so
cute. I'm so excited for the keychain to arrive and I'll do tap tap tap play some more.
So dramatic. Unfortunately the credits go for a bit and they're unskippable but I do want to
special shout out to uh uh Alex Tremblay for the data manager. Shout out to Robert Mullen the
technical writer fantastic job. Thank you fire team lead uh Jocelyn Villix Nolan as if I can
say these names be real for real. This software contains adobe flash player software under
license from adobe systems incorporated corporation adobe adobe adobe adobe okay we get it.
Thank you Francis Page for your gear programming. Thank you Alexander Prich for your Oasis team.
Thank you Fabian Noel for your Oasis concert. Is it Oasis? Oasis? Is that team name? I must
be team name Oasis because I don't remember any Oasis in uh Roma. Thanks adobe. Don't worry
you'll reach the watchers someday. I literally already reached them and YouTube's like yeah
give me like seven to eight business days to update your stats because I can apply for
partnership uh monetization like right now. Well I should be able to but the stats don't say I have
the watch time but I do have the watch time so uh but hopefully we can get our monetization streams
and then you know all that. I have no idea how long this PayPal issue is gonna last but
you guys gave literally and ironically gave so much money that they can't burst.
I have like 10 watchers alone. I miss adobe flash player. Binding up Isaac started on it but I never
actually played it at that stage. I only played it like a couple moves back.
I like the enemies in this game as well. Have you like made them multiplayer enemies or like
uh
I like as well uh the plot line that love Volpe is so like I know it's you Nicolo I know it's you
and like all these things coincidentally happen at the same time. I like stories like that
because it's like no no you're wrong please but thank goodness we did the no swim part that was
awful grabbed a poor man's horse ran up a side of a building a few times and failed and then like
dived across this like bean of rope. Would you consider playing Binding of Isaac on stream?
Oh boy you're in for a treat. In November the uh official multiplayer for a Binding of Isaac
goes live and I would absolutely love to play with you guys. Um we will be streaming that game often
I am uh addicted to it. I've not before anyone asks have you done Dead God? No I've not done Dead
God. I currently am at like uh I think it's like 1,000 of 1% and it's stop that's where I'm at on
one fail. I have absolutely nothing on the two other save files but uh it definitely is going to be a
consistently multiplayer streamed game from bits like I'll do like 12 hour runs for the multiplayer
game of that week and then like we'll pick a different multiplayer game type thing um would you
be fantastic? Ooh Binding of Isaac is hardly it is a randomized kind of dungeon crawler but there's
a lot of interesting story in the background of it um I really enjoy it I actually want to make a
review on this game Assassin's Creed Brotherhood and as well as Binding of Isaac and Call of the
Lamb basically I want to make like real game reviews but only on games that I think are 10
out of 10 because I can't stop yapping about them and like bringing up like how flawless the uh in
rewarding like the gameplay is and how they've like done the tutorials or what aspects have just
really stood out like I just really like anything would be so nice to try it like um as much as we
all like to dog on like video game journalists and stuff like it is definitely uh thank you
please keep yapping I enjoy it if you like the Binding of Isaac I highly recommend Noeta I have
never heard of Noeta uh is it like Pixley like Isaac as well
from how you talking here would be awesome at giving some game reviews uh I've got it as a
donathon like reward it would take a lot of effort though like I definitely think after my
donathon is finished I'll probably have a few shorter games back to back and the reason for
that is because I'll be like working on rewards um I I literally want to like fire the rewards as
soon as possible like once it's done and like all of that um Noeta runs can go for hours oh Isaac
runs are like one hour sometimes if you get really good items and stuff you can be wrapped up in 30
minutes with Isaac um yeah start each review with a five-minute hypnosis section where you turn
your your hypnosis you will like this game that's so good you will like this game you will like this
game you will like this game have you considered collab of girls playing battle ground three
what's bg oh no what's bg battleground why do I think battleground
boulder wait the boulders gate is multiplayer I've never played it
what did I've never played it I didn't realize it was multiplayer
big bouldies gate right so we have just done it we are officially goodness gravy we have a lot
money on our persons this is a bit more money than uh I think you actually need it so it's
given capitalism it's so it's given capitalism so put it back and invest in properties and stuff
I am going to send the birds away sorry I'm going to send the recruits away to level up a little bit
I'm going to do a peep I'm going to make a cup of tea so a three-minute break please
heavily recommend that you um you know get up walk around stretch your legs and do a little pp
as well um and we are going to do the borja towers next and then maybe possibly um
maybe some other miscellaneous stuff that's too strong I'm trying to find something that both of
those last two recruits can go on I mean I've got a oh you're not strong enough so I'll send you
on a mission on your own and then for level two I will send you on a level one mission because I
really don't want anyone to perish he I know you could go up on boulders gate that's so cool
um yes I will definitely look into boulders gate collab I would need to research the game before
I play because I really don't know what it's all about um okay I am going to go pee pee because
my bladder feels like it's about to burst I will tell you if it's neon or not don't worry before
anyone asks I can already read your mind uh but I'll do the thing where I uh I'll mute and then
put the game back on in the background and no one can see from me up here like that guy that
yanked that thing from me when I was away for like two seconds it's so good okay please consider
getting up and going for a pee pee and a leg stretch I will be back incredibly shortly hold on mute okay
I'll be back
you
.